PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT AND
RETIREMENT WILL COME TO ORDER.
GOOD MORNING IN RESPONSE TO THE
COVERT NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND IT HERE TO
SOCIAL DISTANCING AND FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THESE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WE
ARE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARINGS HERE IN THE CAPITAL
WITH SOME OF OUR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS PARTICIPATING REMOTELY
TODAY WE HAVE- TWO MEMBERS
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY SENATOR
MITCHELL AND SENATOR JACKSON
GOOD MORNING SENATOR MITCHELL
GOOD MORNING SENATOR JACKSON'S.
WE ALSO HAVE REPRESENTATIVES
FROM THE GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS
AGENCY EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT AND OTHER
GOVERNMENTAL ENTITIES WHO ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY. FROM A
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE
YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS
WILL GREATLY AID ELIMINATING
ANY ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. I S.
THAT EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO BE
RECOGNIZED THAT YOU USED TO
RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE IN THE
PROGRAM. EACH TIME YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO UN MUTE
PLEASE SELECT ON MUTE BEFORE
YOU BEGIN SPEAKING. R. I. T.
PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU BACK ON
MUTE WHEN YOU ARE DONE. ONCE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE
SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON THE
SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME AND THEN
YOU ARE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING
ROOMS TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW.
AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS EIGHT
FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE. SIX
THREE SIX FOUR. IN THE ACCESS
CODE IS. EIGHT TWO SIX TWO NINE
EIGHT LET ME REPEAT. EIGHT TWO
SIX TWO NINE EIGHT. FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
THE TELECONFERENCES TEAM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE AND
OR OR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. FOR
TODAY'S HEARING WE WILL BE
HEARING ALL OF THE ITEMS ON THE
AGENDA PRIOR TO TAKING ANY
PUBLIC COMMENT ONCE WE HAVE
HEARD ALL OF THE ITEMS ON THE
AGENDA. WE WILL HAVE ONE PUBLIC
COMMENT PERIOD FOR THOSE WHO
WISH TO COMMENT ON ANY ITEM
THAT IS ON OUR AGENDA TODAY.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU
MUST MUTE THE DEVICE YOU ARE
WATCHING. THE HEARING ON PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE. IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE TODAY. I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY. IN ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DISRUPTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IN AS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
WAIT TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS WHO
ARE JUST INTO THE NEW USE OF
ONLINE TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES.
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL AND
PATIENT SO ALL INTERESTED
PARTIES CAN BE HEARD. NOW I
WANT TO BEGIN- MY COMMENTS BY
ACKNOWLEDGING THE OBVIOUS. THIS
HEARING IS OCCURRING IN THE
MIDDLE OF A SOCIAL AND ECONOMIC
CATASTROPHE. BROUGHT ON BY
COVERT NINETEEN. THESE ARE
DIFFICULT TIMES. FOR THE SECOND
TIME IN TEN YEARS WE HAVE ASKED
BDD TO STEP UP IN THE MIDDLE OF
A ONCE IN A LIFETIME ECONOMIC
CRISIS. AND DELIVER YOU I
BENEFITS TO HUGE NUMBERS OF
UNEMPLOYED CALIFORNIANS. IN
MANY CASES AND IN THE FACE OF
NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE CIRCUMSTANCES
EDT HAS DONE. JUST THAT.
PROVIDING YOU AYE BENEFITS TO
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE IN
DESPERATE NEED. IT'S A
REMARKABLE FEAT AND I SALUTE
THE EMPLOYEES AND MANAGEMENT A
DVD WHO HAVE MADE IT HAPPEN.
YET I WOULD BE REMISS IF I DID
NOT KNOW THAT THIS HAS NOT BEEN
THE CASE FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS.
SOME CALIFORNIANS HAVE HAD
THEIR BENEFITS UNFAIRLY DELAYED
OR DENIED WHICH IS TOTALLY
UNACCEPTABLE. THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA ASKS MORE OF US.
TODAY WE ARE GOING TO HEAR FROM
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE KEY TO
IMPROVING OUR SYSTEM ENSURING
THAT NO OTHER CALIFORNIANS ARE
LEFT BEHIND. CIVICALLY WE WILL
HEAR FROM MEMBERS OF THE
GOVERNOR'S TASK FORCE WHO
RECENTLY MADE IMPORTANT
RECOMMENDATIONS TO IMPROVE ET
DES OPERATION. AND FOR ME D. D.
EMPLOYEES WHO ARE ON THE
FRONTLINE OF THE CRISIS AND
FINALLY FROM EDT STAFF WHO WILL
BE CENTRALLY INVOLVED IN THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE TASK
FORCE'S RECOMMENDATIONS. I
BELIEVE THAT THIS HEARING WILL
BE A VITAL AND SIGNIFICANT STEP
IN MOVING FORWARD WITH POLICIES
AND REFORMS THAT WILL ENSURE
THAT D. D. D. FULFILLS ITS
MISSION OF DELIVERING YOU AYE
BENEFITS IN A TIMELY AND
APPROPRIATE MANNER. TO BEFORE
WE BEGIN WITH OR SPEAKERS I
WOULD LIKE TO INVITE THE
PUBLIC. WANTED TO PARTICIPATE
TO CALL IN NOW. PLEASE DIAL
THIS TOLL FREE NUMBER THE ONE I
GAVE EARLIER WHICH IS EIGHT
FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOUR AND WHEN
PROMPTED PLEASE USE THIS ACCESS
CODE OF EIGHT TWO SIX TWO NINE
EIGHT- BEFORE WE HEAR FROM OUR
FIRST PRESENTER JUST WANTED TO
SAY I WATCHED THE ASSEMBLY.
HEARING LAST WEEK- CHAIRED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOPER AND- I
THOUGHT IT WAS AN EXTRAORDINARY
OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL OF US TO
LEARN SO MUCH ABOUT HOW- THE
EDT IS WORKING TODAY AND SOME
OF THE CHALLENGES THAT THEIR
FACE WITHIN THE PROBLEMS THAT
ARE- THOSE UNEMPLOYED IN
CALIFORNIA STRUGGLING WITH THAT
THERE WAS A GREAT HEARING
PROVIDING GREAT INFORMATION-
AND THIS HEARING TODAY IS KIND
OF A- THE NEXT STEP IN THAT
WE'RE WE'RE TRYING TO GO. AND
THE COVER THE AREAS THAT UP-
THAT WERE HIGHLIGHTED IN THAT
COMMITTEE AND ALSO THAT WE CAN
TO. MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE- THE
NEXT STEPS IN PLACE. TO LET
YOUR FROM OUR FIRST PRESENTER
BELONGED TO RICHARDSON
SECRETARY OF THE CALIFORNIA
GOVERNMENTAL OPERATIONS AGENCY
WELCOME SECRETARY RICHARDSON
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE TODAY
PRECIADO JR TESTIMONY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIRMAN SENATORS. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO APPEAR TODAY TO SHARE
INFORMATION ABOUT THE WORK THAT
WE DID AS THE STRIKE TEAM- AS
YOU KNOW THE STRIKE TEAM WAS
FORMED BY THE GOVERNOR TO MAKE
RIGHT. OF IMPROVE. THE
PROCESSING OF CLAIMS IN
MODERNIZING THE EIGHTY D. U. I.
CLAIM EXPERIENCE FOR THE
FUTURE. I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY
CO CHAIR THE STRIKE TEAM WITH
JENNIFER PARKER WELL KNOWN. WHO
IS AN EXPERT IN GOVERNMENT
SYSTEMS AND TECHNOLOGY. I TAKE
THIS OPPORTUNITY ON BEHALF OF
THE GOVERNOR AND I TO. TO THANK
HER FOR HER DEDICATION TO
IMPROVING GOVERNMENT AND THE
TIME SHE CONTRIBUTED AS A
CITIZEN OF CALIFORNIA TO HELP
MAKE THE UNEMPLOYMENT SYSTEM
BETTER. THE STRIKE TEAM ALSO
INCLUDED A NEW TOM WHO LEADS
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY AS WELL AS A DIET.
AT NIGHT HEAD OF THE OFFICE OF
DIGITAL INNOVATION WE WERE ALSO
SUPPORTED BY AN OUTSIDE EXPERT
TECHNOLOGY TEAM. WHO HELPED US
BETTER UNDERSTAND THE
TECHNOLOGY SYSTEMS AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY THE OPERATIONAL
PROCESSES WITH NET. AS
OUTSIDERS WE WERE NOT BURDENED
WITH THE RESPONSIBILITY OF
RUNNING THE PROGRAM DURING A
CRISIS. INCLUDING BRINGING UP
NEW FEDERAL PROGRAMS AIMED AT
PROVIDING RELIEF DURING THIS
PANDEMIC. SO FOR MOST OF AUGUST
WE MET WITH FRONTLINE ET DE
EMPLOYEES CLAIMANTS MANAGERS
LEADERSHIP STAFF AS WELL AS
MANY LEGISLATORS AND MEMBERS OF
YOUR STAFF TO BETTER UNDERSTAND
PERSPECTIVES ABOUT THE PROBLEMS
THAT EDG AND POTENTIAL
SOLUTIONS. THE TEAM VISITED
OFFICES AND SHUTTLE MANAGERS
AND STAFF AND SPOKE WITH
CLAIMANTS REVIEWED NOTICES
REVIEWED CALL CENTER DATA AND
LOOKED AT LIKE TRONIC AND MAIL
COMMUNICATIONS SENT BY
CLAIMANTS TO EDT. THE TEAM%
OBSERVED PHONE SESSIONS WITH
EIGHTY D. AND SERVICE CENTER
REPRESENTATIVES AND CLAIMANTS
TO EXPLORE WHERE BREAKDOWNS ARE
OCCURRING. MOST IMPORTANTLY THE
TEAM FOCUSED ON DATA AT EVERY
STEP WE USE DATA TO UNDERSTAND
THE PACE OF CLAIMS PROCESSING
TECHNICAL SYSTEMS AND WORK USE.
THE IT NEED VERIFICATION TOOL
RECOMMENDED BY THE TEAM HAS
BEEN INSTALLED AND IS MAKING IT
EASIER AND FASTER FOR CLAIMS TO
VERIFY THEIR IDENTITIES WHEN
FILING FOR UNEMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS. AS ANTICIPATED BY THE
STRIKE TEAM THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE TOOL HAS DRAMATICALLY
LOWERED MANUAL WORK AND IS
REDUCING TIME INTENSIVE
PROCESSING THAT HAS BEEN
REQUIRED TO VERIFY THE
IDENTITIES OF CLAIMANTS. I AM
VERY HAPPY THAT BOTH DIRECTORS
TONG AND PAT AND I ARE HERE
TODAY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE ABOUT THE
NEUTRALITY DAY. WE ALSO
RECOMMENDED OPERATIONAL CHANGES
AND A TWO WEEK RECESS TO
IMPROVE SYSTEMS TO SPEED THE
PROCESSING OF CLAIMS AND REDUCE
THE BACKLOG. AS YOU KNOW THAT
RESET ENDED A WEEK AGO MONDAY.
WE ALSO RECOMMENDED THAT EDT
MAKE IT EASIER TO USE YOU ARE
ONLINE BY MAKING YOU AYE ONLINE
AND ASSOCIATED TOOLS WORK
BETTER ON MOBILE DEVICES FOR
INCREASED EASE OF USE AND
INCREASED USER ERRORS AND DATA
ENTRY SINCE WE NOW KNOW THAT.
ERRORS CAN CAUSE DELAYS IN
CLAIMS PROCESSING. WITH THE
IMMEDIATE FIXES IN PLACE THE
STRIKE TEAM RECOMMENDED THAT
EDG USE DATA DRIVEN EFFORTS TO
PREVENT FRAUD AND ABANDON OLDER
PROCESSES THAT ARE NOT BASED ON
THE MONITOR TENDS TO DEFRAUD
EDIE'S PROGRAMS. BUILDING ON
THE RECENT IMPROVEMENTS AND
DOCUMENT UPLOAD. WE ARE
RECOMMENDING EDG MAKE IT EASIER
TO UPLOAD DOCUMENTS TO THEIR
SYSTEM USING MOBILE PHONES OR
COMPUTERS TO SWEET CLAIMANTS
ABILITY TO RESPOND TO REQUESTS
FOR FURTHER VALIDATION OF THEIR
CLAIMS. AND REDUCE THE MAIL
PROCESSING BURDEN ON EDT BEYOND
THOSE CRITICAL STEPS WE
RECOMMENDED ET DE SHOULD
REVISIT THE BENEFITS SYSTEM
MODERNIZATION PROJECT AND
REIMAGINE IT FOR THE FUTUREIN
WAYS THAT PRIORITIZE CLAIMANTS
NEEDS THIS EFFORT DONE IN
TANDEM WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY AND
THE OFFICE OF DIGITAL
INNOVATION SHOULD BEGIN
IMMEDIATELY. ONCE THE BACKLOG
HAS BEEN RESOLVED AS A PART OF
A BOLD CROSS DISCIPLINARY
MILITARIZATION EFFORT THAT
INCLUDES AN OVERHAUL OF
ADMINISTRATIVE ROLES AND
PROCESSES OPERATIONS AND
TECHNOLOGY WITH THE CENTRAL
FOCUS ON IMPROVING THE
EXPERIENCE OF THOSE FILING FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS. WE ALL
KNOW THAT THE COBIT NINETEEN
EPIDEMIC TRIGGERED AT EPIDEMIC
TRIGGERED AN UNPRECEDENTED
VOLUME OF CLAIMS THAT HAS
OVERWHELMED THE DEPARTMENT AND
ITS SYSTEMS. AT ITS CORE THE
DEPARTMENT HAS GROWN OVERLY
RELIANT ON A SINGLE GROUP OF
PEOPLE WHO MUST PERFORM HIGHLY
SPECIALIZED TASKS TO PERFORM
AND PROCESS CLAIMS. IN THE LONG
RUN THE DEPARTMENT MUST TAKE
STEPS TO SIMPLIFY THAT WORK BY
MODERNIZING THE PROGRAM
TOGETHER WITH THE NEW
TECHNOLOGY. FOR THIS REASON WE
HAVE RECOMMENDED THAT EDT
EXPLORE THEIR OPERATIONS AND
TECHNOLOGY AND BEGIN THOSE GOLD
CROSS DISCIPLINARY
MODERNIZATION INVOLVING AN
OVERHAUL OF ALL OF THEIR
SYSTEMS AGAIN AND THEIR
PROCESSES. I BELIEVE THE STRIKE
TEAM HAS HELPED EQUIP EDG
WATSON TWO NEW TOOLS AND NEW
APPROACHES THAT THEY ARE
EMBRACING AND IMPLEMENTING AS
WE SPEAK ENABLING YOU AS
LAWMAKERS ALONG WITH THE LABOR
AND WORKFORCE DEPARTMENT AGENCY
TO SUPPORT EIGHTY. MANY HARD
WORKING DEDICATED PUBLIC
SERVANTS HAVE LITERALLY WORKED
AROUND THE CLOCK IN RECENT
WEEKS TO BRING UP THESE
IMPORTANT CHANGES AT EDG AND
I'M EXTREMELY PROUD OF THE
WORK. ESPECIALLY THE WORK OF
THE EMPLOYEES EDG AND THEIR
HARD WORK TO SERVE CALIFORNIANS
AT THIS TIME. WITHIN MY AGENCY
THE GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS
AGENCY THE DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY AND THE OFFICE OF
DIGITAL INNOVATION WILL
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF OUR PRIMARY
RECOMMENDATIONS. THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO APPEAR
TODAY. THANK YOU SECRETARY
RICHARDSON- I APPRECIATE THAT
TESTIMONY AND- WE WILL LOOK
FORWARD TO SOME QUESTIONS- A
LITTLE LATER IN ARE HERE ND I
DIDN'T WELCOME SENATOR JACKSON
AND SENATOR- MITCHELL FROM
REMOTELY BUT I DID NOT WELCOME
OUR GOOD FRIEND AND OTHER GREAT
SENATOR FROM SACRAMENTO SENATOR
A RICHARD PAN WELCOME SENATOR
FAN AND- I KNOW YOU MAY HAVE A-
MEMBERS YOU MAY HAVE SOME.
OPENINGS SOME COMMENTS WOULD
PERHAPS WHEN WE GET TO THE
QUESTION PART OF THE HEARING.
AFTER THE FIRST PANEL IF YOU
ASK YOUR QUESTIONS YOU CAN MAKE
YOUR COMMENTS AT THAT TIME IF
THAT WORKS ALL RIGHT FOR YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- WILL NOW
MOVE TO THE SECOND THIRD
PRESENTER NEXT WE WILL HEAR
FROM AMY TONGS. STATE CHIEF
INFORMATION OFFICER AND
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY- AND- THEN WE WILL
HEAR FROM A FOOD PAT- PATTNAIK
DIRECTOR OF THE OFFICE OF
DIGITAL INNOVATION WELCOME
DIRECTORS AND- WE'LL BEGIN WITH
DIRECTOR TOM THANK YOU. WELCOME
CHAIR HILL AND MEMBER OF THE
COMMITTEE A PLEASURE TO BE
HERE- I AM HERE TO SUPPORT- AND
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU
MIGHT HAVE FROM THE PANEL. AND
AS THE SECRETARY TRISH AND HAS
MENTIONED WE HAVE THE PRIVILEGE
TO BE PART OF THE STRIKE TEAM.
TO PROVIDE ASSESSMENT AND
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR- EIGHTY TO
IMPLEMENT AND I WOULD DEFERRED
FOR THE COMMENTS- TO THE PANEL-
WHEN THE QUESTION ARISES. THANK
YOU. VERY GOOD THANK YOU- THEN
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO FROM THREE
D. D. D. EMPLOYEES THOSE
EMPLOYEES WHO ARE ON THE FRONT
LINES OF THIS CRISIS IRENE
GREEN CHOICE WHEELER POLAND'S
AND JOHN TAREQ. ON THE SCREEN
YOU WILL GO FIRST IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE. THANK YOU SO MUCH GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT
TODAY. I'M AT THE STATE OF MIND
IT WAS ARE YOU CRAZY AND I HAVE
BEEN IN A PLENTY OF THE EDT- AS
AN EMPLOYMENT PROGRAM OR VISIT
IN FLORIDA ELEVEN. YEARS A FEW
MONTHS- I'VE ALWAYS BEEN A
CROWD. PERSON TO BE FOR A TODAY
BECAUSE THE THAT I PROVIDE
ELIGIBLE KIND OF. WITH ABILITY.
TO PUT THE FOOD ON THEIR TABLE
TO KEEP A ROOF OVER THEIR
HEADS. INTO A SINCE THE JOB
SEARCH IN PLACEMENTS THAT IS
NEEDED- I WORK IS ALWAYS BEEN
ESSENTIAL. BUT THE DEMOCRATS
HIGHLIGHTED JUST HOW MUCH THOSE
OF US THAT WORK. AT EDT OUR
HEROES. IN ADDITION TO MY WORK
AND I DIFFER CAL. ARE ALSO A
PROUD MEMBER OF SEIU LOCAL ONE
THOUSAND. SO I WANTED TO TAKE
THE STRIKE TEAM FOR THE
RECOMMENDATIONS AND OF THE-
ADMINISTRATING ADMINISTRATION
KEEPS ME. FROM CREATING THE
STRIKE TEAM I ALSO WANT TO
THANK THE SENATE FOR ASKING US
TO SPEAK AT TODAY'S HEARING.
THE STATE DOESN'T TRADITIONALLY
REACH OUT I THINK THAT THIS WAS
A STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
I HOPE TO KEEP THIS DIALOGUE
GOING FORWARD AND HOPE THAT
THIS IS DONE MORE FREQUENTLY.
INVITED THE EDT A PLATE BY
COMMENT OF OUR EXPERIENCES.
WORKING AT THE EDT. THE DALLAS
ABOUT WHAT IT'S LIKE TO AT IT
DURING RECORD OF UNEMPLOYMENT.
MY COLLEAGUE JOYCE MILLER OMENS
WE'LL TALK ABOUT OUR WORK
ENVIRONMENT IN OUR PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT. TRAINING THAT'S
AVAILABLE TO US AND THE VALUE
OF OUR WORKERS VERSUS
CONTRACTING OUT. MY OTHER
COLLEAGUE JOHN TO WORK WELL
TALK ABOUT OUR WORK FLOW
TECHNOLOGY AND OPERATIONS AND
HOW BOTH ARE LIMITING OUR WORK.
AS YOU KNOW WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING TIRELESSLY TO ENSURE
UNEMPLOYMENT CALIFORNIA
UNEMPLOYED CALIFORNIANS SKEWS
ME GET THE BENEFITS THAT THEY-
NEED AND THAT THEY REQUIRE WE
UNDERSTAND THAT WITH A LIFELINE
FOR MANY- STRUGGLING
CALIFORNIANS AND THAT'S WHY
WE'RE WORKING AS HARD AS WE DO-
WE WENT FROM WORKING AN EIGHT
HOUR WORK DAY FIVE DAYS A WEEK.
TO WORKING SEVEN DAYS PER WEEK
UP TO FOURTEEN HOURS A DAY- YOU
KNOW AND THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
WE HAVE COMMITTED TO DOING NOT
BECAUSE IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
FEEL THAT WE HAVE TO DO
SOMETHING THAT WE FEEL WE NEED
TO DO. WE HAVE SACRIFICED OUR
HOLIDAYS WE SACRIFICE THE GAME
NIGHTS AND MOVIE NIGHTS WE
SACRIFICE FAMILY DINNERS. BUT
THIS HAS BEEN GOING ON SINCE
MARCH IS SAYING PEOPLE ARE
STRESSED IS REALLY JUST AN
UNDERSTATEMENT- IN ADDITION TO
THE INCREASED WORKLOAD WE FACE
CONSTANT PRESSURE FROM THE
MEDIA. AND EXASPERATED
FRUSTRATED CLAIMANTS. WE ARE
CONSTANTLY BEING TOLD THAT
WE'RE NOT PROCESSING CLAIMS
FASTER NOW. THAT WE DO NOT CARE.
AND I WANT TO SAY PRO THE I WAS
IN. FROM THE- ROSTER BACK
WITHIN THOUSAND WHEN RECESSION
STARTED. AND I HAVE FIRST HAND
KNOWLEDGE OF THE STRUGGLES THAT
IS AT THAT TIME BEING A SINGLE
MOTHER OF TWO SMALL CHILDREN.
TRY TO MAKE SURE THAT I KEPT A
ROOF OVER THEIR HEAD THAT I PUT
FOOD ON THEIR TABLE. AND THAT I
WAS ABLE TO PROVIDE FOR THEM
ALL THE WHILE TRYING TO FIND-
AN ABILITY TO FIND EMPLOYMENT
BECAUSE AT THE TIME I WAS
UNEMPLOYED. DURING THAT TIME I
ALSO BECAME HOMELESS- NOT MANY
PEOPLE KNOW THAT ABOUT ME- IN I
UNDERSTAND FIRST HAND HOW HARD
IT IS FOR THOSE THAT ARE GOING
THROUGH THIS TIME- HOW
EXTENSION. OF THESE BENEFITS
ARE TO THEM. SO OUR WORK CAN TO
EXCEED OUR NORMAL WORKLOAD YEAH
WE HAVE ABOUT TWO THOUSAND FOR
THE TRAINING STAFF BUT WE
EXPECT TO PERFORM AND I REALLY
UNREALISTIC LEVEL. BUT WE TRY
OUR HARDEST TO MEET EVERY
DEMAND THAT WE KNOW THAT WE
SHOULD IN EVERY CRITERION THAT
WE KNOW WE SHARE IN ORDER TO
MAKE SURE THAT CALIFORNIANS ARE
RECEIVING THE BENEFITS THAT
THEY SURVIVE YOU SHOULD BE
RECEIVING. WE ARE HOPEFUL THAT
THE RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE
STRIKE TEAM WILL MAKE OUR
WORKLOAD MORE MANAGEABLE- BUT
PLEASE KNOW THAT WE DO CARE- WE
ARE DOING EVERYTHING THAT WE
CAN. TO ENSURE THAT THE
CLAIMANTS GET. THE HELP THAT
THEY NEED. SO I AM GOING TO IT
OVER CHOICE WE LOVE ALL HAS GO
TO TALK A LITTLE BIT LIKE I
SPENT. OUR WORK PRODUCTIVITY
DEVICE IF YOU DON'T MIND. THANK
YOU THE SCREEN. THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR EMPLOYEES TO
STEP UP AND MAKE A COMMENT-
WHITE SAREEN I AM AN EMPLOYMENT
PROGRAM WRAPPED WITH THE
EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT IN THE UNEMPLOYMENT
DIVISION I HAVE BEEN WITH THE
DEPARTMENT THIRTEEN YEARS. AND
ALONG WITH MY CO WORKERS WE
TAKE THIS JOB EXTREMELY
SERIOUSLY- I'M ALSO AN SEIU
LOCAL ONE THOUSAND MEMBER. AND
WE REALLY APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TALK WITH THE
STRIKE TEAM TO ACTUALLY. HELP
THEM SEE SOME OF THE CHALLENGES
FROM THOSE OF US WHO ARE THE
FRONT LINE USERS AND WE REALLY
APPRECIATED BEING ABLE TO SPEAK
WITH THEM AND GET THAT
OPPORTUNITY. AS MISS IRENE SAID.
WE WANT TO TALK ABOUT THE WORK
PRODUCTION. TRAINING IN
PARTICULAR WHILE AS THEY SAID
THERE ARE LIMITED- LIMITED
NUMBER OF A SPECIALIZEDSTAFF
WHO ARE FULL TIME PERMANENT
EMPLOYEES WHO DO THIS. AND CARE
GREGORY DEAL ABOUT WHAT WE DO.
WE ALSO HAVE. ALL OF THE
LIMITED TERM EMPLOYEES AND
PERMANENT ADMIN STORE BEING
HIRED TO HELP SUPPLEMENT TO.
ADDRESS THIS HEAVY WORKLOAD WE
ALSO HAVE STAFF THAT WE HAVE
BORROWED. BAY DEPLETED AND
ROLAND HERE TO COME FORWARD
FROM OTHER DEPARTMENTS WITHIN.
THE STATE TO COME HELP US OUT.
FORTUNATELY BECAUSE THE RAMP UP
IS SO FAST. THE TRAINING IS A
VERY LIMITED TO BARE BONES
BASICS. WHAT YOU NEED TO GET ON
THE PHONE START TALKING TO
CLIENTS EDT IS ALSO HAD TO
SUBSIDIZE THAT WITH HIRING SOME
TEMPORARY WORKERS THROUGH IT A
SERVICE AND UNFORTUNATELY
BECAUSE THE RAMP UP IS SO FAST
THE TRAINING IS VIRTUAL. VERY
LITTLE INTERACTION WE HAVE
GRAVE CONCERNS ABOUT THE
CUSTOMER SERVICE BEING PROVIDED
BECAUSE IT'S NOT AT THE LEVEL
AT WHICH THE DEPARTMENT
TRADITIONALLY PROVIDES WHICH IS
CAUSING A LOT OF FRUSTRATION
CHALLENGES AND OPPORTUNITIES WE
HAVE A ONE PHONE PEOPLE WE HAVE
LEVEL TWO PEOPLE AND THEN YOU
GET TO THE SPECIALIZED
PERMANENT PERSONNEL. THE
LIMITED. CHALLENGING TRAINING
DOESN'T FULLY GIVE. ARE
TEMPORARY LIMITED TERM STAFF.
I'M REAL SUCCESS WITH OUR
CLIENTS AND IT PROVIDES A HUGE
DISSERVICE TO OUR CLIENTS
BECAUSE OF THE LACK OF
INFORMATION KNOWLEDGE THAT THEY
HAVE AND BY THE TIME THEY GET
THEIR HANDS ON A SPECIALIST
THEY ARE EXTREMELY ANGRY
FRUSTRATED CHALLENGED. BUT THEY
DO ACTUALLY APPRECIATE THE WORK
WE DID WHEN THEY ACTUALLY GET
HELP SO WE ARE PROUD TO BE ABLE
TO DO THAT. BUT THERE'S-
BECAUSE THIS IS SO
UNPRECEDENTED WE UNDERSTAND
IT'S A CHALLENGE TO DO THIS BUT
WE NEED TO WORK SMARTER. SO
THAT WE CAN BE BETTER FOR OUR
CLIENTS. WE ARE REALLY HOPING
AND APPRECIATE THAT THE STRIKE
TEAM RECOGNIZE THE SKILL LEVEL
THAT ARE PERMANENT FULL TIME
EMPLOYEES BRING TO THIS JOB.
AND THAT WE REALLY DO CARE BUT
WE ALSO RECOGNIZE THERE ARE
SOME. MARTYR WAYS TO DO
BUSINESS AND WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT THANK KNOWLEDGE
THE THINGS WE DO HOW WE DO THEM
AND HOW WE CAN IMPROVE THE
SITUATION. SO I AM VERY
THANKFUL FOR THAT. SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES AGAIN WITH OUR OUR
TEMP SERVICE- LIMITED TERM
PERSONNEL IS THEY AREN'T AS
DEDICATED TO THIS THIS ISN'T
JUST A JOB. WHEN YOU WORK AT
THIS IS A THIS IS A LIFESTYLE
AND A DEDICATION. THE THINGS WE
DEAL WITH THE PEOPLE WE TALKED
TO WE ARE OFTEN THEIR LIFELINE
IN A VERY BAD PLACE. ANISHA
HEARD MISS I MEAN SAY SHE KNOWS
FIRST HAND. WHERE THE PEOPLE
WHO HAVE TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE
AND WE ALL DO TRY. BUT WE ARE.
A DEPARTMENT WITH LOTS OF
CHALLENGES LOTS OF REGULATIONS
AND WE REALLY WOULD APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE A LITTLE
MORE STREAMLINED. THAT THE
STRIKING POINTED OUT WHICH WAS
WAS PHENOMENAL- I KNOW WITH.
RANK AND FILE WITH OUR
MANAGEMENT TEAM EVERYONE IS
STEPPING UP WE ALL WANT TO MAKE
THIS WORK AND WE WANT TO BE
MORE EFFICIENT FOR THESE
CLIENTS BECAUSE- A LOT OF THESE
PEOPLE ARE FAMILY THEIR
FRIENDS. THEIR THE PEOPLE WE
SEE EVERY DAY THEY'RE THE
PEOPLE WE SEE IN THE NEWS. WE
KNOW THEY HURT AND IT HURTS
WHEN WE CAN'T DO WHAT THEY NEED
US TO DO. SO A LOT OF THE
THINGS WE NEED WOULD BE
INCLUDING. AND AN EXPANSION OF
OUR I. T. TEAM SO THAT THEY
WOULD BE ABLE TO NOT ONLY BUILD
AND UTILIZE BUT MAINTAIN. OUR
I. T. NEEDS RIGHT NOW THEY'RE
SUCH A SMALL DEPARTMENT. THAT
DAY JUST GETTING PEOPLE TO LOG
INS THE THINGS WE NEED JUST TO
GET HIM ON THE PHONE. IS
SEVERELY. AND WE- REALLY WANT
TO SEE THAT CHANGE. AND IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT TO ALL OF US.
THAT WE DON'T MAKE THIS MISTAKE
AGAIN. AS AS MR CARE SAID. THIS
IS THE SECOND TIME WE'VE HAD
HISTORIC. CHALLENGES AND
OPPORTUNITIES. AND I REALLY
HOPE AT THE END OF THIS
OPPORTUNITY AND CHALLENGE THAT
WE COME OUT STRONGER SMARTER
AND BETTER PREPARED TO ACTUALLY
PROVIDE FOR CALIFORNIA WHICH IS
OUR NUMBER ONE PRIORITY. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I THINK WE GET ENOUGH. THE
TRUE SENSE OF THE STRUGGLES
THAT YOU'VE BEEN FACING AND MY
GOODNESS THAT THE WHEN YOU
THINK OF THE TIME AND I
REMEMBER WHEN- IT RIGHT IN THE
BEGINNING OF THE OF THE
PANDEMIC IN THE STRUGGLES THAT
THE EMPLOYEES WERE FACED WITH
AND THE TWELVE TWENTY FOUR
HOURS A DAY YOU KNOW THAT THE-
THE TWELVE HOURS A DAY THE
FOURTEEN HOURS A DAY SEVEN DAYS
A WEEK THE HOLIDAY WORK THAT-
THAT WE WERE BEING ADVISED ON
SO- JUST CAN'T TELL YOU HOW
GRATEFUL WE ARE FOR THAT HARD
WORK AND- CALIFORNIA AND ALSO.
THE OF THE FACT THAT OUR
DISTRICT OFFICES WHO AND I
THINK I SPEAK FOR ALL OF OUR
THE SENATORS THE CALLS THAT WE
ERE RECEIVING AND ALL OUR
STAFF MEMBERS WHO ARE TAKING
THESE CALLS AT HOME- AND THE
PAIN THAT THEY WERE FEELING AND
THE STRUGGLES AND THE- THE
SADNESS THE DEPRESSION THAT
THEY WERE GOING THROUGH.
LISTENING TO THESE THE STRESS
THE ANXIETY AND THE PAIN THAT
THESE THAT OUR CONSTITUENTS
WERE STRUGGLING WITH IN YOUR-
YOUR CONSTITUENTS WERE
STRUGGLING WITH- TRYING TO GET
RESOLUTION TO THEIR ISSUES AND
TO TRY TO GET THAT NECESSARY
BENEFITS IT'S SO IMPORTANT TO
THEM SO- WE- WE OFFER WERE
UNDERSTAND IT COMPLETELY WHAT
YOU WENT THROUGH AND- THE
STRUGGLES THAT YOU'RE STILL
GOING THROUGH WITH THAT BECAUSE
OUR- OUR EMPLOYEES AND STAFF
MEMBERS ARE FEELING IT AS WELL
SO THANK YOU. VERY MUCH ONE OUT
HERE FROM JOHN- TUROK
EMPLOYMENT PROGRAM
REPRESENTATIVE FROM. CAL EDT
COULD MORNING. MORNING MR. GOOD
MORE SANTA. AND G. DIRECTORS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR ALLOWING
US SEIU LOCAL ONE THOUSAND JUST
TO JUSTIFY. MY NAME IS JOHN
TAREQ I. LYMAN'S PROGRAM
REPRESENTATIVE ONLINE INSURANCE
PROJECT. I HAVE BEEN WE NEED TO
DO JUST OVER TEN YEARS IT'LL BE
ELEVEN IN JANUARY- I HAVE BEEN
IN A WORKSITE SHOP STEWARD IN
THE E. D. D. SAN FRANCISCO
BUILDING FOUR NINE WILL BE TEN
YEARS IN JANUARY- I AM.
GRATEFUL TO THE COMMITTEE ON
BOTH ENDS OF THE TASK FORCE
LISTENING TO US OUT FRONT LINE
WORKERS ARE. IN BECAUSE I THINK
WE GET WE HAVE A PERSPECTIVE OR
SHOP OR PERSPECTIVE THAT IS MAY
BE PARTICULARLY UNUSUAL
CREATIVE. I LIKE MISS IRENE AND
THAT SORT OF THING EDG SUCCESS
STORY IN MARCH AFTER I FILED MY
PHD AND STUDIES OF. HOW IN
DECEMBER TWO THOUSAND EIGHT I
WAS ON A FOR NINE BUCKS TO
SCREEN. I WENT TO THE WERE
FORCE ARE BRUNCH IN FOR WORK
AND THEY ME THEY. IS HIRING AND
I AM. I WAS A PROMINENT
INTERMITTENT FIVE AND A HOCKEY
AND THEN WAS CONVERTED. TO
PRIME FULL TIME WHAT I DO IS I
FILED PLANS OVER THE PHONE. AND
ALEK HONESTLY HI ON CERTAIN AND
TRY MOVE THINGS ALONG
COMPLAINTS QUITE. AND GENERALLY
ARE QUITE A LOT OF LA PAPER
PUSHING AS YOU CAN IMAGINE THIS
THAT WE HAVE. THAT HAVE
PREVIOUS UNITS ARE. GENERATES
AS YOU HAVE SEEN OF WORK I AND
WOULD HAVE BEEN MEANS OF HI
GLAD TO AT THE ONE OF
DEPARTMENT BECAUSE EVEN THE-
AND NEXT EMERGENCY COMP. AND TO
SOME DEGREE ON ONE AND IT'S IS
MORE DESIGNS STIMULATE THE
ECONOMY. THAN TO HELP WORKERS
IT DOES ACTUALLY HELP WORKERS
AT ONE EIGHT ONE ONE IS ABLE TO
MOVE SOMEONE'S GOING ALONG. AND
GET THEM PAID IT IS VERY VERY
BALLOTS ON SPECIALLY HAVING
BEEN THERE MYSELF. SO IN SOME
WAYS BECAUSE AS I UNDERSTAND IT
R. E. G. G. IS THE SECOND
LOWEST AGE AGENCY. AND STATE
SERVICE DMB IS NUMBER ONE IN
THAT REGARD- WE HIRE A LOT OF
PEOPLE AND KIND OF BECOMES LIKE
A GATEWAY JOHNSON TO THE STATE
CIVIL SERVANTS WE'VE HIRED
HUNDREDS AND HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE
IN THE TOWN I WAS STARTED
DURING LAST QUESTIONS MY SECOND
QUESTION. WORKING DURING THAT
TIME HE SAID THERE ARE A LOT OF
PEOPLE WHO GET TRAINED AND THEN
WE MOVE ON PRETTY QUICKLY TO
OTHERS A BETTER PAYING STATE
SERVICE OPTIONS. FOR OTHER
OPPORTUNITIES GENERAL. SHE
ANSWERED. IS A CHIU FOR. THE
AGENTS I THINK CHIU. KEEP
PEOPLE AROUND YOU ARE AND A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHAT DOING.
I'M I WAS CHARGED WITHOUT
GIVING AN EXAMPLE OF A OUR-
WORK ISSUE FROM THE SHOP FLOOR.
ONE OF THAT MY COLLEAGUES
MENTIONED DURING THE GOVERNMENT
OPERATIONS HEARING WAS AND I'LL
GET THE EXAMPLE IS. WE'RE
PROCESSING IT AND CLAIM. THE
CLAIMANT TRANSPOSES NUMBER
LET'S SAY THEY WERE BORN JULY
ONE NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX BUT
INSTEAD THEY WRITTEN DOWN
NINETEEN SIXTY SEVEN. SO THE
REQUEST WAS AND IS BACK IN THAT
SORT OF A SITUATION WE SHOULD
BE ALLOWED TO CALL OUT AND
CLARIFIED THAT THEY MATCH
NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX NOT
NINETEEN SIXTY SEVEN RATHER
THAN SENDING ITS TO ART ARE. OF
THE IDENTITY VERIFICATION
PROCESS WHICH I'M SURE YOU HAVE
A LARGE- IS IT HAS BEEN ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT IS REALLY BEEN
HOLDING UP. A LOT OF POINTS- AS
I SAID I AM GLAD TO BE WORKING
WITH YOU D. D. WITH MY
COLLEAGUES- HANDS TO BE HELPING
CALIFORNIANS ARE AND ONE OF THE
PEOPLE WHO WORKS. TWELVE HOURS
A DAY SIX SOMETIMES SEVEN DAYS
A WEEK- BLESSED TO BE ABLE TO
DO THAT- BUT I ALSO DON'T. WANT
TO AVOID- THIS. DYING OF THE
WORK ON THE JOB SO I DO TRY TO
THE BEST OF ACCOUNTS. THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK WITH YOU. AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO ANY QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TARGET
THERE WILL BE QUESTIONS AND-
APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE WITH
US TODAY AND FOR YOUR GOOD
WORK- WILL NOW GO BACK IF WE
COULD TO THE FIRST PANEL AND-
DI<c.cyan> PATTNAIK DIRECTOR OFFICE</c>
OF DIGITAL INFORMATION IS NOW
WITH US AND WE COULD HEAR THAT
TESTIMONY AND I'M SURE THERE
WILL BE QUESTIONS AFTER FOUR.
OF THEM AS WELL SO. PLEASE
PIANIST FABRIC. WELL THANKS
VERY MUCH AND- ESPECIALLY TO
YOU- MISTER CHAIRED HAVING BEEN
ONE OF YOUR CONSTITUENTS FOR A
LONG TIME IT'S NICE TO SEE YOU
TODAY AND THE REST OF ALL OF
YOU WHO ARE ON FOR TODAY'S
HEARING THESE IMPORTANT ISSUES
IN THIS AN IMPORTANT TIME- THAT
WE'RE GOING THROUGH RIGHT NOW
I'LL KEEP MY REMARKS RATHER
BRIEF AND THEN BE AVAILABLE FOR
QUESTIONS AFTERWARDS I WOULD
LIKE TO ECHO A COUPLE OF THINGS
ONE THAT THE WORK THAT THE
FRONTLINE STAFF IS DOING IT HE
DID HE- IS THE MOST IMPORTANT
WORK THAT'S BEING DONE RIGHT
NOW AND- I THINK I. SPEAK FOR
THE ENTIRE STRIKE TEAM WHEN I
SAY THAT THE IDEAS DE DE HOPE
AND THE SENSE OF COMMITMENT TO
THAT WE GOT FROM TALKING WITH
ALL OF THEM WAS CRITICAL TO
HELP US FRAME OVER THE RIGHT
CHALLENGES OVER THE PROBLEMS
THAT WE NEED TO FOCUS ON AND
WE'RE DEEPLY THANKFUL FOR MR
TURAKI AND THIS WE WERE IN
STANDARD SCREEN FOR REALLY
PROVIDING A LOT OF CREEKS-
ADVICE INTERACTION ABOUT WHAT
FRONTLINE STAFF ARE FACING SO
THANK YOU FOR THAT OPPORTUNITY
AS WELL HI YOU WILL HEAR FROM.
YOU DD AND YOU'LL HEAR FROM
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE STRIKE HIM
AS WE'RE GOING THROUGH- THAT
THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT CHANGES
TO BE ADDRESSED BUT WE'RE
OPTIMISTIC AND CONFIDENT THAT
WE CAN MAKE THOSE HAPPEN AND
LOOK FOR TO THE REST OF THE
DISCUSSIONS TODAY THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THERE
ARE I KNOW I HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS IMPROVE MEMBERS OF
THE- COMMITTEE HAVE THEM AS AS
WELL THAT WE. CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF EXTERNAL AFFAIRS
LEGISLATION AND POLICY AT EDT.
S. FERRIS PLEASE MORNING
MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR ASKING
ME TO BE HERE TODAY MY NAME IS
NANCY VARIOUS AND I'M THE CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF EXTERNAL
AFFAIRS LEGISLATION AND POLICY
AT EDT UNDER MY PURVIEW ARE
FIVE BRANCHES ADMINISTRATION
LEGAL LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS
PUBLIC POLICY AND THE POLICY
ACCOUNTABILITY AND COMPLIANCE
BRANCH TO MOVE BEYOND ALL THAT
I ENVISION THIS POSITION AS ONE
WHERE I WORK WITH THE
LEGISLATURE THE EMPLOYEES AT
EDT. INQUIRES STAKEHOLDERS AND
OF COURSE THE ADMINISTRATION TO
MAKE IMMEDIATE PLACE THAT IS
MORE PEOPLE CENTER TAKING INTO
CONSIDERATION THEIR NEEDS AND
EXPERIENCES DURING A VERY
STRESSFUL TIME FOR THEM AND
THEIR FAMILIES I WANT YOU NEED
TO BE KNOWN AS THE AGENCY THAT
HELPS CALIFORNIANS IN NEED TO
GET THE RESOURCES AND BENEFITS
THAT THEY'RE ENTITLED TO YOU
QUICKLY AND WITH EMPATHY. I
KNOW THE FOCUS IN THIS MOMENT
IS ON UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
BENEFITS BUT HOLISTICALLY
SPEAKING THERE ARE OTHER AREAS
THAT DESERVE ATTENTION AS WELL
STATE DISABILITY INSURANCE
WORKFORCE SERVICES PAID FAMILY
LEAVE AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH
TO THE SENATORS HERE ESPECIALLY
SENATOR JACKSON FOR YOUR HARD
WORK TO GET YOUR EXPANSION BILL
TO THE GOVERNOR'S DESK AND SIGN
THIS YEAR. WE THINK WE NEED TO
LOOK AT HOW THE PROGRAMS ARE
INTERCONNECTED AND NOT
NECESSARILY. SEPARATE AND APART
FROM ONE ANOTHER. I HAVE BEEN
EDITED NOW FOR THREE. RIGHT
AFTER THE DESTROY TEAM WORK WAS
FOR. PRIOR TO THAT MANY OF YOU
KNOW I WAS AT SEIU LOCAL ONE
THOUSAND REPRESENTING THE VERY
EMPLOYEES THAT WORK AT EDT THAT
WERE ON THE PREVIOUS PANEL THAT
JUST SPOKE. I CANNOT EMPHASIZE
ENOUGH HOW IMPORTANT IT IS. TO
NOT ONLY HEAR WHAT THE
EMPLOYEES HAVE TO SAY BUT TO
REALLY LISTEN TO ME THOUGHTFUL
ABOUT WHAT THEY'RE HEARING IN
THE DAY TO DAY OPERATIONS.
THEIR INSIGHT IS ESSENTIAL TO
PUTTING INDIANA SUCCESSFUL PATH
IT IS DEFINITELY THE WAY
FORWARD. ALTHOUGH GRATEFULLY I
PERSONALLY HAVE NEVER FILED FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS LIKE SOME
OF THE MEMBERS ON THE PREVIOUS
PANEL. I DO KNOW FIRSTHAND THE
EFFECTS OF HAVING A PARENT LAID
OFF AND HAVING THAT PARENT
APPLY FOR YOU LIKE. I CAN
RELATE TO THE ANGUISH THAT
PEOPLE GO THROUGH THAT MY
PARENTS WENT THROUGH.
ESPECIALLY WHEN THEY'RE TRYING
TO HIDE THAT DISTRESS FROM
THEIR KIDS NO AVAIL OF COURSE.
I UNDERSTAND WHAT FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES ARE GOING THROUGH.
THIS PANDEMIC HAS BROUGHT TO
LIGHT. WORKERS THAT MOST OF THE
GENERAL PUBLIC NEVER THOUGHT
MUCH ABOUT. BEFORE FAST FOOD
WORKERS GROCERY STORE WORKERS
HEALTHCARE WORKERS. CUSTODIANS
LIKE MY DAD. LOTS OF PEOPLE
TAKE THEM FOR GRANTED BEFORE
THE PANDEMIC BUT NOW WE TALK
ABOUT THEM IN A DIFFERENT WAY
WE TALK ABOUT THEM AS HEROES AS
MISS IRENE MENTIONS. WELL I
CONSIDER MY FRIENDS ON THE
PREVIOUS PANEL HEROES IN THEIR
OWN RIGHT. THEY SERVE REGULAR
PEOPLE LIKE MY MOM WHO THROUGH
NO FAULT OF THEIR OWN HAVE LOST
A JOB AND MAYBE YOU'RE
WONDERING HOW THEY'RE GOING TO
BE ABLE TO AFFORD. TO PAY THE
BILLS NEXT MONTH SH I CANNOT
THANK THEM ENOUGH FOR THEIR
DEDICATION BECAUSE I KNOW IT IS
NOT EASY. THE LEGISLATURE HAS
ALWAYS BEEN A GOOD PARTNER DROP
MY PREVIOUS WORK AT LOCAL ONE
THOUSAND AND I REALLY LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING THAT
COLLABORATION IN MY NEW ROLE.
AND PART OF THAT IS GOING TO
FALL ON ME I'M GONNA NEED TO
UPDATE THE LEGISLATURE AT THE
GOOD AND THE BAD. MAYBE MORE
THAN YOU WANT MAYBE MORE THAN I
WANT. BUT WE NEED TO STAY
CONNECTED ON THE SAME PAGE
ABOUT WHAT IS RIGHT FOR
CALIFORNIANS. I WILL ADMIT I
DON'T HAVE THE- I DON'T HAVE
ALL THE ANSWERS ESPECIALLY NOT
THREE WEEKS AND- I'M- AND I
KNOW THAT YOU DON'T THINK THAT
YOU HAVE ALL THE ANSWERS BUT
I'M HOPEFUL THAT TOGETHER. WE
CAN COME UP WITH THE ANSWERS. I
THINK THAT THIS IS BIGGER THAN
EATING DEER THE LEGISLATURE
THIS IS ABOUT FAMILIES TRYING
TO MAKE ENDS MEET. DURING AN
UNPRECEDENTED UNPRECEDENTED
TIME IN HISTORY. IN ADDITION TO
THE LEGISLATURE I NEED TO BRING
IN OTHER STAKEHOLDERS RIGHT THE
WORKERS I ET DE. ADVOCACY
GROUPS EMPLOYERS WE ALL NEED TO
BE ABLE TO SIT AT THE SAME
TABLE AND COME UP WITH
SOLUTIONS TOGETHER AND QUICKLY.
AND IF MY TIME IN LABOR HAS
TAUGHT ME ANYTHING IT IS THAT
PEOPLE AND ORGANIZATIONS WITH
DIFFERENT VIEWS CAN WORK
TOGETHER AND WHILE EVERYONE HAS
THEIR OWN INTEREST AT HEART.
EVERYONE CAN AGREE THAT SERVING
THOSE CALIFORNIANS IN NEED IS
PARAMOUNT TO ANY ONE INDIVIDUAL
INTEREST ALONE. I WOULD BE
REMISS NOT TO MENTION THE FULL
SUPPORT OF SECRETARY STEPHEN
ALWAYS THAT LABOR AGENCY AND OF
COURSE THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE.
IT'S BEEN A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT
OF TALENT BROUGHT INTO BOTH
INDIAN LABOR AGENCY OVER THE
PAST COUPLE MONTHS SIX WEEKS OR
SO. AND I'M ALREADY SO
IMPRESSED BY EVERYONE'S
DEDICATION TO ENSURING THAT EDT
IS SET ON A PATH TO SUCCESS.
WE'VE ALL BEEN WORKING TOGETHER
HOLDING EACH OTHER ACCOUNTABLE
AND MORE. IMPORTANTLY HOLDING
OURSELVES ACCOUNTABLE. AND I'M
SURE AS ALL OF YOU. THERE WOULD
AGREE WE DON'T WANT TO GO DOWN
THE WRONG PATH EVEN WITH THE
BEST OF INTENTIONS I DON'T WANT
TO BE SITTING HERE AGAIN IN A
YEAR TELLING YOU THAT NOTHING
HAS CHANGED. IN FACT MY GOAL IS
TO BE SITTING IN FRONT OF THIS
COMMITTEE HOPEFULLY AT SOME
POINT IN PERSON AT THE CAPITOL
IN MERE MONTHS TELLING YOU THAT
THINGS ARE ON THE RIGHT TRACK.
IN FACT I TRULY BELIEVE THAT
WOULD BE EDT STRIKE TEAM
RECOMMENDATIONS WHICH WERE
CRITICAL WELCOMED AND
APPRECIATED ET DATE IS ON THE
RIGHT TRACK RIGHT NOW SURE
THERE'S A LOT OF WORK TO BE
DONE BUT NO ONE IS AFRAID TO DO
THAT WORK ESPECIALLY MY
COLLEAGUES FROM THE PREVIOUS
PANEL THAT'S WHY THEY'RE HERE.
BECAUSE IF WE'RE NOT ALL
WORKING TOWARDS IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE MOST CRITICAL
RECOMMENDATIONS AND THIS. CAN
NEVER BE A CALIFORNIA FOR ALL.
AND I JUST WANT ACKNOWLEDGE AS
A FORMER DISTRICT DIRECTOR BOTH
IN THE US. AND SENATE I WANT
HARD. TAKE A- JUST A BANK THE
CAPITAL IN DISTRICT STAFF WE'VE
KILLING THOUSANDS. OF
CONSTITUENT CALLS DURING THIS
PANDEMIC. I COMPLETELY
UNDERSTAND THE TOLL THAT THIS
HAS TAKEN ON STAFF AS THEY TRY.
TO HELP YOUR CONSTITUENTS
ACCESS THESE CRITICAL BENEFITS.
I DO WANT TO SAY THAT WE HAVE
HAD SOME POSITIVE FEEDBACK
WE'VE HAD A LOT OF POSITIVE
FEEDBACK ON OUR IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE LEGISLATURE SUGGESTION
FOR THE CASE MANAGEMENT SYSTEM-
AND I'M CONFIDENT THAT WE ARE
ON THE RIGHT TRACK WITH THAT-
WITH THAT. I LOOK FOR DEPARTING
WITH THE LEGISLATURE AS WE MOVE
FORWARD AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU. YOU
ARE A REAL NEWBIE HERE UP IN
THAT IN THE SENSE OF. HITTING
THE GROUND RUNNING BECAUSE OF
YOUR EXPERIENCES BUT- IT'S A
TOUGH PLACE TO BE AND- COMING
INTO IT AND YOU'VE HAD SOME
GREAT TO. READ COMMENTS SO
THANK YOU. I NOW WILL MOVE TO
CAROL WILLIAMS THE CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF OPERATIONS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA EMPLOYMENT
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT. THIS
WILLIAMS GOOD MORNING. GOOD
MORNING CAN YOU HEAR ME YES.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS CAROL
WILLIAMS AND I WAS HONORED TO
BECOME THE CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF OPERATIONS EDT ON
AUGUST TWENTY FOURTH. TWENTY
TWENTY. THANK YOU FOR THE
INVITATION TO ADDRESS YOU TODAY.
MY AREAS OF RESPONSIBILITY
INCLUDE THE FOLLOWING BRANCHES
TAX WORK FOR SERVICES
DISABILITY INSURANCE
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE AND
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY. PRIOR
TO RECENTLY JOINING THE GREAT
EDT TEAM MY LIFE'S WORK FOR
TWENTY EIGHT YEARS WAS ON
IMPROVING THE TAX AUDIT
COLLECTION AND FILING
EXPERIENCE FOR TAXPAYERS
INTERACTING WITH THE CALIFORNIA
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD. THIS IS
THE KNOWLEDGE AND EXPERIENCE I
WILL DRAW FROM TO SOLVE ET DES
BIG COMPLEX PROBLEMS. THEY LIVE
TV WE GAINED SIGNIFICANT
EFFICIENCY THROUGH AUTOMATION
TO IMPROVE THE CUSTOMER
EXPERIENCE. WE WERE VIEWED AND
MODIFIED BUSINESS PROCESSES AND
PROCEDURES TO REFLECT THE
MODERN TAXPAYERS EXPERIENCE.
AFTER COMPLETING THAT BUSINESS
ANALYSIS WE BROUGHT IN
AUTOMATION AND THIS IS
DEFINITELY A CONTINUOUS PROCESS.
THIS WAS A PROCESS I USED WHEN
I OVERSAW THE BACKLOG IN
RESOLUTION OF HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF PIECES OF
TAXPAYERS CORRESPONDENCE THIS
BACK WHAT HAD CONSEQUENCES. ONE
OF THEM LEADING TO PREMATURE
COLLECTION ACTIVITY IT WAS
ESTIMATED AT THAT TIME THE
BACKLOG WOULD HAVE TAKEN OVER A
YEAR TO RESOLVE AS A TEAM WE
COMPLETED THIS WORK IN THREE
MONTHS. AND PUT MEASURES IN
PLACE SO THAT IT WOULD NOT
OCCUR AGAIN. MY WORK EXPERIENCE
WILL ALSO SHOW YOU THAT I
BELIEVE OPERATIONS SHOULD BE
TRANSPARENT TO THE PUBLIC. ET
THESE CUSTOMERS WILL BENEFIT
FROM KNOWING WHERE THEY ARE IN
OUR PROCESSES AND WHEN THEY CAN
EXPECT RESOLUTION. EIGHTY DAYS
INVOLVING THE DIGITAL
TRANSFORMATION IS INDEED UNDER
WAY WHICH WILL CONTINUE TO
ELIMINATE THE LONG STANDING
TIME CONSUMING PAPER BASED
BUSINESS PROCESSES. IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN I LOVE THE
EFFORT TO LIFT THE VEIL OF OUR
INTERNAL OPERATIONS AND
WELCOMES TRANSPARENCY INTO OUR
CUSTOMER SERVICE OPERATIONS FOR
THE PUBLIC. IF INTERESTED YOU
CAN SEE YOU HAVE TO BE AS AWARD
WINNING BEST APPLICATION
SERVING THE PUBLIC CUSTOMER
SERVICE DASHBOARD ON THEIR
WEBSITE. THIS PUBLIC FACING
DASHBOARD ALLOWS CUSTOMERS TO
SEE SERVICE LEVELS AND WAIT
TIMES WITH THE HOPE THEY
UTILIZE THE FASTER ONLINE SELF
SERVICE CHANNELS. WHICH I'M
CONFIDENT WILL BE THE FUTURE OF
EDIE'S WEBSITE. ONE OF THE
HIGHLIGHTS OF MY CAREER HAS
BEEN THE PAST FIVE YEARS
WORKING SIDE BY SIDE WITH STAFF
AND COMMUNITY MEMBERS ON
WEEKENDS AS A CERTIFIED
ADVANCED VOLUNTEER INCOME TAX
ASSISTANCE TAX RETURNS FOR
FREE. IN COMMUNITIES NEEDING
THESE SERVICES AND PROVIDING
INFORMATION ON THE EARNED
INCOME TAX CREDIT TO HELP
IMPROVE THE FINANCIAL SITUATION
OF INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES.
SERVING THE PUBLIC BY PROVIDING
INFORMATION AND SERVICES WAS AN
HONOR FOR ME AS WELL AS BEING
VERY REWARDING. MY BRIEF TIME
HERE DDD WHICH AGAIN BEGAN ON
AUGUST TWENTY FOURTH TWENTY
TWENTY HAS BEEN FOCUSING ON THE
PROCESS OUTLINED BY THE STRIKE
TEAM AND AGREED UPON BY EATING.
FOLLOWING THIS PROCESS WHICH
SOME CALL A ROAD MAP I BELIEVE
WILL LEAD TO GETTING PEOPLE
THEIR UNEMPLOYMENT PAYMENTS AS
FAST AS POSSIBLE. THE STRIKE
TEAM WITH THEIR LASER FOCUS
AIMED AND STEERED EDT TOWARDS
HUMAN CENTERED SOLUTIONS TO
PROBLEMS AND DELAYS IMPACTING
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE. WE ARE
THANKFUL FOR THEIR
COLLABORATION AND THIS ROADMAP
THAT WILL ENABLE EDT TO MAKE
BETTER BUSINESS DECISIONS USING
NEW TOOLS AND RELIABLE DATA. WE
ARE WORKING THROUGH THE
RECOMMENDATIONS AND MAKING
ASSIGNMENTS AFTER SOME
ADJUSTMENTS WE REMOVED ELEVEN
DOUBLE KICKS AND COLLAPSE THEM
INTO A GRAND TOTAL OF ONE
HUNDRED RECOMMENDATIONS. TWENTY
EIGHT OUT OF THAT ONE HOPPED
OUT OF THOSE ONE HUNDRED
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE COMPLETE.
THREE OF THE FOUR
RECOMMENDATIONS DEEMED MOST
IMPORTANT HAVE BEEN COMPLETED.
A NUMBER ONE RECOMMENDATION WAS
TO IMPLEMENT ID ME WHICH WAS
SUCCESSFULLY ACCOMPLISHED
OCTOBER THE FIFTH. THE TWO WEEK
RESET WHAT YOU'RE FAMILIAR WITH
ALLOW THE SUCCESSFUL DEPLOYMENT
OF ID ME THE NEW IDENTITY
VERIFICATION SYSTEM. AND IT IS
GOING VERY WELL. AT THE START
OF THE TWO WEEK RESET PERIOD
WHICH IS SEPTEMBER THE
NINETEENTH ENDING OCTOBER THE
FOURTH ALONG WITH THE STRIKE
TEAM WE IDENTIFIED AT ONE POINT
SIX MILLION PEOPLE WERE STILL
WAITING OVER TWENTY ONE DAYS
FOR THEIR PAYMENT OR
DETERMINATION. THIS IS WHAT IS
REFERRED TO AS THE BACKLOG.
THIS IS WHAT WE INTERNALLY
REFER TO AS HUMANS WAITING FOR
THEIR MONEY. OVER FOUR HUNDRED
AND TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND OF
THOSE INDIVIDUALS ARE NO LONGER
WAITING. WE ARE ON TRACK TO
ELIMINATE THE BACKLOG BY
JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY ONE. EDB
EMPLOYEES ARE IN FACT THE
JEWELS AND CHAMPIONS OF THIS
PROGRESS IN SPITE OF THE
VARIOUS CHALLENGES THE PANDEMIC
HAS CREATED. I WANT TO THANK
IRENE JOYCE AND JOHN FOR THEIR
TESTIMONY IN FOR ALL THE OTHER
EMPLOYEES FOR THEIR INPUT INTO
THE STRIKE TEAM REPORT. I
REINSTATED AND I AGREE
EMPLOYEES ARE WORKING FROM HOME
REPORTING TO THE OFFICE AND
SUMMER WORKING AS MANY AS SEVEN
DAYS A WEEK. THEIR EFFORTS AND
WORK ARE COMMENDABLE. I BELIEVE
THE STRIKE TEAM RECOMMENDATIONS
AND CONTINUED EXTERNAL
COLLABORATION WITH THAT WE WILL
CONTINUE TO BECOME MORE
AUTOMATED TECHNOLOGY TECHNOLOGY
TECHNOLOGICALLY ADVANCED. AND
EFFICIENT. AND THE
COLLABORATION REFERRING TO IS
THE EDT WORKFORCE. OUR LABOR
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AGENCY
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY OFFICE OF DENTAL
DIGITAL INNOVATION AND OF
COURSE THE LEGISLATURE. I HAVE
NOT BEEN HERE LONG BUT I HAVE
COME IN THE WITH A LOT OF
REALLY GOOD HARD WORKING
DEDICATED PEOPLE WHO TRULY CARE
AND WE ARE ALL GIVING IT OUR
ALL TO RESOLVE THE SITUATION.
EVERYONE IS TO BE COMMENDED I
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO ADDRESS YOU TODAY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISS WILLIAMS AND
THERE WILL BE SOME QUESTIONS-
FOLLOWING THE- THE PANELS- WILL
NOT MOVE TO MAURICE M. AND SO
ON THE SENIOR ADVISOR
CALIFORNIA LABOR AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AGENCY MR AMSEL.
GOOD MORNING. MORNING THANK YOU
THANK YOU MR CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS MARIE
SENSE ONE THAT I AM A SENIOR
ADVISER TO THE SECRETARY JULIE
SUE. AT THE LABOR AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AGENCY. THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
APPEAR TODAY. I WAS RECENTLY
APPOINTED WITH DDT DEPUTY CHIEF
DEPUTIES HERE TODAY THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF LEGISLATION AND THE
EDT GENERAL COUNSEL. TO BRING
MY EXPERIENCE OF NEARLY THIRTY
YEARS WITH THE NATIONAL
EMPLOYMENT LAW PROJECT. TO HELP
THE FEDERAL GOVERNORS AND
SECRETARIES SERVICE VISION I
WAS A HUMAN CENTERED DELIVERY
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE SYSTEM.
AND MAKE SURE THAT ALL GOES FOR
ENTITLED TO BENEFITS CAN ACCESS.
THEM AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE. AT
THIS CRITICAL WE WANT TO ENSURE
THAT WE BUILD A CALIFORNIA FOR
ALL ECONOMY AND THAT YOU I. IS
A CRITICAL PART OF THAT. OVER
MY CAREER WITH NOW WHICH WAS
DEDICATED TO SERVING LOW WAGE
AND UNEMPLOYED WORKERS I
PARTNERED WITH ORGANIZERS
ADVOCATES AND AGENCIES ACROSS
THE COUNTRY. TO STRENGTHEN AND
DEFEND THE U. I. PROGRAM. I'M
ESPECIALLY PROUD OF THE ROLE I
PLAYED WITH MY COLLEAGUES TO
EXPAND FEDERAL AND STATE YOU
LIVE BENEFITS. FOR MILLIONS OF
WORKERS AND COMMUNITIES HARD
HIT BY MAJOR DISASTERS AND THE
RECESSIONS OF THE EARLY
NINETIES TWO THOUSANDS. THE
GREAT RECESSION OF TWO THOUSAND
AND SEVEN AND NOW THE WORST
ECONOMIC DOWNTURN OF OUR
LIFETIMES RESULTING FROM THE
CODE AND I'M- BUT AS THE
LEGISLATURE KNOWS ALL TOO WELL.
IT'S NEVER ENOUGH TO JUST
CHANGE THE LAWS. THE REAL WORK
COMES DOWN TO WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT TODAY. WHICH IS
CREATING THE SYSTEMS TO ENSURE
THAT ALL ELIGIBLE WORKERS CAN
FULLY ACCESS THEIR BENEFITS.
THAT'S WHY WE WORK SO HARD IT
KNOCKED TO ALSO PRIORITIZE
ACCESS LIKE IT'S BRAND NEW
TRANSLATION AND- TRANSLATION
SERVICES AND CENTERING MARKERS
WHEN STORIES. WHEN STATES
MODERNIZE THEIR U. I.
TECHNOLOGY. WORKING WITH
EXCEPTIONAL LEADERS LIKE
SECRETARIES TO THE REMARKABLE
LABOR AGENCY STAFF INCREDIBLY
DEDICATED AGENCY OFFICIALS AND
WORKERS AT T. C. B. T. N. O. D.
I. MY HOPE IS THAT MY
EXPERIENCE WILL CONTRIBUTE TO
BUILDING. A U. I. SYSTEM THAT
APPLIES THE HARD LESSONS OF THE
PRIOR RECESSIONS AND CORBETT TO
BUILD TO. BUILD ONE OF THE BEST
U. I. PROGRAMS IN THE COUNTRY.
UP FRONT IT'S IMPORTANT
EXERCISE THE LABOR AGENCIES
WITH RESPECT TO EDT AND YOU I.
SYSTEM IS ONE OF OVERSIGHT.
DURING THE ROLLOUT OF THE
FEDERAL CARES ACT PROGRAMS THE
LABOR AGENCY WORK WITH EDTA TO
MAKE POLICY DECISIONS TO ENSURE
THAT THOSE ELIGIBLE FOR THE NEW
PROGRAMS. ACCESS TO THEM. OKAY
THING ON THE STRAIGHT TEAM'S
RECOMMENDATIONS WE ASKED YOU
TODAY FOR A TIMELINE OF
IMPLEMENTATION OF ALL ONE
HUNDRED RECOMMENDATIONS. WE ARE
MAINTAINING CHECK INS WITH YOU
NEED THE SUPPORTING ABG MAKING
DATA DRIVEN DECISIONS AND
HELPING TO ENSURE
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THE
COMMITMENTS EDT HAS MADE TO
IMPLEMENT ALL THE STRIKE TEAMS
RECOMMENDATIONS. THROUGHOUT THE
LABOR AGENCY IS PARTNERING WITH
YOU NEED TO SET CLEAR GOALS ASK
THE RIGHT QUESTIONS INSURE THAT
THERE IS FOLLOW THROUGH ON. HIS
COMMITMENTS AND HELP PROVIDE
THE RESOURCES NEEDED. TO GET
THE JOB TO GET THE JOB DONE.
THE KEY QUESTION THAT I'VE BEEN
TASKED WITH OVERSEEING IN MY
ROLE AS SENIOR ADVISER FOR
LABOR AGENCY. IS ARE WE
CONTINUING TO DRIVE TOWARD THE
GOAL OF A HUMAN CENTERED YOU I
EXPERIENCED AS SECRETARY SUE
HAS CONSISTENTLY EMPHASIZED. SO
WHAT DOES THAT LOOK LIKE. IT
INVOLVES REINFORCING THE
MISSION OF THE PROGRAM TO SERVE
EVERY CALIFORNIAN IDENTIFYING
THOSE AREAS WERE WORKERS OF ALL
BACKGROUNDS AND ABILITIES ARE
HAVING THE HARDEST TIME
ACCESSING OR NAVIGATING THE
SYSTEM AND THEN APPLYING ALL
OUR RESOURCES TO WORK THROUGH-THE CHALLENGES TO CONTINUOUSLY
IMPROVE THE PROGRAM AND MAKE
THE CLAIMS PROCESS AS SEAMLESS
AS POSSIBLE. WE SHOULD BE
PROVIDING BENEFITS TO ENSURE A
TIMELY FASHION TO WORKERS WHO
FILE CLAIMS WHILE ALSO BRINGING
INTO THE SYSTEM ALL THE
ELIGIBLE WORKERS WHO STILL
BELIEVE THEY DON'T QUALIFY OR
WERE OTHERWISE DISCOURAGED FROM
APPLYING. WE WANT TO LEVEL THE
PLAYING FIELD WHEN IT COMES TO
ACCESS TO YOU I BENEFITS WHICH
IS THE SAME AFFECTED UNION
MEMBERSHIP HAS ON RATES OF
ACCESS TO YOU WHY. FOR EXAMPLE
WE KNOW THAT UNION MEMBERSHIP
PROVIDES THE EDUCATION SUPPORT
WORKERS NEED TO HELP NAVIGATE
YOU I. SYSTEM. WHILE ALSO
REDUCING THE STIGMA THEY CAN BE
ASSOCIATED WITH APPLYING FOR
BENEFITS. THESE ARE VEHICLES
BUT DISTRACTING MADE SEVERAL
CONCRETE RECOMMENDATIONS THAT
WILL HELP PRIORITIZE AND GROUND
THIS EFFORT. FOR EXAMPLE WITH
THE INPUT OF WORKERS IN FRONT
LINE EDT STAFF. EDT AN ODI HER
DEVELOPING IMPROVED CLAIM
STATUS FUNCTIONALITY FOR
WORKERS TO BE BETTER INFORMED
OF ALL THE ACTIONS MADE ON
THEIR CLAIM. WHERE IS IN THE
PROCESS AND WHAT IF ANY
ADDITIONAL ACTIONS THEY NEED TO
TAKE. THE STRIKE TEAM ALSO
EMPHASIZED THE NEED TO ADDRESS
THE QUOTE INSURMOUNTABLE
BARRIERS FACING THE NEARLY ONE
IN FIVE IMMIGRANT CALIFORNIANS
OR LIMITED ENGLISH PROFICIENT.
AND TO ADDRESS THE LACK OF
ACCESSIBILITY TOOLS THAT MAKE
IT ESPECIALLY CHALLENGING FOR
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES TO
NAVIGATE THE EDT WEBSITE. THEY
CALLED OUT THE NEED TO REVAMP
YOU NEED THESE FORMS TO MAKE
THEM MORE EASILY UNDERSTOOD.
AND THE WEEKLY THE WEEKLY
CERTIFICATION QUESTIONS HAVE
BEEN ESPECIALLY CHALLENGING FOR
CLAIMANTS TO ANSWER DURING THE
PANDEMIC. IN A SPECIAL
SIGNIFICANCE THE STRIKE TEAM
EMPHASIZED THE NEED FOR UNITY
TO BETTER BALANCE THE FOCUS ON
FRAUD PREVENTION AND DETECTION
WITH THE RIGHTS OF WORKERS TO
TIMELY ACCESS THEIR BENEFITS.
SO IN TERMS OF NEXT STEPS IS AS
CAROL WILLIAMS INDICATED EDT
HAS TOTALLY COMMITTED TO
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE STRIKE
TEAMS URGENT RECOMMENDATIONS TO
ELIMINATE THE BLACK THE
BACKLOG. AND IMPLEMENT
NECESSARY TECHNOLOGY AND
BUSINESS PROCESS IMPROVEMENTS.
AT THE SAME TIME CODE HAS
EXPOSED AND COMPOUNDED MANY PRE
EXISTING CHALLENGES AND
INEQUITIES IN YOUR SYSTEM IT
ALSO REQUIRES SERIOUS
ATTENTION. SOTHE LABOR AGENCY
WILL WORK CLOSELY MONITORED
ADT'S PROGRESS ON MAKING THE
CHANGES SO CLEARLY NEEDED AND
SET UP ACCOUNTABILITY
MECHANISMS. WE WILL CONTINUE TO
FACILITATE AND ENSURE IT IS
WORKING CLOSELY. WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY IN THE
OFFICE OF DIGITAL INNOVATION
AND OTHERS TO MAKE THESE NEEDED
IMPROVEMENTS AND WE VERY MUCH
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE LEGISLATURE OF SWELL ON
THESE CRITICAL PRIORITIES.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU MR EMPLOYMENT OF FREESHEET
THEIR COMMENTS AND THERE WILL
BE QUESTIONS I KNOW AS WE MOVE
FORWARD- AND THANK YOU TO ALL
THE PRESENTERS- IN OUR PANELS
BUT WE WILL NOW. BEFORE WE GO
TO MEMBERS QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS I WANTED TO. REMIND
THE- AND INVITE THE PUBLIC WHO
WANTS TO PARTICIPATE TO CALL IN
NOW. AND PLEASE DIAL THE TOLL
FREE NUMBER THAT I GAVE YOU
EARLIER WHICH IS EIGHT FOUR
FOUR. TWO NINE ONE SIX THREE
SIX FOUR. AND WHEN PROMPTED
PLEASE USE THIS ACCESSCODE
EIGHT TWO SIX. TWO NINE EIGHT.
SO WE NOW BRING THE DISCUSSON
BACK TO MEMBERS- SENATOR PAN-
POLICE SAID YOU ARE HERE. AND
THEN WE WILL GO TO SENATOR
JACKSON AND SENATOR MITCHELL SO
SENATOR BEN WELCOME THANK YOU
THANK YOU- CHERRY HILL AND
CENTERVILLE AND- FIRST OF ALL-
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
SERVICE IN THE STATE SENATE AND
CHAIRING THIS COMMITTEE. I HAD
THE HONOR AND PRIVILEGE OF.
COMING INTO BEING YOUR SEATMATE.
IN THE STATE ASSEMBLY AND I THE
ONLY NEW YORK HERE AND SENATE
SO I KNOW THAT THIS YEAR. GONNA
BE COMPLETING YOUR TIME IN THE
STATE SENATE. THANK YOU SO MUCH
YOUR LEADERSHIP FRIENDSHIP-
DURING THIS TIME. THANK YOU. SO
I APPRECIATE THE PRESENTATIONS
WE'VE HEARD- TODAY I THINK I
THINK THAT- IN RELATION TO THIS
HEARING WE HAVE BOTH SORT OF
SHORT TERM. AND THE IMMEDIATE
ISSUES WE HAVE AND THEN PERHAPS
SOME LONG TERM ISSUES TO DEAL
WITH. THANKS ONE BEGINS BY
SAYING THAT- AS I SAY.
RECOGNIZE CENTER HELLO YOU KNOW
WELL WHEN I FIRST CAME TO THE
STATE ASSEMBLY ACTUAL ON THE
FIRST BILLS I DID. EMAIL OUT OF
CONVERSATIONS I HAD WITH THE
WORKERS. EDT AND I'D REALLY
APPRECIATE THE PRESENTATIONS-
FROM- D. E. WORKERS- FROM THE
SCREEN AND SWITZERLAND'S AND MR
TAREQ- BECAUSE- THAT WAS IN THE
MIDST OF THE GREAT. RECESSION
AND INTRUSIVE INTERESTING
ENOUGH- WE'RE HEARING
COMPLAINTS ABOUT PEOPLE NOT BE
ABLE TO GET THROUGH THE E. D.
AND WHAT HAPPENED WAS IS THAT-
YOU KNOW PEOPLE EXPRESSED A LOT
OF ANGER WITH THE WORKERS AT
EDT BUT WHAT. ACTUALLY IS I
WOULD LISTEN TO THE WORKERS.
WHAT HAD HAPPENED WAS IS THAT
THE WORKERS WERE ACTUALLY TOLD
THEY COULD NOT HELP. FULL IN
PERSON IN FACT WHEN SOMEONE TO
SHOW UP TO A NEEDY CENTER THEY
WERE TOLD TO GO CALL EDIE AND-
WELL I HAVE NOT HAD PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE OF APPLYING FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT- ACTUALLY I'VE HAD
FAMILY MEMBERS WHO HAD- I
DECIDED TO CALL THE PHONE LINE
TO FIND OUT WHAT WOULD HAPPEN
IF I WANT TO PLAY FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT. AND I GOT TO
EXPERIENCE WHAT SO MANY OF MY
CONSTITUENTS WHO WERE
STRUGGLING EXPERIENCED WAS IS
THAT THEY WOULD YOU WOULD CALL
IN AND YOU WOULD ACTUALLY GO
THROUGH A PHONE TREE YOU KNOW
TAKE ABOUT TEN MINUTES. AND
THEN YOU CAN EVEN LEAVE A
MESSAGE IT SAID THAT. THEY WERE
TOO BUSY AND TO TRY AGAIN. AND
WE HEARD FROM PEOPLE WHO HAD
CALLED OVER AND OVER AND OVER
AGAIN. AND COULDN'T GET
THROUGH. AND THEN WHEN THEY
WOULD SHOW UP AT TEN EDT OFFICE
THEY WERE TOLD THAT. THEY
CANNOT BE HELPED. AND THAT.
THEY SHOULD CALL AGAIN IN FACT
THE REASON PLAY TELEPHONE MUCH
GO AND TRY THISPHONE AND YOU
CAN IMAGINE HOW FRUSTRATED
PEOPLE WERE- AND I DO WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT- EVENTUALLY
THERE WHATEVER CHANGES TO ALLOW
WORKERS TO HELP BUT I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT WE DO LISTEN TO
THE WORKERS ON THE FRONTLINE.
NOW I DO ALSO NEED TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT WITH COVE IT-
WE DID HAVE A VERY LARGE NUMBER
OF CLAIMS HAPPENED VERY
SUDDENLY- TWELVE POINT SIX
MILLION I BELIEVE HAVE I GOT
THE NUMBER CORRECTLY- AT LEAST
THROUGH AUGUST AND THIS
REPRESENTS A TWENTY SIX FOLD
INCREASE IN CLAIMS FROM PRIOR
TO CODE- APPROXIMATELY SIXTY
THOUSAND CLAIMS A DAY BUT
ACTUALLY I WOULD ALSO POINT OUT
WELL CERTAINLY EXTREMELY LARGE
NUMBER. I WOULD ALSO POINT OUT
THAT DURING THE GREAT RECESSION
AT LEAST WHEN I FIRST CAME TO
THE ASSEMBLY- THERE WERE
APPROXIMATELY ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION CLAIMS. IN THE
BEGINNING OF TWENTY TEN. AND
THAT REPRESENTS ABOUT FIFTY
THOUSAND A DAY SO- ANYWAYS I
GUESS- WELL SIXTY THOUSAND
CERTAINLY LARGE AND FIFTY
THOUSAND. WE DO NEED TO THINK
ABOUT WHAT OUR BASELINE
CAPACITY SHOULD BE. AND WE
THINK ABOUT OUR BASELINE
CAPACITY WE'VE HEARD ABOUT HOW
MANY- TERMS OF SPECIALISTS AND-
SO FORTH SO I GUESS ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS I DO HAVE- FOR AND I
APPRECIATE THAT IT'S
INTERESTING THAT- I THINK. OF
ALL THE THREE PEOPLE PRESENTED
FROM DDD I DON'T KNOW IF ANY OF
THEM WERE ACTUALLY ON THE JOB.
PRIOR TO AUGUST. AND THE COVE
IT STARTED. SEVERAL MONTHS
BEFORE THEN- SO- BUT- MAYBE WE
CAN HAVE YOU SPEAK TO HOW
MANY'S DO WE TALK MADE
REFERENCE TO SPECIALIST
PERSONNEL. HOW MANY SPECIALISTS
PERSONNEL ACTUALLY ARE THERE
EDT. RIGHT NOW AND HOW LONG
DOES IT TAKE TO TRAIN SOMEONE
TO BECOME A SPECIALIST. THEN I
GUESS THE- THE THIRD PART OF
THE QUESTION AND I KNOW THAT-
MISTRIAL SINCE BOTH TOUCHED ON
THIS IN TERMS OF SAYING THAT
WELL WE YOU KNOW. WE NEED TO
LOOK PAST RECESSIONS. HOW MANY
SPECIAL SHOULD WE HAVE ON HAND.
NOT HOW MANY SPECIALS WE NEED
TO PROCESS TWO THOUSAND CLAIMS
A DAY WHEN WE HAVE A LOW
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE. BUT KNOWING
THAT. WAS COVERED WITH SIXTY
THOUSAND TODAY IN THE HEIGHT OF
THE- IN TWENTY TEN WITH FIFTY
THOUSAND A DAY. WHAT KIND OF
BASELINE CAPACITY SHOULD WE
HAVE ESPECIALLY IN RELATION TO
IN TERMS OF PERSONNEL
ESPECIALLY IN RELATION TO THE
FACT THAT YOU KNOW HOW LONG IT
TAKES TO TRAIN SOMEONE TO BE. A
SPECIAL SO HOW MANY SPECIALISTS
WE HAVE RIGHT NOW. HOW LONG'S
IT TAKE TRAIN TO TRAIN SOMEONE
TO BE THAT SPECIALIST. AND THEN
HOW MANY SHOULD WE HAVE ON HAND
AT ANY TIME BECAUSE- WE HAVE A
RECESSION YOU KNOW. IT'S THAT
DOESN'T JUST. IT HAPPENED A
PERIOD YOU KNOW WHAT. IT
DOESN'T ACTUALLY TAKE A YEAR
FOR THAT TO HAPPEN I MEAN OFTEN
TIMES IT HAPPENS FAIRLY SHORTLY
SO- PERHAPS A POUND OF CAROL
WILLIAMS IS DIRECTOR OF
OPERATIONS- MARIE SAMUELSON CAN
SPEAK TO ANSWER THOSE QUESTIONS.
I CAN I CAN ACTUALLY SPEAK TO
THAT THIS IS NANCY. OKAY SORRY-
SO I'M NOT EXACTLY SURE HOW
MANY PERSONNEL SPECIALIST WE
HAVE I HOW MANY SPECIALISTS WE
HAVE I BELIEVE IT'S AROUND FIVE
HUNDRED IF I'M LOOKING AT MY
CHURCH CORRECTLY- AS FAR AS HOW
LONG IT TAKES TO TRAIN YOU KNOW
I KNOW THAT WAS SOMETHING THAT
THE STRIKE TEAM. LOOKED VERY
DEEPLY INTO- AND YOU KNOW THEY
TALKED ABOUT THE EIGHT HUNDRED
PAGE MANUAL AND HOW IT TAKES
YOU KNOW MORE THAN SIX MONTHS
ON TO TRAIN SO. THAT THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT YOU KNOW WE ARE
LOOKING INTO RIGHT NOW ABOUT
HOW WE CAN TRUNCATE THAT TIME
LINE BECAUSE- WE DO NEED TO BE
ABLE TO PAY THAT IF. ANOTHER
PANDEMIC HITS OR ANOTHER YOU
KNOW ECONOMIC. DOWNFALL HAPPENS.
OKAY HI THIS IS THIS IS CAROL
KAYE- BUT ALSO LIKE TO ADDRESS
THAT- I DON'T HAVE THE EXACT
BREAKDOWN OF THE EPR CERTAINLY
CAN I'M HAPPY TO PROVIDE THAT
INFORMATION BUT THE TOTAL WORK
FORCE PRE PANDEMIC OF THE
UNEMPLOYMENT BRANCH WAS A
LITTLE UNDER TWO THOUSAND- WE
HAVE. AS YOU KNOW TREMENDOUS
NUMBER OF FOLKS THAT HAVE BEEN
LOAN FROM OTHER AREAS- ET D. AS
WELL AS OTHER DEPARTMENTS WERE
VERY GRATEFUL TO THEM AND WE
HAVE A SMALL AUGMENTATION OF
STAFF FROM A VENDOR. OUR PLAN
GOING FORWARD. WE HAVE HIRED
FORTY TWO HUNDRED TO DATE AND
WE ARE HIRING AN ADDITIONAL ONE
THOUSAND. THEY ARE WAITING ON.
THE START DATE AND GET I CAN
GIVE YOU WE CAN GIVE YOU THE
BREAKDOWN OF THE NPR'S. MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT IT TAKES
YEARS. TO BE AS PROFICIENT AS
IRENE CHOICE AND JOHN. AND
THEREIN LIES THE DIFFICULTY AND
THE STRIKE TEAM RECOMMENDATION
BUT ESSENTIALLY SAID STOP
HIRING STOP TRAINING SO WE DID
STOP TRAINING AND MANDATE THAT
EMPLOYEES ACTUALLY SPOKE TO
THAT. AND WE ALLOW THEM. TO
STOP TRAINING AND DO WHAT THEY
WERE PROFICIENT- AT THAT TIME
TO DO BECAUSE WE NEEDED THE
MOST EXPERIENCED STAFF. NOT TO
BE TRAINERS RIGHT NOW. NOT TO
DO THE FANTASTIC- J. T. THAT IS
REQUIRED TO HELP FOLKS BECOME
PROFICIENT BUT FOR THEM TO BE
ABLE TO DO THEIR DIRECT WORK
BECAUSE OUR WHOLE WITHOUT
QUESTION. IS TO COMPLETE THE
BACKLOG IS TO GET EVERYONE THAT
IS ENTITLED TO THEIR BENEFITS
IT HAS BEEN WAITING FOR MONTHS
THEIR BENEFITS. SO WE CAN GET
YOU THAT- SENATOR PENN WE CAN
GET YOU THAT RECONCILIATION BUT
THAT'S MY UNDERSTANDING OF
WHERE WE ARE. AND HOW WE'RE
PROCEEDING FORWARD THANK YOU
SO- I GUESS JUST TO. I
APPRECIATE THAT AND THAT'S WHY
I SAID THE VERY BEGINNING WE
ALSO THERE TO RESPONSE AND THEN
THE LONG TERM. RIGHT AND SO I
AGREE THAT. DIDN'T MEDIA NEED
THAT YES WE HAVE NEED TO DIRECT
EVERY WE'LL DIRECT RESOURCES
TO. TAKING CARE OF THE BACKLOG
THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE
WAITING. THEY'RE NOT JUST
WAITING AND KNOW YOU'VE DONE IT
AND KNOWLEDGE THAT I MEAN THAT
THEY'RE STRUGGLING RIGHT- THAT
THEY'VE BEEN UNEMPLOYED FOR A
WHILE THEY HAVE NO INCOME ALL
RIGHT R. J. ME ONLY A PARTIAL
INCOME THING WHAT'S HAPPENING
OR HOUSEHOLD. SO THEY DON'T
THEY'RE LOSING THEIR HOMES
OTHER TYPES OF THINGS- THEY'RE
NOT THAT SO. BUT I DO WNT TO
TOUCH ON AND PERHAPS- YOU KNOW
I GUESS THIS MAY BE SOMETHING
THAT WILL BE POTENTIALLY
PROPOSED AND- NEXT BUDGET. YEAH
WE DO NEED TO HAVE A
DETERMINATION OF WHAT KIND OF
BASELINE CAPACITY DO WE NEED TO
HAVE RIGHT BECAUSE YOU'RE
TELLING ME IT TAKES AT LEAST
SIX MONTHS AN HOUR TEARING
YEARS. TO TRAIN SOMEONE WE NEED
TO KNOW HOW MUCH YOU HAVE BOTH
I MEAN I HEAR ABOUT THE
TECHNOLOGY AND OF COURSE
PERSONNEL. THEN HOW MANY
PERSONNEL DO WE NEED TO HAVE ON
HAND. BECAUSE IF YOU KNOW YOU
HAVE A RECESSION HIT- AND
THAT'S A NORMAL INTERNET
HAPPENS IN IN IN IT AND-
NORMALLY IN ECONOMIC CYCLES-
AND IT'S GOING TO TAKE SIX
MONTHS OR YEARS TO TRAIN
SOMEONE. WELL THE AVERAGE
RECESSION IS ABOUT ONE AND A
HALF YEARS. OKAY SO THAT'S SO
YOU IF YOU DON'T PERSON IS
ALREADY THERE AND THE REASON
YOU ARE REDIRECTING PEOPLE IS
BECAUSE- YOU DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
RIGHT. SO CAN YOU SPEAK TO WHAT
KIND OF BASELINE CAPACITY
SHOULD EDT HALF IN YOUR
OPINION. I CAN SPEAK TO THE
SEVERAL MEETINGS THAT WE'VE HAD
OVER THE PAST TWO WEEKS DEALING
WITH OUR BUDGET TO GIVE YOU
THAT AND PROVIDE THAT EXACT
INFORMATION THAT THROUGH
FINANCE AND OUR NORMAL BUDGET
PROCESS. WE ARE ACTUALLY
MEETING ON THAT AND WORKING
THROUGH THOSE NEEDS SO THAT WE
CAN BE TRANSPARENT AND ASK FOR
WHAT WE NEED TO THINK YES THANK
YOU. OKAY BECAUSE YOU KNOW IT'S
A SAID YOU'RE HIRING A LOT OF
PEOPLE. BUT YOU CAN'T UTILIZE
THEM BECAUSE THERE. DON'T THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TRAINED. THE
OTHER. CAR IS THAT PRE. DE ID
ME- AS BEING SORT OF THE BIG
TECHNOLOGICAL LEAP FORWARD- CAN
YOU SPEAK TO- THE- CARD THE-
DIFFERENCE IN APPROVALS
BETWEEN- THAT WE'RE GETTING
WHAT I MEAN I KNOW YOU JUST
STARTED THE WEEK. VERSUS PRIOR
SO I UNDERSTAND THE 40% WERE
BEING KICKED OFF TO MANUAL
PROCESSING- THE GOAL FOR.
WHAT'S HAPPENING RIGHT NOW THE
ID ME AND- IN TERMS OF MANUAL
PROCESSING AND WHAT'S THE GOAL-
WE'RE WHAT'S THE GOAL FOR THAT
WHEN WE HIT THAT GOAL FOR ID ME.
PERHAPS DIRECTOR TOM CAN START
US OFF. YES HAPPY TO- HELLO
SENATOR PANNED OUT- HAPPY TO
ADDRESS DESIGN A SPECIFIC
QUESTION ON NINETY ME AND IF I
COULD ACTUALLY LAY OUT A BIT OF
A CONTACTS- INDEED THE
AUTOMATION GOAL THAT WAS SET
FORWARD SPECIFIC TO YOUR
QUESTION ABOUT BASELINE- IT AND
IT'S A VERY YOU KNOW VERY MUCH
APPRECIATED ON THAT ANGLE THAT
YOU'RE LOOKING AT. THAT AT THE
END OF THE DAY OUR ANGLE HERE
IS TRYING TO PROCESS OR HELP
EDT PROCESS AS MUCH AS THE-
CLAIMS FROM AUTOMATED ASHION
SO THAT REDUCES THE NEED FOR
IBM MANUAL WORK WHICH REQUIRES
FURTHER TRAINING IN THE NEW
STOCK BEING BROUGHT ON BOARD.
AND DAD REALLY WAS INSPIRED BY
THE CONVERSATION THAT THE
STRIKE TEAM HAD WITH OUR-
STAFFERS FROM EDT AND IF I CAN
TAKE A MOMENT TO PERSONALLY
THANK- JOHN IRENE. AND IS
WHEELER ALL JOYS BILL CONGRESS
OF REALLY REALLY HELP US TO
PINPOINT WHERE THE ISSUES ARE
AND THEREFORE THE
RECOMMENDATION WAS BASED OFF
THAT. WHAT CAN WE DO FROM AN
AUTOMATION ASPECT TO MANAGE THE
MANUAL WORKLOAD THAT ARE
NECESSARY- YOU KNOW REQUIRED BY
EDT SO THAT THERE ARE FOUR
THROUGH AUTOMATION. TO LIMIT
THE NUMBER OF MANUAL WORK THAT
IS REQUIRED SO WITH THAT IN
MIND- THERE WAS A- ANALYSIS
THAT WAS DONE. BASED ON THE
CURRENT CAPACITY AND THE
EXPERIENCE AND KNOWLEDGE THAT
THERE WAS A CIRCLE OF- BLESSED
AND THIRTY SIX HUNDRED- MANUAL
WORKFLOW THAT THE ROK EDT HALF
THE CAPACITY WORTH SO THEREFORE
AND AUTOMATION GOAL WAS SET. TO
MAKE TWO TO ALLOW- YOU KNOW
THAT THAT THE NUMBER OF MEN WHO
CLAIMS TO BE PROCESS TO BE
UNDER THAT. AND THEREFORE YOU
HEARD- THERE WAS ALSO OTHER
COAST THAT WAS SENT OUT OF THE-
ID VERIFICATION PROCESS WAS THE
BIGGEST- BOTTLENECK IF YOU
WANT. COURAGEOUS MEN NO WORK
INTO YOUR REFERENCE SENATOR PAT
AND- BASED ON THE CURRENT
TODAY'S FLOW 60% OF THE CLAIMS
THAT COME IN I COULD GO IN AN
AUTOMATIC PROCESS THAT DOES NOT
REQUIRE A MANUAL FOR WORKFLOW.
AND 40% DOES REQUIRE A MANUAL
WORKFLOW. SO WITH THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF IT ME WHICH-
IT'S BEEN OFFICIALLY LAUNCHED-
SINCE- OCTOBER FIFTH WITH A
LITTLE BIT OF A PRETTY SOFT
LAUNCH COUPLE DAYS PRIOR TO
THAT. WE WERE MONITORING VERY
CLOSELY HOW DOES THAT CHANGE
THE NUMBER OF MANUAL CLAIMS
THAT REQUIRED A ME A MANUAL
PROCESS- I'M SORRY I'M JUST
GOING TO THE SITE- A COUPLE OF
EXAMPLES OR COUPLE OF. NUMBERS
FOR REFERENCE NUMBER ONE FOR
ALL OF THE CLAIMS THAT HAVE
COME. INTO EDT THE FIRST OF
THAT NEED TO DO TO DO. IS TO I
TO IT I YOU KNOW IS IN THE
APPLICATION. AND IN THAT. YOU
WILL TAKE THEM TO AN ID ME
IDENTITY VERIFICATION PROCESS
IN IN THAT WE HAVE BEEN
MONITORING THE DATA ALONG WITH
EDT THAT 70% OF THOSE
APPLICANTS WERE ABLE TO
SUCCESSFULLY VERIFIED.
THEMSELVES MEANING THEY SAY WHO
THEY ARE AND WITH YOU KNOW
SUPPORTING DOCUMENTATION
VERIFIED THAT INDIVIDUAL.
MENACE DOES CLAIM SEVENTY FIVE
OF 70% OF THE TOTAL
APPLICATION. WAS ABLE TO CLOSE
WITHOUT VERIFICATION AND THAT
70% IT'S VERY MUCH ON TARGET-
IN IN OUR- ESTIMATE IN TERMS
OF- THE SEPARATION WITH THOSE
CLAIMANTS THAT HAVE THE- I
IDENTITY THAT THEY CAN SUPPORT
VERSUS POTENTIALLY SOME
FRAUDULENT ACTIVITY THAT WE
VERY MUCH WANT TO PREVENT- FOR
COMING IN TO EAT THESE WORK
LOOK. NOW THAT WOULD CLAIMING
THAT HAVE SUCCESSFULLY
VERIFIED- THEMSELVES WITH THE
ADDENDUM THE END OF THE
VERIFICATION PROCESS THOSE
CLAIM OF COMMANDS TO EDT AND TO
BE SUBMITTED THROUGH THE U. I.
ONLINE PROCESS. AND FROM THERE.
H. OF THE CLAIMS THAT WERE
AUTOMATICALLY FILED- THROUGH A
TWENTY FOUR HOUR PERIOD AND
THEREFORE DRAMATICALLY REDUCE
THE NUMBER OF CLAIMS THAT
REQUIRES MANUAL INTERVENTION
AND THIS GOES BACK TO YOUR
POINT- SENATOR PAN. THAT YOU
KNOW IF THE SENA OF THAT
REQUIRES MANUAL INTERVENTION-
IT'S MANAGEABLE BASED ON THE
CURRENT BASELINE OF EDT THAT
BAN AND THAT IT'S GOING TO BE
VERY VERY HELPFUL. IN MOVING
THESE CLAIMS ALONG- SO DIED
PROCESS IS BEING MONITORED
CLOSELY BY EDT AND THE EARLY
INDICATION IS SIDE- IT'S GOING
IN THE VERY VERY GOOD TREND.
AND I BELIEVE- I'LL PROBABLY
ANOTHER WEEK OR SO- THAT WILL
BE MORE DATA- THAT CAN BE
PRESENTED TO LOOK IF THAT TREND
STAYS AS WE MENTIONED BECAUSE
THIS REALLY JUST IMPLEMENT IT
IN A WEEK AND A HALF AGO SO
THAT'S THE ULTIMATE GOAL IS
THROUGH. A COMBINATION OF
AUTOMATING THE IDENTITY
VERIFICATION PROCESS TO REALLY
REDUCE THE NUMBER OF CLAIMS
THAT NEED TO BE PROCESS
MANUALLY SO THAT THERE ARE FOUR
EDT ARE ABLE TO KEEP UP WITH
THE WORKFLOW AND CONTINUE TO
MOVE. FORWARD WITH TYPICALLY. I
HOPE THAT DRESS QUESTION.
THAT'S HOW YOU DIDN'T QUITE
TALK ABOUT WHERE YOU HOPE. THAT
YOU SAID PER. WHAT THE ULTIMATE
AND IS SET OVER TRYING TO
IMPROVE FROM 70% OR IS THAT
THAT I MEAN I KNOW YOU ONLY
HAVE A WEEK AND A HALF OF
EXPERIENCE WITH THIS. YEAH AND
I'LL I'LL CLARIFY THAT ACTUALLY
THE- 70% OF THE IDENTITY
VERIFICATION PASSING RATE.
WE'RE VERY HAPPY WITH THAT AND
I WANNA MAKE SURE YOU DO AT.
BUT YOU KNOW THERE'S A THERE'S
A CLEAR SEPARATION OF THE
DANITY VERIFICATION REGIME
VERSUS THE EDT AUTOMATION RIGHT
OKAY BECAUSE ON THE IDENTITY
VERIFICATION RATE. YOU ACTUALLY
DO NOT WANT A VERY HIGH NUMBER
BECAUSE IF IT IS AND PERHAPS A
VERIFICATION CHECK IS TOO
RELAXED GRAHAM YOU WANTED TO
HAVE. A REASONABLE PERCENTAGE
AND ON THE NATIONAL STANDARD
IT'S- FOR THEM LESS COMPLEX
STATES IT'S ABOUT 80% OF THE
MORE COMPLEX STATES SUCH AS
CALIFORNIA- IT IS 70% IT'S
RIGHT ON THE MARK. OKAY SO
THAT'S WHY THE AUTOMATED
IDENTIFICATION SYSTEM AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT THE GOAL IS TO
GET MADE UP FOR THIS PARTICULAR
SYSTEM BUT OVERALL FOR THE
OVERALL VALUATION TO. DO
AUTOMATED PROCESSING FOR MUCH
HIGHER PERCENTAGE OF CLAIMS ARE
BEING SUBMITTED CORRECT.
CORRECT AND THAT'S THE SECOND
PERCENTAGE IS THAT AFTER PEOPLE
GET THROUGH THE IDENTITY
VERIFICATION- YOU KNOW MEANING
THAT PART IT'S ALREADY
AUTOMATED THEN YES IN THE
STRIKING REPORT THERE IS A
HIGHER PERCENTAGES OF 9890%
CLASS. THROUGH THE REMAINING
PART OF THE AUTOMATION THE EDT
IT'S VERY MUCH WORKING TOWARDS
AND I HAND IT BACK TO CAROL
SPEAK TO THAT EFFORT- AS THE
CURLY TREND. DATA IS LOOKING
VERY GOOD OKAY. SO MAYBE CAROL
ANSWER SO THE 90% IS OF ALL
CLAIMS BEING SOME. MOVING FOR
OR IS IT HIDING FOR OF THIS
PERCENT THEY GOT THROUGH IT ME.
WELL IT'S A VERY GOOD QUESTION
WHAT WE ARE WHOLE GOAL IS THAT
WHEN. IT'S ALL PART AND PARCEL
OF THE SAME EXPERIENCE THE
THESE INDIVIDUALS ARE COMING
INTO OUR SYSTEM. FINALLY AND
GRATEFULLY THEY'RE NOW GOING
THROUGH IDENTITY VERIFICATION
FIRST THAT'S ID ME AND WHEN
THEY'RE SUCCESSFUL THROUGH THAT
THEY RE ENTER THE ET DE
PLATFORM TO FILE THEIR CLAIMS.
SO WEIRD OUR GOAL IS TO LOOK AT
IT IN ITS COMPLETE TOTALITY OF
AUTOMATION MEANING THAT NO ONE
HAD TO TOUCH ANYTHING AS
DIRECTOR TOM EXPRESSED. WE ARE
VERY EARLY INTO THIS PRODUCT
PROCESS BUT WE ARE VERY
ENCOURAGED BY WHAT WE'RE SEEING
WITH THESE CLAIMS THAT ARE
COMING IN WHAT WE'RE STILL
REVIEWING THEIR DATA. THEY'RE
MOVING THROUGH LIGHTNING FAST
AND I HOPE TO HEAR FROM THE
PUBLIC THAT. FOR THAT THEY ARE
HAVING THIS EXPERIENCE WELL AS
WELL AND WE'RE LOOKING TO GET
THAT FEEDBACK AND BRING THAT
WHAT HAPPENS TO THE 30% WHO
DOESN'T GO THROUGH IT NEEDED
STAT- WHAT HAPPENS TO THEM I
MEAN. FRIDAY INTO A MANUAL
PROCESS ARE THERE AND SOME
OTHER EVALUATION THAT. CAN TAKE
THEM INTO THE AUTOMATED PROCESS.
THERE IS AN OPTION FOR MEN FILE
WE HAVE SEEN NO GREAT CHANGE IN
THAT AS WELL BECAUSE- IT IS TWO
PRONGED SO AT THIS POINT- SO
WE'RE VERY ENCOURAGED ABOUT
THAT THERE'S NO INCREASE IN THE
MANUAL. CLAIM FILINGS WHAT
WE'RE LEARNING- AGAIN WE'RE
VERY NEW WITH ID ME IS THAT
WHAT THEY ARE RESTING. IS
LIKELY FRAUD. AND QUITE
HONESTLY THIS IS WHAT HE DID
WAS WHAT WE WERE NOT CAPTURING-
UP FRONT. AND IN THAT'S
INDICATIVE OF THE SIGNIFICANT
REDUCTION IN CLAIM FILINGS ONE
SINCE WE STOPPED THE AUTOMATIC
BACKDATING OF COOL CLAIMS. INTO
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF ID ME IF
THERE ARE TRUE CLAIMANTS THEY
SHOULD BE ABLE TO PASS THROUGH
IT IT MAY HAVE SEVERAL
ITERATION AND DIRECTOR TOM CAN
SPEAK TO THIS FIRST HAND- OF
HOW TO MAKE IT THROUGH. IF YOU
ARE A TRUE INDIVIDUAL SO VERY
FEW SHOULD. TRULY NOT BE ABLE
TO MAKE IT THROUGH THE IDENTITY
VERIFICATION SYSTEM BECAUSE THE
LAST. STOP IS REALLY TO HAVE AN
OPEN- EXCHANGE WITH AN
INDIVIDUAL FROM ID. FROM ID ME
THROUGHOUT FACE FACE TIME FACE
CHAT WHERE YOU ACTUALLY CAN
PRESENT THAT THE DA. THAT
YOU'RE DIFFICULTY- GETTING
PASSING THROUGH FOR
VERIFICATION TO A LIVE PERSON
AND THAT WE DID WITNESS
FIRSTHAND HOW THAT EXPERIENCE
WORKS. AND IT IS EXTREMELY
SUCCESSFUL BUT BACK TO YOUR
QUESTION THAT 30% WE DO
INDICATE THAT THAT IS MOSTLY.
FRAUD AND FOR THOSE THAT
PERHAPS IT'S NOT WE ARE STILL
LOOKING TO FIND THAT THEY WOULD
DO THAT THOSE THAT CAN'T MAKE
IT THROUGH ID ME HALF AS
EXPEDITED PATHWAY. TO GET THEIR
CLAIM. FILED AND RESOLVED WITH
US. THAT'S THAT'S GOOD TO KNOW-
THE OTHER QUESTION IS THAT- TRY
UNDERSTAND YOUR IT NEEDS A
TECHNOLOGY SOLUTION. EVEN AS
WE'RE STRUGGLING TO GET KIDS
BACK TO SCHOOL WE KNOW THAT
PEOPLE DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO
NECESSARY EQUAL ACCESS TO
TECHNOLOGY- WHAT. WHAT KIND OF
ASSISTANCE ARE WE PROVIDING
PEOPLE WHO MIGHT NOT HAVE FULL
ACCESS. TO THE TECHNOLOGY
NECESSARY FOR. I NEED SO THEY
MAY KNOW HAVE THIS THE I'M
SMART. OR OTHER TYPE OF DEVICE
DOES SO KEYS CAN YOU SPEAK TO
THAT WHAT KIND OF UP. ARE WE
I EDA. TO WHATEVER. OUR OTHER
WAYS THEY CAN PROVIDE. THEIR
DOCUMENTS I CAN SPEAK TO THAT
DOES SENATOR PAT AND- AND THEN
IF CARROLL- YOU KNOW NANCY
ANYTHING YOU'D LIKE TO CONTACT
ME IF YOU'RE FREE TO DO SO
SPECIFICALLY. TO THE QUESTION
ABOUT- ACT. ACCESS TO DIGITAL
MEANS TO- GO THROUGH THIS
PROCESS- NUMBER ONE ON. THE
EDGE YOU KNOW BASED ON A LOT OF
RESEARCH THERE'S ABOUT 96% OF
THE POPULATION IN CALIFORNIA.
I'M SO IT'S 96% AT THE
POPULATION THAT HAS ACCESS TO
SOME SORT OF MOBILE DEVICE- TO
BE ABLE TO CONDUCT SUCH-
OUTSIDE. OF IDENTITY
VERIFICATION AND AUTOMATIC
FASHION. SECOND TO THAT. IN THE
INDIVIDUAL DOES NOT ACTUALLY
NEED TO OWN. A CELL PHONE PER
SE FOR THEM TO DO THIS. THEY
COULD ACTUALLY BORROWED THE
PHONE FROM THEIR FAMILY AND
FRIENDS. TO GO THROUGH THIS
PROCESS AND I'VE ACTUALLY
PERSONALLY GONE THROUGH IT-
JUST TO GET A USER EXPERIENCE
THE PROCESS DOES NOT TAKE MORE
THAN FIFTEEN MINUTES- AND THEN
A PROCEDURE. THAT EVEN IF YOU
KNOW IN THE CIRCLE OF FAMILY
FRIENDS ARE NOT ABLE TO HELP
HIM A CELLPHONE. OR AID A
TABLET THAT HAS THE CAPABILITY
TO TAKE A PICTURE OF THE
DRIVER'S LICENSE FOR EXAMPLE
AND- IT. AND THERE'S ALSO- YOU
KNOW MACHINES IN THE COMPUTER
SAYING A LOT. OR OUT AREA. THE
COULD GET ACCESS TO THE TO
PROVIDE THAT. EVEN IF THAT IS
NOT ASSESSABLE AS CAROL HAS
MENTIONED. IT ME ITSELF HAS A
HELP DESK. ON THE CALL THE
MEMBER SERVICE- THAT HELPS
INDIVIDUALS TO BE ABLE TO GET
ON THE PHONE CAL TO. ASK
QUESTIONS AND THEN THEY HAVE A
SECONDARY SERVICES CALLED
TRUSTED A REFEREE THAT IS
SPECIFICALLY HELP THOSE
INDIVIDUALS. AWAY VALIDATING
THEMSELVES WITHOUT THE MEANS OF
WHAT WAS DESCRIBED LIKE A
MOBILE DEVICE OKAY. SO THERE'S-
MULTIPLE LAYERS. OF HELP THAT
IT'S BEEN OFFERED. AND TO
EMPHASIZE WHAT CAROL MENTIONED.
ALL OF THIRTY PER. THAT WE'RE
NOT ABLE PASS. YOU KNOW THE GET
GO THE STAFF THAT WE RECEIVED
FROM IBM IT'S HELPED US IT'S
ABOUT. TWO THOUSAND OF THOSE
INDIVIDUALS THAT WERE ACTUALLY
HAVE REACHED OUT TO THE HOUSE
DESK AND HELP THEM TO. YOU KNOW
GET THEM SELF VALIDATED WHICH
REALLY- BASED ON DATA INDICATED
A LOT OF THOSE THAT. COULDN'T
GET IN- OUR POTENTIAL FRAUD
FRAUDULENT- CLAIMS IT IS VERY
BRIEFLY- THAT CONCERNS ABOUT
PRIVACY- YOU'RE NOW BORROWING
SOMEONE ELSE'S DEVICE YOU A
PICTURE. AND SO FORTH. FIVE MAY
BE CENSORED INFORMATION. RIGHT
SO AGAIN COMING BACK TO IN THE
SCENARIO IF I DO NOT HAVE THE
DEVICE AND I NEED TO BORROW
FROM MY FAMILY REMEMBER THESE
AT THE IT'S AND WHAT ITS
REQUIRE STABILITY TO SUBMIT A
DRIVER'S LICENSE IN THIS ASPECT
AND THAT'S THE THAT'S A WORK
FLOW THAT WAS PROVIDED AND BAD
INFORMATION YOU KNOW IT'S NOT
TO BE STORED ON THE PHONE AND
THE INDIVIDUAL CAN MAKE SURE
THEY DID LATER ON THIS OUR
DEVICE FROM A FAMILY MEMBER. OR
ANOTHER OPTION IS SIMPLY TO GET
ON THE CALL WHICH IS ALSO A
TESTAMENT LET MYSELF- USED TO
JUST HAVE AN ONLINE CAPABILITY
TO ANSWER SOME OF THE QUESTIONS
SUCH AS YOU KNOW- YOUR
FINANCIAL LIKE WHO'S YOUR
MORTGAGE COMPANY THINGS LIKE
THAT THAT IS NOT REQUIRED
TAKING A PICTURE OF YOUR
DRIVER'S LICENSE SO THERE'S
MULTIPLE MEANS TO PROVIDE THAT
INFORMATION I DO WANT TO POINT
OUT IN THE SELECTION OF- ID ME-
THE IDB SOLUTION IT'S A- FULLY
COMPLIANT WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CONSUMER PROTECTION- ACT. THE
CCPA AND THEN AS WELL AS THE
NEWEST STANDARD FROM NATIONAL
LEVEL OKAY. ALL RIGHT. AND I
KNOW I KNOW THE UTAH THE THAT
IS ALSO. THAT BACK WE'RE
LOOKING AT JANUARY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE- I APPRECIATE THE
CHALLENGES THAT'S A- STILL A
LONG WAYS OFF I THINK. OF SOME
NEW TECHNOLOGY THAT BUT-
PERHAPS- I WILL PAUSE HERE- MAY
HAVE SOME OTHER QUESTIONS LATER
BUT TO ALLOW MY COLLEAGUES I
KNOW IT'S TAKING A LONG TIME
THANK YOU NOT YOUR HEALTH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR PAN
OF THOSE WERE ACTUAL QUESTIONS
AND- AND I THINK WE'LL BOTH BE
FOLLOWING UP WITH AN
APPOINTMENT AND GET A LITTLE
BIT- LET ME GO TO SENATOR
MITCHELL I BELIEVE YOU HAVE
SOME QUESTIONS AND WELCOME
AGAIN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
I APPRECIATE YOU- CONVENING ON
TODAY'S HEARING CENTER HILL
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT WE
HAVE THIS OPPORTUNITY FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE AS A LEGISLATURE TO
SEND A STRONG SIGNAL TO THE
GENERAL PUBLIC AND TWO ET DE.
THAT WE ARE CLEAR THAT WE HAVE
TO BE PARTNERS IN YOUR SUCCESS
NONE OF US BENEFIT THE
RESIDENTS OF CALIFORNIA AND
THEIR ELECTED LEADERS WHEN. WIN
IMPORTANT. GOVERNMENT FUNCTIONS
LIKE EIGHTY FAIL SOLD THE
NATURE OF MY QUESTIONS ARE
REALLY BE FOCUSED ON WHAT WE
ALL CAN DO. TO IMPROVE AND DO
BETTER. BEFORE I START WITH
MICHAEL THERE. BACK PAM'S LAST
QUEST YOU KNOW DOCTOR PAY AND-
WE HVE TO TAKE RESPONSIBILITY
TO SOME DEGREE BECAUSE IT'S NOT
JUST ANY DAY THAT'S EXPECTING
PEOPLE TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
INTERNET AND SOME TOOL WITH
TRANSITION ALMOST ALL OF OUR
ENTITLEMENT PROGRAMS. TO HAVE
SIMILAR YOU KNOW REQUIREMENTS
AND SO WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT PEOPLE ARE APPLYING FOR
CAL WORKS IN CALFRESH IN
SUBSIDIZED CHILDCARE. AND EVEN
TO THE DMV IT'S NOT JUST ANY
DAY THAT YOU KNOW IS EXPECTED
TO HAVE TECHNOLOGY. ALMOST ALL
THE ENTITLEMENT PROGRAMS ARE SO
I THINK THOSE ARE QUESTIONS WE
SHOULD PERHAPS BE ASKING EVERY
STATE DEPARTMENT AS THEY COME
FORWARD IF WE'RE GOING TO ALLOW
PEOPLE TO USE TECHNOLOGY. FOR
GREATER EFFICIENCY THAN WE NEED
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY HAVE
ACCESS THAT'S NOT UNIQUE TO EDT.
I'D LIKE TO. THINK OF. GREEN
THIS WHEELER MR TROTT- FOR
BRINGING US THEIR- PERSPECTIVE
FROM THE FRONT LINES I THINK
THAT THANK YOU. MR CHAIRMAN
FOR. CREATING SPACE FOR THE
AGENDA VOTE TO ALLOW THEM TO DO
THAT IT'S IMPORTANT AND I'M
GLAD TO KNOW THAT THEY WERE
ABLE TO ENGAGE. WITH THE STRIKE
TEAM- AND GIVE THEIR- NOT ONLY
EXPERIENCE- IN THE MIDDLE OF
CALL THAT BUT CLEARLY ALL OF
THEM ARE LONG TERM EDT
EMPLOYEES AND SO I THANK YOU
FOR YOUR- PUBLIC SERVICE. AND
YOUR UNDERSTANDING ABOUT. THE
UNIQUE POSITION YOU'RE IN IN
TERMS OF REALLY BEING A LIFE
LINE FOR MANY CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS SO I THANK YOU. YOU
KNOW FOR MISS WILLIAMS- AS I
THINK MISTER HILL SHARED ALL OF
MY COLLEAGUES WILL SHARE- YOU
KNOW OUR OUR DISTRICT STAFFS
HAVE BECOME YOU KNOW FRONTLINE
A. J. IF YOU WILL. IN TERMS OF
THE NOW THOUSANDS OF CALLS THAT
WE HAVE RECEIVED- SINCE MARCH
AND I'VE SHARED WITH SOME OF
YOUR COLLEAGUES I'M NOT SURE
YOU THAT I- YOU KNOW FANCY
MYSELF A FORMER DISTRICT OFFICE
STAFF FOR ANYONE COULD MANAGE
CALLS AND I COULD MANAGE YOU
KNOW CONSTITUENTS- COMPLAINTS
AND INTERACTION. AND SO I.
STAFF TO THE DISTRICT OFFICE
LINE FOR TWO DAYS. AND. THE
STORIES THE FRUSTRATION THE
FEAR THAT I WITNESSED FIRSTHAND
REALLY IS OVERWHELMING. IT IT
MADE ME RETHINK AND TALK TO MY
SENATE COLLEAGUES ABOUT WAYS IN
WHICH WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE
WE'RE SUPPORTING OUR STAFF- WHO
ARE WHO WHO ALSO ARE TRAINED IN
THE SPECIFIC EFFECTS. OF WHAT
YOUR STAFF TO DO AND SO I
APPRECIATE YOU ALL INVESTING IN
YOUR LEGISLATIVE LIAISON UNIT-
I DO HAVE A RATHER LENGTHY LIST
HERE THAT MY DISTRICT OFFICE
STAFF PROVIDED ME WITH THEIR
ONGOING QUESTIONS CONCERNS AND
CHALLENGES EXPERIENCE WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE UNIT UNIT I WON'T
SHARE THIS IN THIS PUBLIC
HEARING I WILL SEND IT TO YOU
IN HOPES THAT WE CAN REALLY GET
SOME RESOLUTION. BUT WITH
REGARD TO WHAT WE ALL CAN DO TO
MAKE THE LEGISLATIVE LIAISON
PROGRAM BETTER- AND MORE
EFFICIENT SO I MAKE SURE THAT.
I FOR THESE COMMENTS TO YOU
THANK YOU I LOOK FORWARD TO
RECEIVING IT YES LET ME GO ON
YOU KNOW ONE OF THE ONLY OVER.
ON ITS THE BOX TO CONTINUE
WORKING WITH EDT TO IMPLEMENT
THE STRIKING RECOMMENDATIONS
ARE THEIR CURRENT PLANS TO
CONTINUE THAT PARTNERSHIP BUT
WE. NEEDED TO PROVIDE A FORUM
FOR ACCOUNTABILITY. WELL I
COULD DRESS ON MY UNDESTANDING
OF WHERE WE ARE WITH THAT
PARTNERSHIP WITH THAT THAT'S
OKAY THE STRIKE TEAM.
ESPECIALLY HAS PROVIDED EDB THE
ROADMAP AND BLUEPRINT GO OPS
HAS DONE WHAT THEY WERE CHARGED
TO DO MY UNDERSTANDING OUR
CONTINUED ACCOUNTABILITY WILL
WOULD BE WHAT. WILL BE WITH OUR
LABOR AGENCY AND WE ACTUALLY DO
MEET WITH- THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE UP FREQUENTLY WE WILL BE
DELIVERING A FULL STRENGTH
TEAM- ROADMAP. REGARDING
TIMELINES AND ASSIGNMENTS AND
END DATES IN VERY SHORT ORDER
AND I COULD JUST I JUST LIKE TO
OFFER THAT TO YOU ALL AS WELL
AS TO RECEIVE THAT YOU'LL BE
ABLE TO TRACK. AND SEE WHERE WE
ARE WITH ANY LEVEL OF FREQUENCY
THAT YOU'RE INTERESTED IN THAT
SHOULD BE DONE IN JUST A FEW
MORE WEEKS SO- THE STRIKE TEAM
ESSENTIALLY HAS- TAKEN CARE OF
THEIR FULL CHARGING TASKED WITH
EDIE'S ACCOUNTABILITY AND
RESPONSIBILITY. WE'LL CERTAINLY
CONTINUE. FORWARD WITH UP WITH
PARTNERS. AND SO THERE WAS SO.
I UNDERSTAND WHOLE CONTENT
STRIKE TEAM AS YOU STRIKE AND
THEN YOU'RE OUT OF THERE- DO
YOU. SEE ANY VALUE- YOU KNOW
FOR EXAMPLE EVEN AS A AS A
TOUCH POINT. IF YOU'RE GOING
DOWN THE ROAD TO IMPLEMENT THE
RECOMMENDATIONS AND- IN ANOTHER
SET OF EYES TO DETERMINE EVEN
IF THAT INITIAL RECOMMENDATION.
ENDED UP BEING THE BEST IDEA
AFTER YOU'VE GONE DOWN THAT
ROAD I MEAN THEY WILL BE
INVOLVED AT ANY POINT IN TERMS
OF. IN EVEN IN A FEEDBACK LOOP
OUTLOOK SPEAK I'M SURE SENATOR
REGISTER SHE MIGHT STILL BE ON
BUT ARE. ONGOING RELATIONSHIP
WITH TECHNOLOGY DEPARTMENT
BECAUSE MOST OF THE STRIKE TEAM
RECOMMENDATIONS WHAT DID. HE
HAVE AN ELEMENT OF TECHNOLOGY
AS WELL AS THE OFFICE OF
DIGITAL INNOVATION THOSE ARE
OUR CLOSE CONTINUED ONGOING
PARTNERS TO SEE THIS THROUGH
THAT'S THAT'S MY UNDERSTANDING
HOW WE'RE MOVING FORWARD. SHARE
SHARE ENOUGH FAIR ENOUGH ONE
QUICK QUESTION I HAD TO STEP
AWAY FOR A SECOND SO I WILL PUT
MY COLLEAGUES ASK ABOUT IT IS
THE ISSUE WITH REGARD TO FRAUD-
THAT THAT I DON'T WANT TO
BELABOR BECAUSE I'M CLEAR THAT
YOU KNOW. MANY LARGE SYSTEMS
INCLUDING THE IRS YOU KNOW CAN
FALL VICTIM TO PEOPLE WHO
WILLFULLY WANT TO DEFRAUD
GOVERNMENT WHICH IS
UNFORTUNATE- I GUESS OUR
CONCERN IS YOU KNOW HOW WE MOVE
FORWARD AND ENSURE THAT WE
BUILD A SYSTEM THAT MEETS THE
NEEDS. OF FOUR CALIFORNIANS
WITH VALID CLAIMS. WHILE BEING
CAREFUL ABOUT NOT IMPLICITLY
CREATE A SYSTEM WITH NEGATIVE
BIAS I DON'T WANT TO CREATE
FIRE WALLS THAT ARE SO
STRINGENT. THAT VALID CLAIMS
GET CAUGHT UP IN THE DRAMA
BECAUSE WE'RE TRYING TO. KEEP
THE BAD. GUYS AT BAY. AN IMAGE
OF IS NOT FERRIS I CAN ATTEMPT
TO ANSWER THAT THAT IS ALSO A
CONCERN THAT WE HAVE I MEAN WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
CLAIMANTS- GET THE BENEFITS
THAT THEY ARE ENTITLED TO. AND
WE DON'T NECESSARILY WANT TO BE
A AN AGENCY THAT. IS YOU KNOW
STOPPING FRAUD AT ALL COSTS
RIGHT SO WITH THE I. D. ME-
WHICH YOU KNOW- DIRECTOR TONG
AND YOU KNOW HAS HAS TALKED
ABOUT. ID ME WE DO BELIEVE WILL
PREVENT MOST OF THAT FRAUD IF
NOT ALL OF IT. GOING FORWARD-
AND IT IS SOMETHING YOU KNOW
THAT WE HAVE NOW BEEN LOOKING
AT FOR THE PAST THREE WEEKS
THAT I'VE BEEN HERE IS HOW WE
CAN. ADDRESS THE PEOPLE THAT
ARE CAUGHT UP IN THAT FRAUD AND
HOW WE CAN GET THEM THERE ON.
THEIR BENEFITS AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE GREAT GREAT BECAUSE
BECAUSE WE DID GET SOME CALLS
THERE WERE PEOPLE WHERE YOU
KNOW WHO CLAIMED THAT THEIR
ADDRESS PLEASE USE THAT THEY
AREN'T COMMITTING THE FRAUD.
BUT NOW THEY'RE AFRAID TO
BECAUSE THEY'RE DRESSES USED
AND THEY'VE BEEN LABELED AS
WELL- BUT YOU'RE CONFIDENT THAT
ID ME WILL HELP NAVIGATE
THROUGH THAT. WE ARE. THANK YOU.
WE'RE TALKING LITTLE BIT ABOUT
A WILL. WHICH WAS A BUDGET
COMMITTEE BILL THAT REQUIRED
EDT TO CREATE A DASHBOARD WITH
THE INTENT TO CLEARLY IDENTIFY
BOTTLENECKS IN THE SYSTEM
DELAYED ACCESS TO BENEFITS- TWO
QUESTIONS WHAT ARE THE
DEPARTMENT'S PLANS TO TARGET
RESOURCES. TO ENSURE IDENTIFIED
BOTTLENECKS ARE CLEAR TO OUR
SYSTEMS CAN WORK MORE
EFFICIENTLY. AND SECONDLY- DO
YOU HAVE ANY RECOMMENDED
CHANGES AS OF YET. TO THAT
DASHBOARD. SENATOR NANCY
VARIOUS- SO I'LL TAKE THAT THE
SECOND QUESTION FIRST BECAUSE I
MAY NEED CLARIFICATION ON THE
FIRST QUESTION BUT- WE ARE WE
HAVE HEARD IT- FROM THE
LEGISLATURE FROM STAKEHOLDERS-
THAT D. A. B. ONE OH SEVEN IN
OUR DASHBOARDS ARE A BIT
CONFUSING YOU KNOWTHERE'S A
LOT OF NUMBERS. AND WORDS IN
THE FOOTNOTES ARE LONGER THAN
THE NUMBERS AND YOU KNOW SO WE
ARE WORKING ON INTERNALLY BUT
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT I DO
THINK THAT THE LEGISLATURE
SHOULD BE INVOLVED IN AND WE
SHOULD EXACTLY A CONVERSATION
IT I'M ON THIS ALREADY- IN THE
ASSEMBLY AND I'M I LOOK FORWARD
TO HAVING ONE IN THE SENATE TO
ABOUT WHAT KIND OF CHANGES.
MAKES SENSE I THINK YOU KNOW
FOR ME I ALWAYS SAY YOU KNOW MY
SIX YEAR OLD YOU SHOULD BE ALE
TO DRAW A LINE AND THAT'S WHAT
IT SHOULD LOOK LIKE YOU KNOW
AND THAT'S BECAUSE THAT'S HOW I
WOULD UNDERSTAND IT BECAUSE I
DON'T HAVE THE BACKGROUND YOU
KNOW OF ALL THE E. G. D.
KNOWLEDGE THAT SO MANY PEOPLE
HERE HAVE SO MUCH SO THERE. WE
ARE ANTICIPATING A LETTER TO
THE JAIL BC REGARDING CHANGES
WE DO WANT TO HAVE OUR REACH
FIRST WE DON'T WANT TO DO THAT
JUST INTERNALLY AMONGST
OURSELVES ON WHAT THAT LOOKS
LIKE SO THAT'S THAT ANSWER AND
I'M I'M SORRY I SORT OF MISS
THAT. THAT'S THAT'S THE AND
THAT'S THE ANSWER ABSOLUTELY
BECAUSE I AGREE SOMETIMES IN
OUR EFFORT TO YOU KNOW- MOVE
TOWARDS TRANSPARENCY WE MAKE
WEBSITES AVAILABLE THAT NO ONE
UNDERSTANDS. AND THEN WE SAY
WHAT'S ON. OUR WEBSITE WHICH IS
SO. IT'S NOT INTENTIONALLY. BUT
IT'S NOT HELPFUL THAT THE DATA
IS THERE BUT IT'S NOT IN SUCH A
WAY THAT PEOPLE CAN CLEARLY
EITHER MANIPULATED OR
UNDERSTAND IT. IT MIGHT AS WELL
NOT BE THERE SO THAT'S VERY
GOOD TO HEAR. HI CHER G. L. B.
C. I LOOK FOR TO ENGAGE WITH
YOU IN THE PROCESS. AND
RECEIVING THE LETTER SOMEONE
MENTIONED EARLIER IT MAY HAVE.
BEEN MISSED WE RIVER MEMBER.
ABOUT THE SNOW THE NOTION ABOUT
YOU KNOW RIGHT. AND I'M
WONDERING ARE THEY MY
ASSUMPTION WAS YOU SAID THAT
WELL YOU KNOW MOST OF THOSE
REGULATIONS ARE PROBABLY
FEDERAL. BUT IF. THERE CAN AND
WILL BE A PROCESS. I READ THE
STRIKE TEAM REPORT I DON'T
REMEMBER REFERENCE IN IT IF
THERE ARE RECOMMENDATIONS
ABOUT. INDEED IF THERE ARE
REGULATIONS THAT NEED TO BE
UPDATED STREAMLINED. YOU KNOW
I. FOR ONE GET VERY FRUSTRATED
WHEN AS A GOVERNMENT. WE SAY
WELL THAT'S WHAT WE'VE ALWAYS
DONE IT. AND YET NO ONE CAN WHY.
AND SO I'M I'M NOT IN THIS MAY
NOT BE FRONT BURNER BECAUSE
WE'RE IN THE MIDDLE OF A CRISIS
IN AND I WANT YOU TO HAVE THE
RESOURCES WHAT YOU NEED TO DO
TO GET. APPROPRIATE NET CLAIMS
OUT THE DOOR. BUT BUT- IS THERE
A PROCESS OR GROUP OF PEOPLE
WHO CAN BEGIN TO LOOK AT
REGULATIONS AND PROCESS SEES
THE FIGURE OUT. IF YOU NEED
LEGISLATIVE INTERVENTION TO
MAKE IT GO AWAY IF IT IS A
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ACTIONIS
WHAT WE CAN DO TO TRULY CREATE
APPROPRIATE GREATER
EFFICIENCIES CAROL WILLIAMS
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION AND
I ABSOLUTELY CAN- IT TESTED
THERE ARE THERE IS A GROUP OF
PEOPLE. AND THAT IS EXACTLY
WHAT THEY'RE TUNED INTO AND
IT'S NOT JUST- REGULATIONS THAT
MAY NEED TO COME THROUGH THAT
STATE LEVEL BUT IT'S ALSO
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF LABOR BECAUSE
THAT'S WHERE A LOT OF THE FOUR
CORNERS HAS BEEN. AND WE'VE HAD
VERY ENCOURAGING CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF LABOR
BECAUSE CERTAINLY THIS IS A
DIFFERENT TIME AND- PERHAPS
THINGS NEED TO CHANGE AND BE
MODIFIED BUT IT IT CERTAINLY IS
A NATIONAL ISSUE BUT THAT WE
ARE KEEPING TRACK OF WHAT WE'RE
RUNNING UP AGAINST SO THAT WE
NEED TO HAVE THE PROPER
CONVERSATIONS AND CHANGES AT
THAT TIME. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION I APPRECIATE THAT LAST
QUESTION FOR ME SAID IT
REALIZED PROCEDURE INDULGENCE.
YOU KNOW WHAT. IT. PEOPLE WHO
ARE CALLED THEIR BACKS AGAINST
THE WALL AND THEY'RE AFRAID AND
THEY'RE DESPERATE. I CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE YOU LOG US A HARD
DATE OF JANUARY TWENTY SEVENTH
THAT YOU INTEND TO LIQUIDATE
THE BACKLOG I AM HOPING THAT
WITHIN THAT TIME FRAME THAT
YOU'RE PROCESSING THEN YOU'RE
PRIORITIZING THE OLDEST CLAIMED
HIS FIRST. AND I'M GONNA BE
YOUR NUMBER ONE CHEERLEADER
HOPING THAT WE SENT YOU GIVEN A
SPECIFIC DATE WHICH MAKES ME
NERVOUS THAT WE WERE ABLE TO
HIT IT. AND ILL SAY HERE
PUBLICLY WHAT I'VE SAID IN
OTHER CALLS IS IF YOU GET TO A
POINT WHERE YOU THINK YOU GONNA
MISS THAT DATE PLEASE TELL US
SOONER RATHER THAN LATER.
BECAUSE I THINK A PART OF THIS
IS HELPING ALL OF US TO MANAGE
EXPECTATIONS ABSOLUTELY WE'RE
NOT GOING TO JUDGE THERE WERE
TWENTY SEVEN. LET US KNOW. WITH
REGARD TO MANAGE EXPECTATIONS
YOU KNOW I REALIZE AS WE WENT
THROUGH THIS PROCESS AND- I'VE
HAD TELE TOWN HALLS AND WE'VE
HAD EDT PEOPLE. ON THE
TELEPHONE CALLS AND I WAS IN
THE MIDDLE TRYING TO FIELD
QUESTIONS AND- WAIT- RECALL
THAT WHAT IS THE WHAT WHAT THE
NORMAL CYCLE OF A CLAIM WHAT IS
A REASONABLE EXPECTATION TO
ASSUME ABOUT. I APPLY WHAT IT
CLAIMED COULD BE PAID. AND
WHAT'S THE REALITY TODAY.
THAT'S A FANTASTIC QUESTION- MY
UNDERSTANDING OF PRE CALL WITH
THAT THE BACKLOG GENERAL DIDN'T
EXIST BECAUSE THE OUTPUT
MATCHED THE NUMBER OF RESOURCES
RIGHT THE CLEARLY THE ISSUES
THAT HAVE ALWAYS BEEN THERE
WHICH IS THE MAIN WORK THAT
FALLS OUT TO AN INDIVIDUAL YOU
KNOW WE'RE WE'RE ALWAYS THERE
THEY- THESE ISSUES WEREN'T NEAR
WHAT COME OUT OF IT CLEARLY WAS
COLD AND THE NUMBER. OF
INDIVIDUALS SEEKING OUR SYSTEMS
AND CLICK AND CLAIMS. SO THAT'S
WHY YOU WILL HEAR US CONTINUE
TO SAY- WE'RE THANKFUL FOR THE
STRIKE TEAM AND ID ME BECAUSE
THAT MANUAL WORK WHILE I WAS
ABLE TO BE MANAGED M. PRYOR
CREEK OF IT. IT'S MANUAL IT'S
TOUCHES IT'S AN INDIVIDUAL'S
EMPLOYEE THAT HAS TO MAKE
JUDGMENTS THAT WE HEARD FROM-
EARLIER FROM. THREE BROWN
PLEASE THAT. CLEARLY WE HAVE
LATELY FOUND AUTOMATION CAN DO
INSTEAD OF AN INDIVIDUAL THE
RESOURCES OUR E. P. R. SHOULD
BE WORKING ANY WORKING WORK
THAT CANNOT BE AUTOMATED CANNOT
BE AUTOMATED RIGHT THAT'S WHERE
WE FIND OURSELVES NOW IN
LOOKING FOR AUTOMATION BEYOND
THE ID ME TO CONTINUE TO REDUCE
THE MANUAL TOUCHES ANY TOUCHES-
THAT HAVE TO OCCUR IN ORDER TO
SPEED THROUGH THOSE CLAIMS SO
YOU KNOW THAT'S WHERE WE ARE
TODAY. HE LIKE TO ANSWER IT OR
AS AN ADDITIONAL QUESTION THAT
THAT YOU KNOW THAT'S MY
KNOWLEDGE TODAY. ANYONE ELSE
HEY THIS IS MARIE SIGH I CAN
TRY TO HELP WITH THEM ONTO ADAM
THERE ARE THE FEDERAL STANDARDS
IN A DIMENSION WHICH IS A RULE
THAT REQUIRES THAT. THE 7% I
BELIEVE OF CLAIMS BE PROCESSED
WITHIN TWENTY ONE DAYS AND WE
WEREVERY MUCH CLOSE TO. THAT
MARK BEFORE CODE OBVIOUSLY NOW
LIKE MANY OTHER STATES. WERE
WERE WERE NOT IN THE SAME RANGE
RECORD AROUND 5260% I BELIEVE
BUT GETTING BACK TO YOUR
QUESTION SENATOR MITCHELL ABOUT
COM. THE PROCESS OF REVIEWING
REGULATIONS AND OTHER POLICIES
I'M SURE THAT'S A THAT'S A
SUBJECT OF LABOR AGENCIES BEAR
INTEREST IN HELPING WITH THIS
WELL OBVIOUSLY WORKING WITH THE
V. D. N. AS KAREN MENTIONED. A
LOT OF THIS- INVOLVES
INTERACTIONS WITH THE LABOR
DEPARTMENT AND HELPING TO GET
SOME RELIEF FROM SOME OF THE
EXTRA BURDEN THAT THAT ISN'T
BECAUSE SOMETIMES WITH THE
FEDERAL STANDARDS SO THERE ARE
A RANGE OF POLICIES THAT WE
COULD LOOK AT ME THE- REAL
INTEREST IN WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE. OBVIOUSLY VERY
CLOSELY. I WOULD YOU KNOW
AGENCIES OUT ON. THANK YOU AND
IT IS MY ASSUMPTION TO THAT
THAT GIVEN THE NATURE OF THE
WORK THERE WILL ALWAYS PERHAPS
BE A CIRCUMSTANCE IN WHICH
THERE HAVE TO BE A MANUAL TYPE
ACT BUT THAT SHOULDN'T BE OUR
FALL BACK BECAUSE WE HAVE
INVESTED IN- TAKEN FULL
ADVANTAGE OF NEW TECHNOLOGY
AND- MAKING SURE THAT. STATE
EMPLOYEES HAVE BEEN TRAINED CAN
TRANSITION FROM THOSE HISTORIC
MANUAL TOUCH POSITIONS IN TWO
OF THE USE OF THE NEW
TECHNOLOGY SO- I THANK YOU ALL
FOR YOUR- COMMITMENT AND
TIRELESS WORK- WE WILL ALL
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT ONE
ANOTHER. TO MAKE SURE THE CAL
WHEN YOU RESIDENTS HAVE THE
SUPPORT FROM GOVERNMENT IT
SOUNDS LIKE THE GOVERNMENT
DESIGNED FOR- AND THAT IS
THROUGH THE BUDGET PROCESS SAYS
DR PANTS SUGGEST. IT THAT WE
ARE IN ALIGNMENT- TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE INVESTING. AT THE
APPROPRIATE LEVEL IN THE
APPROPRIATE THINGS TO MAKE- THE
EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT THE EFFICIENT- STATE
AGENCY WE ALL NEED FOR IT TO BE.
THANK YOU SO I DON'T KNOW IF I
WAS ABLE TO RAISE MY HAND
MISTER CHAIR BUT- IF YOU
WOULDN'T MIND. YOU HAVE YOUR
NEXT ON MY LIST SENATOR JACKSON
RIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH. PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOU FIRST I ALSO
WANT TO THANK THE FOLKS AT
EDDIE G. D. I KNOW- WE HAD-
DURING OUR FIRES IN THE CRISIS
HERE IN MY DISTRICT IN SANTA
BARBARA VENTURA COUNTY. HE DD
WAS THERE. TO HELP. AND THEY
WERE. CLEARLY CARING THEY WENT
ABOVE AND BEYOND THE CALL AND I
KNOW THAT THAT IS SORT OF THE
CULTURE OVER D. D. D. AND I SO
I WANT TO THANK YOU ALL. OF
THAT BEING SAID WHEN WE'VE HAD
THIS CRISIS- AND THAT HAS
REALLY IMPACTED SO MANY
CALIFORNIANS SO MANY AMERICANS-
IT'S ONE THING TO BE WORKING.
YOU KNOW TWELVE HOURS A DAY
SEVEN DAYS A WEEK BUT FOR THE
RECIPIENTS WHO ARE GETTING
THEIR BENEFITS I IT'S HARD FOR
THEM TO SEE BEYOND THEIR OWN
PERSONAL NEEDS- AND THAT'S
UNDERSTANDABLE SO- I DO WANT TO
THANK YOU BUT BUT I AM
CONCERNED AS EVERYONE HAS
ARTICULATED- SO FAR. BECAUSE IT
SEEMS TO BE ALMOST-
INCOMPREHENSIBLE THAT IT IS
TAKING SO LONG TO GO THROUGH
THIS PROCESS- IT SEEMS AS I
UNDERSTAND IT THEY'RE REALLY
KIND OF TWO. BASIC ISSUES HERE
ARE THE PEOPLE SEEKING. THIS
ASSISTANCE ARE THEY LEGITIMATE
ARE LEGITIMATELY ENTITLED. SO
ONE OF THE THINGS YOU HAVE TO
DO IS DETERMINE WHETHER THEY
ARE WHO THEY SAY THEY ARE AND
THE NEXT IS TO DETERMINE
WHETHER THEY'RE ENTITLED TO
THOSE BENEFITS- I DON'T KNOW
WHAT THE OTHER HAD A KIND OF
COMPLEXITIES ARE BUT- IT SEEMS
TO ME THOSE ARE THE TWO BASIC
ISSUES. THAT WE'RE DEALING WITH
AND- THE FACT THAT IT TAKES
YEARS TO TRAIN PEOPLE
APPROPRIATELY. SAYS TO ME AS A
POLICYMAKER THERE'S SOMETHING
WRONG HERE IF THE SYSTEM IS SO
DIFFICULT- NOT ONLY FOR
INDIVIDUALS SEEKING- THE
ASSISTANCE ARE A MUST- INJURE
BUT THOSE WHO ARE PROVIDING IT
SO- I WOULD LIKE TO ASK OUR
FIRST MY FIRST QUESTION. REALLY
IS HAVE THE PROBLEM'S BEEN MORE
RELATED TO THE LACK OF
TECHNOLOGY. OR THE- THE LACK
OF- OF TRAINING. IN A WORDS
THAT THIS. ISSUE MANAGEMENT
STAFFING OR OTHER NON I TEACH
SHOES ARE REALLY IS THIS
SOMETHING WHERE IF WE DIVED
INTO THIS- AND THAT'S THE STATE
THAT INVENTS ALL THE TECHNOLOGY
BUT CERTAINLY HISTORICALLY HAS
NOT DEMONSTRATED ITS ABILITY TO
APPLY IT. AFFECTED LAKE. OR
ECONOMICALLY- IF WE LOOK TO TRY
TO AS AS SENATOR MITCHELL IS
SUGGESTING REALLY- I HAD. A
MUCH MORE SOPHISTICATED AND
EFFICIENT TECHNOLOGICAL-
OVERLAY TO THE SYSTEM WOULD
THAT MAKE THE SYSTEM WORK-
TRULY EXPEDITIOUSLY- AND
EFFECTIVELY FOR THAT THE
CLIENTS THAT YOU HAVE. HI
SENATOR THIS IS CAROL WILLIAMS-
PERHAPS- DIRECTOR TOM CAN
ASSIST WITH THIS AS WELL BUT MY
UNDERSTANDING IS. THE ENEFITS
SYSTEM MODERNIZATION WAS REALLY
I TRIED DOING. JUST THAT
BECAUSE IT IT WILL CERTAINLY
GET UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE IS
OUR ABSOLUTE PRIMARY. WE
CERTAINLY HAVE OTHER BENEFITS
TO PAY OUT TO THE CLAIMANTS M.
JUST MY SHORT TIME BEING THE
LACK OF A FULLY ROBUST
INTERPRET INTEGRATED CASE
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM IS WHERE WE
LOSE TIME. AND WHERE THERE IS-
MULTIPLE LAYERS OF PROCESSES
WHICH TAKE TIME TO GO THROUGH-AND THAT'S THAT'S WHAT THAT'S
WHAT YOU DON'T SEE BUT THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE SEEING IS. THESE
CLAIMS HAVE SO MANY TOUCH
POINTS THEY GO THROUGH SO MANY
ITERATIONS BUT CERTAINLY
UPDATED SMART INTEGRATED
TECHNOLOGY WE CAN SEE YOUR WAY.
THROUGH THIS IN THE FUTURE. SO
THAT'S WHY I DO LOOK TO AT THE
RIGHT TIME IS THE- VENTURE MLB
ALSO ADDRESSED BY THE STRIKING
THANK YOU WHAT WHAT IS IT GOING
TO TAKE WHAT WHAT IS THE COST
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT IS THAT
TECHNOLOGY AVAILABLE. AND WHY
ARE WE NOT PURSUING IT IF IT
IS. YEAH AND- I COULD JUMP I'D
CHIME IN HERE- SENATOR JACKSON-
SO IF I'M ON THE STRIKE TEAM
ANALYSIS ACTUALLY IT'S A
COMBINATION OF TECHNOLOGY THAT
ARE- YOU KNOW FROM FROM FROM
AGES AGO THAT LACKS THE
FLEXIBILITY. TO ALIGN WITH THE
MEDIA AT A BUSINESS CHANGE OR
EVOLUTION THAT HAS BEEN
REQUIRED IN RESPECT IN THE
RAPID RESPONSE OF THE PANDEMIC
THAT IS CERTAINLY ONE OF THE
COST TO IT. BUT DISTRACTING
REPORT HAS ALSO POINTED OUT
THAT IF THERE ARE OPERATIONAL
M. POLICY PROCEDURE PROCESS
CHALLENGES THAT THE THAT NEEDED
TO BE STREAMLINED AND I THINK
ONE OF THE- PREVIOUS- I MADE
MAYBE WAS. A SENATOR MITCHELL
MAYBE LISTEN TO RECOUNT THAT
WAS ASKING ABOUT YOU KNOW HOW
DO YOU DEAL WITH FRIDAY'S DON'T
LET'S LET'S NOT GET TOO TIGHT
YOU KNOW ON THE FRAUD THAT
PREVENT THE GOOD YOU KNOW
INTENDED CLAIMANTS ACTUALLY GO
THROUGH AND THAT OF ITSELF. AND
DISTRACTING REPORT HAS
SUGGESTED AN EDT IS FOLLOWING
SUIT ON THAT TOO LOOKING AT FOR
THE POLICY AND PROCEDURE
OPERATION ASPECT WHAT CAN BE
DONE TO RIGHT SIZE THIS. SO AND
THEN IN ADDITION ALL OF THAT
THE M. AND THE MANAGEMENT
EFFICIENCY IN THE TRAINING
THAT'S REQUIRED THAT PERHAPS
THERE IS A LOT OF MANUAL
PROCESS YOU KNOW HAVE YOU HEARD
FROM CAROL THAT IS NEEDED. THAT
IF THAT IT'S AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
AUTOMATION THAT NEEDS TO BE YOU
KNOW A STRONG FOCUS SO I WOULD
SAY FROM THE STRIKING
OBSERVATION AND THE STRIKING
RECOMMENDATION IF THE HOLISTIC
APPROACH FROM A TECH POLICY
IMPROVEMENT THAT. NEEDED TO
HAPPEN IN THE IN IN ET. SO IT
WHEN YOU SAY A WHOLE LIST OF.
YOU MENTION. IN THE ISSUE. THAT
THERE WHAT WHAT ELSE IS
INCLUDED. IN THAT HOLISTIC
APPROACH THAT. REQUIRES WE
LOOK. OUTSIDE OF A TECHNOLOGY
IS THE PRIMARY. DRIVER
INEFFICIENCY IN THIS PROCESS. I
WENT OUT ON TOP OF THAT IT IS
REALLY- FROM THE PERSPECTIVE OF
HUMAN CENTERED EXPERIENCE AND I
BELIEVE IN THE RESERVE
MENTIONED DAD AND THAT WAS YOU
KNOW VERY MUCH IN LINE MAN WITH
THE LABOR AGENCY
ADMINISTRATION'S APPROACH THAT
WHEN DESIGNING THESE PROCESS
AND OPERATION EFFICIENCY AND
THEREFORE COUPLED BY THE
TECHNOLOGY TO ENABLE THAT. IT
REALLY HAS TO COME FROM WHAT IS
THE BEST EXPERIENCE THAT CAN BE
PROVIDED TO THESE CLAIMANT AND
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT- THE
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY AS
WELL AS THE OFFICE OF A DIGITAL
INNOVATION WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE V. D. AS EDT
PURSUING THEIR NEW
MODERNIZATION EFFORT WHICH IS
CALLED THE BUSINESS BOUGHT BY A
SYSTEM MODERNIZATION BSN. I HAD
TO MAKE SURE THAT FOCUS THAT'S
AT THE FOREFRONT THE USER
EXPERIENCE NEEDS TO DRIVE A LOT
OF THESE MODERNIZATION SO IF I
MAY WHEN IT COMES TO USER
EXPERIENCE. I MEAN MOST THESE
PEOPLE JUST WANT TO GET THOSE
PAYCHECKS SO THAT THEY CAN PAY
THEIR RENT PUT FOOD ON THE
TABLE WHAT ELSE IS THERE TO
THIS- HUMAN EXPERIENCE. THAT IS
SO CRITICALLY. IMPORTANT THAT
YOU'RE FOCUSING ON IN ADDITION
TO THE TECHNOLOGY I MEAN
CERTAINLY IT'S NICE TO HAVE
SOMEBODY ON THE PHONE TO ASSURE
YOU THE MONEY'S COMING THAT
YOUR SITUATION IS BEING HANDLED
PROPERLY- BUT BEYOND THAT WHAT
IS THERE ABOUT THE HUMAN
EXPERIENCE THAT YOU FEEL.
REQUIRES. ADDITIONAL I'M
PLEASED AT THE- WORK. WHO WELL
TRAINED- SO IN IN THIS OUR
PARENTS WE SOPHISTICATED
PROCESS. RIGHT AND I'M GONNA-
ASK MY- A COLLEAGUE- WE DIET TO
JUMP IN AS APPROPRIATE AS WELL
AND ALSO AS WELL AS MORE EDT
BECAUSE I KNOW THERE ARE. A
STRONG BELIEVER IN OF THIS AS
WELL I CAN SPEAK TO ADAM REESE
BUT THEY'RE VERY BRIEFLY
SENATOR JACKSON DO YOU SEPARATE
EXPRESS WE'RE TALKING ABOUT. IT
STARTED RIGHT NOW A LOT OF THE
MENU TOUCHES REQUIRE AND I
BELIEVE- JOHN FROM EARLY
ADMISSION TO IS PERHAPS THE
COMPLICATED INSTRUCTIONS ON
FILING. APPLICATION AND IS
PERHAPS THE ONLINE THESE TWO
EASY FOR SOMEBODY TO TRANSPOSE
THERE ARE YOU KNOW BIRTHDAY IN
AUGUST NINETEEN SIXTY SEVEN TO
NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX. AND
BECAUSE OF THOSE- YOU KNOW- A
DIFFICULT TO USE OF APPLICATION
OR DIFFICULTY IN THE
INSTRUCTION THAT CREATED- MORE
MENU TOUCH REQUIREMENTS. TOOL
TO FILE A CLAIM AND THE USER
EXPERIENCE ASPECT IS TO LOOK
FOR IMPROVEMENT ON THAT. AND
THEN ANOTHER THING I'LL HAND IT
OFF TO- WE DIAL IS YOU GETTING
RIGHT GETTING TO. COMMUNICATION
IN KEEPING THE CLAIMANTS IN
TERMS OF WHERE THE STATUS OF
THE- CLAIM IS WILL GO A LONG
WAY IN HELPING THE CLAIM AND
TO- YOU KNOW LESS ANXIETY ABOUT
WHERE THINGS ARE AT THE NEVER
HEARD BACK OR NOT KNOWING HOW
LONG. IT WOULD TAKE ABOUT
ANOTHER USER EXPERIENCE
IMPROVEMENT BUT YOU GUYS
WORKING WITH EDT TO PROVIDE
MORE INFORMATION TO THE
CLAIMANT ALONG. THIS PROCESS.
I'M SORRY SO AS AN EX OF THAT I
THINK WE YOU PUT AND ON AND
TELL YOU. IT DAILY WE THE- IS.
RIGHT NOW YOU KNOW NOT A MAJOR
PROCESS. OR IS THIS THE KIND OF
TECHNOLOGY THAT THAT IS
AVAILABLE OR WOULD BE AVAILABLE
THE REASON I'M BRINGING THIS UP
IS THAT. PART OF THE CHALLENGE
AND WHEN I LOOK AT THE
STATISTICS OF THE NUMBER OF
CASES THAT SUDDENLY WELL I MEAN
WE HAD THIS PANDEMIC AND
SUDDENLY. YOUR WORKLOAD WAS
EXTREME- AND YOU STILL AND THE
RECOMMENDATIONS SAY LOOK LET'S.
TAKE SOME OF THESE NEW HIRES-
GIVE SOME MORE MENIAL TASK
BECAUSE THE PEOPLE REALLY
UNDERSTAND THIS WORK ARE
SPENDING ALL THEIR TIME
TRAINING AND NOT DOING WORK SO
I'M TRYING TO THINK- IS THERE
SOME WAY WE COULD BE MORE
PREPARED IN THE FUTURE. GOD FOR
BED BUGS. IT'S LIKELY WE'RE
GOING TO SEE THESE KINDS OF
SITUATIONS AGAIN. WHERE WE HAVE
THE TOOLS AVAILABLE SO THAT- WE
DON'T HAVE TO RUN OUT AND HIRE.
THOUSANDS OF NEW PEOPLE THAT WE
CAN'T TRAIN BECAUSE THE PEOPLE
KNOW HOW TO DO THIS HAVE TO DO
THE WORK AND CAN'T SPEND THE
TIME TRAINING PEOPLE WHO. FOR
WHOM IT WILL TAKE A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF TIME TO GET EDUCATED
ANYWAY SO. THAT YOU ALWAYS HEAR
IT. ARE YOU LOOKING AT THAT ARE
THESE THINGS THAT ARE
REASONABLE TO PURSUE. YEAH AS A
CENTER JACKSON A DIET BUT NIGHT
FROM ODI ODD THAT HI YOU'RE
YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT THERE
ARE A LOT OF IMPROVEMENTS THAT
WE CAN MAKE BOTH ON THE
TECHNOLOGICAL SIDE. THE NON
TECHNOLOGICAL SIDE HI TO BOTH
IMPROVE THE CURRENT EXPERIENCE
GIVING THEM THE STATUS OF THE
CLAIM AS YOU JUST TALKED ABOUT-
YOU KNOW WHERE IT IS AT EVERY
POINT ALONG THE WAY. NOT JUST
THAT YOU HAVE CLEARED THE
IDENTIFICATION VERIFICATION A
STEP IN THE PROCESS BUT YOU'VE
ALSO GONE IN CLEAR THE WAGE
COMPUTATION PART OF THE
PROCESS. THAT WE ARE WAITING ON
A CERTIFICATION- DOCUMENTS FROM
YOU ALL OF THOSE DIFFERENT
PARTS OF THE PROCESS I THINK
AND PROVIDING VISIBILITY INTO
THEM. AT THIS POINT. THE LEVEL
OF RESOLUTION OF THE UPDATES
THAT WE CAN PROVIDE OFTEN SAY
PENDING. AND THAT'S NOT REALLY
HELPFUL TO PEOPLE AND SO YOU
NEED TO BE ABLE TO GIVE PEOPLE
JUST A LITTLE MORE GRANULAR
DETAIL THAT SAYS. ARE YOU
WAITING FOR ME TO TAKE ACTION
AS A CALIFORNIA ARE YOU WAITING
FOR EDT TO TAKE ACTION TO OPEN
THE EMAIL THAT I SENT YOU WHERE
ARE WE EXACTLY IN THE PROCESS.
SO THAT I KNOW WHAT I NEED TO
DO IS A CALIFORNIA AND YOU KNOW
WHAT YOU NEED TO DO AS AS THE
CITY CALIFORNIA SO THAT IS
CERTAINLY A PART OF IT- THERE
ARE OTHER PARTS OF IT AS WELL.
AND IT'S EXACTLY TRUE APPOINTED
BEING PREPARED FOR THE NEXT.
TIME WHERE WE REALLY TRY TO BE
A LITTLE MORE INTO. OF WHAT
PEOPLE'S NEEDS ARE AND ADD ON.
THAT THAT THERE ARE A LOT OF
ISSUES AROUND DATA THERE ARE A
LOT OF ISSUES ABOUT BEING READY
TO GUIDE TO HAVE OUR SYSTEMS-
BE UPDATED WITH THE LATEST DATA
THAT WE'VE GOT THE RIGHT.
SYSTEMS IN PLACE TO BE ABLE TO
DO THAT IN THE FUTURE THAT
TAKES A LITTLE BIT OF EFFORT
IT'S ALSO IT'S A LITTLE BIT OF
INVESTMENT AROUND. MAKING SURE
THAT- THAT ALL THE DATA IS
FLOWING IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
FROM ALL THE DIFFERENT PARTS OF
EDTA. ARE THERE'S A THIRD PART
TO IT AS WELL WHICH IS. IT'S
SOMETHING THAT REALLY WAS
RAISED- PRETTY STRONGLY I THINK
FROM THE EDT FRONTLINE STAFF.
EDT FRONTLINE STAFF ARE ARE
REALLY INTERESTED IN. HELPING
CALIFORNIANS SOLVING THE ISSUES
RESOLVING THE CLAIMS YOU'LL
HEAR THE WORD AND YOU SAW IT
PROBABLY IN THE STRIKING
REPORT. THE WORDS WORK ITEMS
OVER AND OVER AGAIN AND THAT'S
THE GENERAL IDEA THAT WE NEED
THERE'S A LOT OF CHECKS THAT
YOU DO DO YOU HAVE TO DO. TO BE
ABLE TO- TO SIGN OFF THAT EIGHT
THAT THE CLAIM IS COMPUTED
RIGHTLY AND THAT PEOPLE ARE
GETTING THE MONEY THAT THEY
DESERVE BECAUSE- ULTIMATELY
THAT'S WHAT THEY REALLY CARE
ABOUT. SO WHAT CAN WE DO TO TRY
TO MAKE THOSE STEPS AROUND WAGE
COMPUTATION. EASIER ON WAGE
CALCULATIONS EASIER AND MAKE
SURE THAT THE MONEY GETS OUT
THE DOOR FAST- THERE ARE SOME
FEDERAL RULES THAT ARE IN
PLACE- ABOUT HOW PEOPLE NEED TO
CERTIFY- CITY CALIFORNIA. HAS
TAKEN SOME STEPS TO TRY TO-
ACCELERATE THAT AND TRY TO.
UNDERSTAND HOW WE COULD HOW WE
COULD THRIVE WITHIN THAT
CONTEXT ESPECIALLY WITH THE
POOL PROGRAM THAT WAS IN PLACE
WHICH HAD DRAMATICALLY. FEWER
RULES THAN NOT THAN THE U. I.
SYSTEM SO YOU TALK ABOUT ALL
THOSE DIFFERENT PARTS OF THE
SYSTEM THAT CAN HELP. YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT TO KNOW THAT
THEY CAN ADD THAT THAT THEY
HAVE TO BE IN PLACE. WE'RE
WE'RE REALLY WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK OUT WITH EDTA BECAUSE BACK
TO WHAT- WHAT DOES SENATOR
MITCHELL TALKED ABOUT AS WELL
WHICH IS. GOT POPS. AND
SPECIFICALLY BOTH ODI AND CD T.
ARE PART OF GULF POPS AND WE
REMAIN COMMITTED TO WORKING
WITH YOU NEED TO TRY TO SOLVE
THESE KINDS OF ISSUES- AND TO
REALLY ENVISION. WHAT THE MORE
TRANSFORMATIVE ELEMENTS FOR
THAT CLAIM AND EXPERIENCE COULD
BE LIKE AND SO WE'RE WE'RE
TRYING TO DO THAT. AS WELL AND-
AND ALL OF THAT IS CRITICAL TO
BE ABLE TO REALLY REVOLUTIONIZE
WHAT PEOPLE NEED BECAUSE-
ULTIMATELY WHAT THEY CARE ABOUT
IS THEY'RE HURTING THEY NEED
THEIR MONEY FROM THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. HOW QUICKLY CAN WE
GET IT TO THEM. HOW CAN WE BE
VERY CLEAR ABOUT WHICH PARTS OF
POLICIES AND FOR. WE CAN FLEX
ON BECAUSE THESE ARE VERY VERY.
DIFFICULT TIMES FOR A LOT OF
PEOPLE. BUT OF COURSE IT'S SO
IMPORTANT TO BECAUSE WE WISH
YOU ARE THE FACE OF GOVERNMENT
FOR A LOT OF THESE THINGS. AND
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT THAT THEY
HAVE- TRUST. IN GOVERNMENT
RIGHT NOW IT'S BEEN A REAL
CHALLENGE ON. EVERY LEVEL OF
FOR A VARIETY OF REASONS SAID
WE WON'T GO INTO BUT- I. IN
THAT LINE OF. THINKING AND
QUESTIONING DO YOU HAVE ANY
IDEA HOW OTHER STATES
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE SYSTEMS
FACED WITH THE- THE MASSIVE
INCREASE IN CLAIMS BROUGHT ON
BY THE PANDEMIC. I HAVE FARED
IN COMPARISON TO OURS- HOW HOW
THERE WAS A BACKLOG COMPARING
TO A LARGE THE- AVERAGE TIME
BETWEEN RECEIPT OF A CLAIM- AND
PAYMENT OF A CLAIM AND- OTHER
PERCENTAGE OF CLAIMS THAT ARE
BEING- WITHIN SOME STATED
PERIOD OF TIME DIDN'T. HAVE YOU
HAVE YOU LOOKED. AT THAT DO YOU
HAVE ANY DATA YOU CAN SHARE.
HEY THIS IS MARIE'S SUMMER I
CAN A LITTLE BIT WITH THEM WHEN
THEY'RE THERE ARE THE GENERAL.
DIFFICULT TO COMPARE RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE- YOU I CLAIMS THAT IN A
WAY THAT ARE VERY. VOLATILE BUT
THERE ARE SOME BASIC MEASURES
THAT A COUPLE GROUPS TO PUT
TOGETHER- THAT LOOK OUT LOOK AT
THE PERCENT OF CLAIMS THAT HAVE
BEEN PROCESSED BY STATES SINCE
CORBETT. AND WE RANK I BELIEVE
LAST TIME I LOOKED AT THE
NUMBERS WERE UP AROUND
FOURTEEN. SO WE'RE DOING PRETTY
WELL RELATIVE TO OTHER STATES
BUT OBVIOUSLY. THAT THAT'S NOT
A GOD ENOUGH ANSWER YOU KNOW
WE NEED TO DO BETTER FOR
EVERYBODY WHO'S WAITING ON
THEIR BENEFITS BUT RELATIVE TO
OTHER STATES WHEN IT COMES TO
THAT BASIC MEASURE. YOU KNOW
WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE DOING PRETTY
WELL. SO HAVE WE LEARNED
ANYTHING FROM THE ONES THAT ARE
DOING BETTER THAN WE ARE ARE
THERE ANY PROCESSES OR
PROCEDURES OR APPROACHES THAT.
WOULD BENEFIT US THAT SHOULD BE
ABLE TO REPLICATE SOME OF THEIR.
SUCCESSES FOR CALIFORNIANS. I
AM I DON'T I WOULD DEFER TO-
RETIRED NAVY PROBABLY ON THAT
ONE- I MEAN I CAN SAY THAT
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
INFORMATION SURE THERE'S AN
ORGANIZATION CALLED. THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF STATE
WORK FORCE AGENCY WHICH IS
BASICALLY. THE ESTIMATING
GROUPS LOBBYING ORGANIZATION
FROM THE STATE YOUR AGENCY'S
WORKFORCE PROGRAMS AND THERE'S
A LOT OF SHARING OF INFORMATION
HAPPENING THERE. ARE A
DIFFERENT LEVELS AROUND THE
PRIDE STAR AND ACCESS ISSUES-
SO WE'RE WE'RE YOU KNOW WE'RE
WE'RE ACTIVELY INVOLVED IN
THOSE EFFORTS- AND FOR SURE YOU
KNOW I KNOW THERE'S BEEN A LOT
OF COMMUNICATION AGAIN. IN A
LOT OF NEW SO THE FOLKS- YOU
KNOW. WE'RE NOT A FAN RIGHT NOW
ARE NEW. IT'S MY UNDERSTAND
THAT THERE WAS. IMPORTANT
COMMUNICATIONS LIKE AROUND THE
ROLL OUT OF YOUR WAY. WITH
OTHER STATES AS WELL SO I KNOW
THERE'S BEEN SOME OF THOSE
CONVERSATIONS BUT- AGAIN FROM
THE LABOR AGENCY PERSPECTIVE
WE'RE TRYING TO DO MORE OF
THAT. AND YOU'RE INTERESTED IN
COMPARING NOTES AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE WITH OTHER STATES.
WELL I HOPE SO BECAUSE- YOU
KNOW CALIFORNIA WERE USUALLY
LEADS THE WAY IN OTHER STATES
IMPROVE UPON WHAT WE'VE DONE.
IN THIS CASE IT WOULD BE REALLY
HELPFUL IF WE COULD LEARN-
PERHAPS WHAT OTHER STATES HAVE
DONE THAT AT THAT HAVE BEEN.
MORE EFFECTIVE- AND THEN APPLY
THOSE TO THE EXTENT WE CAN
CALIFORNIA COURSES. SO UNIQUE
AND- WE HAVE SO MANY DIVERSE
POPULATIONS OR WHAT HAVE YOU
BUT- I HOPE THAT THAT- INQUIRY
WILL CONTINUE SO THAT WE CAN
TRY TO IMPROVE. UPON WHAT WE'VE
DONE AND WITH THAT IN MIND- CAN
ANYONE HERE TELL ME- GIVE ME AN
ESTIMATE ON THE LENGTH OF TIME
THAT IT'S GOING TO TAKE- FOR
CASES. THAT ARE BEING PUT ON
THE NEW ONLINE SYSTEM TO BE
RESOLVED SO WE CAN. ASSURE OUR
STAFF OUR DISTRICT STAFF THAT-
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO CONTINUE
TO SEE- AND HAVE TO ENDURE A
LOT OF THE SAME- DELAYS THAT WE
HAVE SEEN AND OF COURSE. THERE
HAVE BEEN SOME REAL
IMPROVEMENTS. THE ABILITY TO
HAVE DIRECT CONTACT THE WORKER
I THINK IT'S BEEN A TRUE. PLUS
I KNOW MY STAFF HAS EXPRESSED
GREAT. AND HOW WOULD HELPED
RESOLVE SOME OF OUR CLIENTS
BUT- GOING FORWARD DO YOU HAVE
AN ESTIMATE ON THE LIKE THE
TIME. SO I WOULD SAY THAT THIS
IS A SERVICE CENTER THIS IS
NANCY VARIOUS- WE ARE THAT THE
NEW CASE MANAGEMENT SYSTEM IS
GOING TO MAKE THINGS MUCH
EASIER TO DEAL WITH THOSE
CASES- WE ARE WORKING ON THE
OLDEST CASES FIRST. AND SO
WHILE SOME OF THEM MAY BE STILL
COMPLEX I MEAN I DON'T
NECESSARILY HAVE AN ESTIMATE AS
TO HOW LONG EACH CASE WOULD
TAKE I THINK SOME. ARE CAN
OBVIOUSLY BE WORKED ON- AND
RESULTS FASTER THAN OTHERS- BUT
WE ARE VERY CONFIDENT THAT WITH
THE NEW CASE MANAGEMENT SYSTEM
AND THE ORGANIZATION THAT THAT.
PROVIDES THAT WE WILL BE ABLE
TO EXPEDITE- SOME OF THESE
CASES. AND OF COURSE IF IT'S A
HARDSHIP CASE YOU KNOW THOSE
GET EXPEDITED. RIGHT AWAY
SOURCES WE SEE THIS PANDEMIC IS
CONTINUING AND- YOU KNOW THE
MONEY IS RUNNING OUT THERE WILL
BE I THINK OF THE UPS AND DOWNS
WE'RE SEEING IT IN OTHER STATES
AND OTHER COUNTRIES WHERE
THEY'RE SEEING THE SECOND WAVE
AND THINGS ARE CLOSING DOWN OF
PEOPLE ARE AGAIN LOSING THEIR
JOBS I. I ANTICIPATE THAT WE'RE
GOING TO BE SEEING THIS AS I'M
SURE YOU DO AND SO IT WOULD BE
VERY HELPFUL- AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE TO GET. THIS GOING AND
I KNOW I'M TERMED OUT SO-
CENTER HILL AND I WILL BE
WATCHING I'M SURE WITH GREAT
ANTICIPATION BUT I KNOW THAT
OUR COLLEAGUES. ARE VERY
ANXIOUS TO BE HELPFUL TO ANY
EXTENT THEY CAN BE AND I
CERTAINLY- APPRECIATE THAT YOU
ARE. AGAIN COMMITTED TO THIS
BUT I DON'T THINK THINGS ARE
GOING TO GET BETTER THAT
QUICKLY UNTIL WE HAVE A
LEGITIMATE VACCINE UP MY ONE
LAST QUESTION GOES INTO A-
ANOTHER AREA- AND I WANT TO
THANK GOD- THE REFERENCE TO THE
FACT THAT. WE ARE- BECAUSE A
PAID FAMILY LEAVE ISSUES AND-
THAT IS SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS
ABOUT THE UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE BENEFITS PROGRAM
RECENT LAWS ON FAMILY LEAVE ARE
LIKELY GOING TO EXPAND OUR
DEMAND FOR FAMILY LEAVE
BENEFITS- S. B. GOSH I CAN
THINK OF THE NUMBER RIGHT NOW
BUT CERTAINLY WE'VE HAD A
NUMBER OF BILLS THIRTEEN EIGHTY
THREE THAT COMES TO MIND
IMMEDIATELY ON. EXPANDING PAID.
FAMILY LEAVE AND- THE ABILITY
OF PEOPLE TO HAVE PROTECTIONS
FOR THAT WE EXPECT WE'LL SEE
MORE PEOPLE ACCESSING IT THEN
WE HAVE- A MILITARY EXIGENCY OF
FAMILY LEAVE BENEFITS WHICH
TAKE EFFECT IN JANUARY- CAN YOU
TALK ABOUT YOUR PREPARATION FOR
THIS BECAUSE- THESE PROGRAMS
ARE GOING TO CALL UPON- YOU
KNOW GREATER- PARTICIPATION.
AND PROBABLY GREATER DEMAND HOW
ARE YOU PLANNING FOR THOSE-
PROGRAMS TO BE IMPLEMENTED AS
WELL. THANK YOU SENATOR CAROL
WILLIAMS- SO FIRST LET ME
ADDRESS THAT- THE COOK AT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC THANKFULLY
HAS HAD NO SIGNIFICANT IMPACT
ON OUR PAID FAMILY LEAVE OR
DISABILITY INSURANCE WORKLOADS
BOTH. OF THOSE WORK LET'S
CONTINUE TO MEET THE CURRENT
METRIC GOALS BUT WE WORK-
COHESIVELY AS A TEAM AND THEY
ARE THE BEST LEADERSHIP TEAM
AND THE EMPLOYEES ARE ACTUALLY
WORKING HAND IN HAND IN GOING
THROUGH THE UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE EXPERIENCE THE TOOLS
THAT THE STRIKE TEAM IS
DELIVERED TO US. IT'S ONE OF
THE NAMES CALLED BURN DOWN TILL
IT'S HOW YOU TAKE A LOOK AT
YOUR WORK AND FORECAST THESE
ARE THE TOOLS WE HAVE ALREADY
AND ARE INTRODUCING TO OUR
OTHER PROGRAMS IN ANTICIPATION
OF. UNKNOWN FOR SCENES WHAT ARE
YOU GOING TO BE WHEN HE HOW ARE
YOU GOING TO DO THIS HOW LONG
IS IT GONNA TAKE SO THANKFULLY
AGAIN GOING BACK TO THE
STRAIGHT TEAM THOSE TOOLS THAT
THEY DON'T. REAL BENEFIT THE
REST OF THE BENEFIT PROGRAMS AT
EDT AND THEY'RE- NOW LEARNING
HOW TO USE THOSE TOOLS IN
PREPARATION FOR- FOR SCENES ARE
FORESEEN IN THE FUTURE IN THEIR
FUTURE FOR THOSE BENEFIT
PROGRAMS. AND WELL THANK YOU-
THOSE ARE ALL MY QUESTIONS I
WISH YOU THE BEST OF LUCK I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR YOUR EFFORTS
AND- IT'S MY HOPE THAT WE WILL.
READ OR MAYBE FOR THE TIME THE
ADVANTAGE WHEN IT COMES TO
ACCESSING TECHNOLOGY- BUT DOING
IT WITH A WITH A- STRONG
MINDSET TOWARDS PRIVACY RIGHTS.
BUT THERE IS TECHNOLOGY OUT
THERE THAT WE REALLY NEED TO-
PURSUE- TO EXPEDITE ALL OF THIS
AND IT'S BEEN A VERY
COMPLICATED PROCESS FOR THAT.
TWENTY TWO YEARS THATI'VE BEEN
INVOLVED IN THIS- BUT IT'S MY
HOPE THAT GOING FORWARD AT
LEAST- WILL BE ABLE TO USE
THOSE TECHNOLOGIES TO THE
BENEFIT. OF THE PEOPLE THAT WE
SERVE SO THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU SENATOR FOR
YOUR SERVICE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SENATOR JACKSON AND I KNOW
SENATOR PAN HAD A FOLLOW UP
QUESTION. THANK YOU THANK YOU
CHAIR HELLO. REFERENCE WAS MADE
TO A- SO I CALLED BENEFIT
SYSTEM MODERNIZATION OR WHAT'S
THE SO- DO YOU SPEAK TO THE
STATUS OF WHERE WE ARE WITH- I.
T. SERVICE. DRESS MORE
SPECIFICALLY ID IN ME BUT THE
LARGER PICTURE IN TERMS OF THE
IT INFRASTRUCTURE OVER AT EDM
PARTICULARLY RELATED TO YOU I'D
WHAT WHERE ARE WE WITH THAT.
WHAT'S THE STATUS OF THAT. I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU WANT TO START
FIRST AND THEN I WILL CAN- ADD
TO DIE FROM THE STATE'S
OVERSIGHT ASPECT ABSOLUTELY
THAT'S INTERESTING. AS A DRESS
WITH STRIKING REPORT AND
RECOMMENDATION WAS TO PUT BSM
ON BECAUSE WE CONTINUE TO FOCUS
ON OUR MORE URGENT ISSUE WAS TO
GET THE CAP GET THESE BACK WHAT
CLAIMS PAID. SO THAT WAS
EFFECTIVELY DONE THERE'D BE
SOME PROJECT WAS PUT ON PAUSE
BELIEVE- LATE MID SEPTEMBER THE
FANTASTIC EMPLOYEES THAT HAVE
BEEN COMMITTED TO THAT PROJECT
HAVE ALL BEEN REDEPLOYED BACK
TO WHERE THE ORIGINAL- OR NEAR
THEIR ORIGINAL WORK ASSIGNMENTS
WORK BECAUSE AGAIN THE FOCUS IS
CURRENTLY ON THE BACKLOG AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME AND THIS IS.
SURE WE READ MY UNDERSTANDING
IS WE WILL REASSEMBLE AND LOOK
AT HOW TO. ENGAGE IN THIS
EFFORT- FOR TODAY'S TIME AND
HOLISTICALLY WRAPPING AROUND
THE OTHER BENEFITS OF THE
DEPARTMENT THANK YOU. YES AND I
UNDERSTAND THE STANDARD VAMPIRE
I'M JUST OF THE BIGGER PICTURE
SO WHERE- SO WHAT STAGE IS THE
SAN AND- WHERE WHERE DO WE-
WHAT'S THE TIMELINE FOR THAT.
THE PROJECT. CENTER BUT I CAN
SPEAK TO THAT FROM EIGHTY
OVERSIGHT ASPECT SO THAT
PROJECT- THE STATE YOU JUST
YOU'RE MENTIONING- THE PROJECT
ITSELF WAS GOING THROUGH THE
FOUR STAGES OF THE PLAN-
PROJECT APPROVAL LIFECYCLE PAL.
AND IT WAS AT STAGE THREE WHERE
THAT THE- THERE WAS ACTUALLY A
PROCUREMENT I WAS IN THE MIDDLE
OF- BEING NEGOTIATED AND THAT
PROCUREMENT SELLS AFTER THE
PANDEMIC AND THEY'RE ALSO
PROPER TIME FRAME NEEDED TO PUT
ON HOLD. PUT ON PAUSE AND A
SUBSEQUENT TO THE PROCUREMENT
POLICIES DIDN'T HIRE PROJECT
WAS PUT ON PAUSE AS CAROL
MENTIONED- BECAUSE THE FOCUS
NEEDS TO SHIFT ALL RESOURCES
AVAILABLE TO ADDRESS THE
BACKLOG NEEDS FROM YOU I'VE
HEARD ABOUT. MOVING FORWARD-
THE A. D. AS SOON AS THE-
BACKLOG IT'S REACH TO
ATTAINABLE THAT YOU KNOW OF A
SPACE AND WE'RE LOOKING AT
GENERATES THAT TIME FRAME WE
ARE AS AN OVERSIGHT INTO T.
GONNA GOD ENGAGE WITH EDT ALONG
WITH- OFFICE OF DIGITAL
INNOVATION TO TAKE A LOOK. YOU
KNOW THE PRIORITIZATION OF THE
CURRENT BSM PROJECT- THE MEMBER
OF THE B. AS IN PROJECTS COVERS
PAID FAMILY LEAVE. DISABILITY
INSURANCE AND YOU WHY INSURANCE
THREE MAJOR COMPONENTS- TAKE A
LOOK AT THAT TO SEE WHAT. A
pPRIORITIZED THE MORE
IMPORTANTLY BASED ON ALL THE
LESSONS LEARNED THROUGH THIS
PANDEMIC. AT THE I. USERS A
HUMAN CENTERED DESIGN LOOKING
AT INTERACTIVE IMPROVEMENTS TO
TECHNOLOGY THAT ARE READILY
AVAILABLE TO SENATOR JACKSON'S
POINT. AND RATHER THAN A BIG
REPAIR REPLACE EFFORT AND
LOOKING AT ALSO LEVERAGE AS
MUCH AS POSSIBLE THE
MODERNIZATION OF FOR THAT IT'S
ALREADY AND CONTINUED TO GO ON
YOU KNOW IN RESPONSE TO AND
THAT MAKE IT SPECIFIC TO YOUR
WATCH. SEE HOW MUCH OF THOSE
CAN BE LEVERAGED SO THAT IS NOT
REINVENTING THE WHEEL BUT THEY
CONTINUE TO A SALARY THAT
MODERNIZATION EFFORT. THROUGH
THE RE ENGAGEMENT WITH EDT
OBVIOUS THAT. IN IS THIS USING
THE I. JOB SO. ABSOLUTELY IS
LOOK FOR WAYS OF A CAN AND
ENTERED A IN AS OPPOSED TO THE
WAY FOR YOU KNOW THE END AT
SOMETIME OF A WE PLAY EFFORT.
MARKET I APPRECIATE NOTHING YOU
SO MUCH FOR THE ANTS I ONE OF
THE THINGS I DO WANT TO JUST
CALM ON IS GENERALLY WE HAPPENS
WE DO IT PROJECTS IN THE STATE-
THE ONES AGO WELL. GO WELL AND-
ARE THE LEAST DON'T HIT THE
PRESS AND THE ONES THAT DON'T
GET DEPRESSED SO THERE'S A
GENERAL OPINION. R. SOMETIMES I
THINK THERE'S A MISCONCEPTION
THAT- STATE IT PROJECTS- ARE
ALWAYS A PROBLEMATIC. I WANT TO
JUST COME INTO THAT- NOW WE
HAVE GOOD ONCE AND WE'VE HAD
BAD ONES AND I'VE CRITIQUE TO
THE BAD ONES- BUT I ALSO
ACKNOWLEDGES SOMEONE WHOSE-
CHAIRED TO TEARS MANY OTHER
COMMITTEES AND DOES OVERSIGHT
THAT WE'VE ALSO HAVE ONES ARE
GOING YOU KNOW IT'S A
RELATIVELY WELL I WON'T SAY
THEY DON'T HAVE PROBLEMS. BUT
THEY'RE GOING RELATIVELY WELL
SO I DO APPRECIATE THAT- THE
ROLE OF- OF PSYCHOLOGY AND
DIRECTOR TOM OUT I'VE NOTICED
THAT THEY'VE ALWAYS BEEN VERY
HELPFUL IN TERMS OF THE LEAST
WHEN I'VE CONDUCTED OVERSIGHT
OVER IT PROJECTS. AND
APPRECIATE THE OVERSIGHT AND I
THINK THAT- CERTAINLY ONE OF
THE THINGS AND I APPRECIATE
THAT THE PODS BECAUSE IF WE'RE
GONNA HAVE A SUCCESSFUL IT
PROJECT WE NEED TO ENGAGE THE
WORKERS ON THE FRONT LINES AND
PARTICULARLY THE ONES WITH THE
MOST EXPERIENCE AND SO I
CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND THAT. NOW
IS THE TIME FOR THEM TO BE
FOCUSING ON THINGS LIKE THE
BACKLOG AND- BUT- UNTIL THEY
ARE ABLE TO BE MORE FREEDOM SO
WE CAN CAN DEVELOP THOSE.
REALLY THAT HUMAN TECHNOLOGY
INTERFACE- THAT'S GOING TO MAKE
IT BE ANY PROJECTS SUCCESSFUL-
YEAH WE NEED TO ENGAGE THE
PEOPLE ARE ON THE FRONT LINES
SO- BUT I DO THINK THIS IS
SOMETHING WE NEED TO- WHEN WE
AS WE CAN CORPORATE LESSONS
WE'RE LEARNING- TO CREATE THAT
BACKBONE AND AGAIN TRYING TO
COME OUT. IN APRIL YOU URGE.
FOR EDIE AND YOU KNOW WHEN WE
START DOING THE BUDGET PROCESS
AND OTHER TYPES OF THINGS
REALLY LOOKING AT WHAT'S OUR
BASELINE CAPACITY. SHOULD BE
AND THAT'S- BOTH PEOPLE ENTER.
AND THEN. BECAUSE IT'S HARD TO
REALLY RE UP TO. IN CRISIS I
THINK THAT'S WHY OF THINGS WE-
COPING OVERALL. IS THAT. WHEN
THE CRISIS HITS. THEN YOU'RE
TRYING TO SCRAMBLE AND I'LL
TELL YOU AS A PHYSICIAN YOU
KNOW WE TALK ABOUT SURGE
CAPACITY AND SOMETIMES WE TALK
ABOUT EFFICIENCY. AND WILL
RESULT IN SOME WAYS WE TALK
ABOUT FISSION SEE W DON'T
THINK ABOUT SURGE CAPACITY
RIGHT SO WE DON'T WANT. PEOPLE
SORT OF VIOLENCE A SITTING
AROUND ABOUT SITTING AROUND
BUT- SAYING LIKE OH WELL LOOK
WE HAVE SOME EXCESS CAPACITY.
WELL THEN THE PROBLEM IS YOU
DON'T IT'S NOT THERE DURING A
SURGE. AND WE'RE REALLY IN
TROUBLE AND WE LEARNED THAT WE
SAW THAT WITH TV WE SAW TAT
WITH OTHER TYPES OF SUPPLIES
WERE SEEN THAT WITH- YOU I AND
PEOPLE GET HURT WHEN THAT
HAPPENS. SO I HOPE THAT DOES
YOU KNOW SAID WE HAVE THE Q.
PROBLEM WE'RE DEALING WITH BUT
ALSO THAT WE'RE PLANNING FOR
LONG TERM. AND THAT WE'RE
THINKING ABOUT THAT SO AGAIN I
THANK YOU SO MUCH- THAT. FOR
YOUR INDULGENCE WILL BE WORSE
THAN US THANK YOU SENATOR PAN
AND I DON'T KNOW IF MR PANIC-
WANTED. TO COMMENT ON THAT
QUESTION ALSO. A LAB DIE AND-
ECHO. WHAT ARE PART AND SEE T.
S. IN INDEED D. THAT. THIS OF.
IS IT IS. DEFINITELY SOMETHING
THAT IS SENATOR JACKSON. ABOUT
CALIFORNIA CAN LEGION- WE HAVE
NOT NLY BEEN HISTORY EVEN IF
SHE SHOULD WE HAVE US REAL
HISTORY AND- TECHNOLOGY- AND
YES PEOPLE ARE AT THE CENTER OF
THE CALIFORNIANS ARE AT THE
CENTER. OF THAT WHAT DO THEY
NEED TO HAVE A GREAT
EXPERIENCE. THAT IS NOT JUST
FOR THE CALIFORNIANS I THINK
THAT WE TYPICALLY. LOOK AT AS
BEING THE QUOTE UNQUOTE.
MAINSTREAM IT ALSO INCLUDES THE
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE
UNDERPRIVILEGED THE
DISADVANTAGED. AND THE
CALIFORNIANS WHO NEED MORE JUST
TO BE ABLE TO ACCESS THE KINDS
OF SERVICES. THAT ARE THAT WAY.
WE NEED THEM TO BE ABLE TO
ACCESS. SO THERE'S A PART OF
THAT WHICH IS THAT WE HAVE TO
BRING- THE LENS OF EQUITY. WE
HAVE TO BRING THE LANDS OF
UNDERSTANDING AND HOW DO WE
INTEGRATE THAT INTO OUR-
TECHNOLOGY SYSTEMS. SO THAT
THEY CAN BE ACCESSED BY
EVERYBODY BUT WE CAN ACTUALLY
SERVE THEM BETTER- THERE'S ALSO
A BIG PART OF IT AND SECRETARY-
ADDRESS THIS AS- DID DIRECTOR
TOM JUST NOW. WHICH IS THAT AT
BAT THE EFFORT OF
MODERNIZATION. AND THE EFFORT
TO TRY TO GET OUR TECHNOLOGY
SYSTEMS. HOW TO BE ABLE TO BE
FLEXIBLE TO BE ADAPTABLE TO BE
RESILIENT. REQUIRES THAT WE
START LOOKING AT TECHNOLOGY
THAT MAY HAVE NOT BEEN.
CONSIDERED BEFORE HI AND WE
HAVE TO DO IT IN A DIFFERENT
WAY WITH THE CHANCE WE THINK
ABOUT PROCUREMENT THE WAY THAT
WE THINK ABOUT SCOPING
PROBLEMS. AND EVEN D. THE-
PROJECTS THAT WE END UP
CHARTERING SO THAT THEY ARE
VERY FOCUSED ON THE RIGHT
PROBLEMS- THAT CENTER JACKSON.
TALKED ABOUT THIS EARLIER THAT-
THAT THERE ARE OTHER STATE
AGENCIES THAT HAVE BEEN MOVING
FORWARD WITH THAT IDEA OF
SPECIFIC. SERVICES THAT WE CAN
PEEL OFF. AND IT WAS ONE OF THE
CONFIRMATION THAT'S THAT WE
WERE ON THE TRACK WE STRIKE.
AROUND I DO ME STAY LIKE FLOOR
IMPLY. I MEET SAY THIS IS ISSUE
AND WE THINK THAT THIS CAN HELP
ADDRESS THIS THE SOCIAL.
ADMINISTRATION IMPLEMENTING ID
ME BECAUSE IT WAS A GREAT
TECHNOLOGY THAT COULD BE USEFUL
THE VA IMPLEMENTING ID ME
BECAUSE IT'S A TECHNOLOGY THAT
COULD BE USEFUL SO WE'RE
LOOKING AT IT BOTH FROM
STANDPOINT OF THE TECHNOLOGY.
THAT NEEDS TO BE THERE BUT HOW
WE CAN REALLY SOLVE AND
ADDRESSED BOTH CALIFORNIANS
NEEDS AS WELL AS MAKE THE
SYSTEM MORE EFFICIENT AND
EFFECTIVE AS A POINTER. THANK
YOU CHAIR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND I HAVE A FEW QUESTIONS THAT
I'D LIKE TO ASK A- PROFESSOR
WITH THE RELATED TO THE STRIKE
TEAM AND- DR TONG. HOW DOES IT
MEET ID ME WORK DO. DO THEY
HAVE ACCESS TO EDIE'S- SYSTEMS
AT ALL IN THE PROCESS NO IT
DOESN'T I DO ME IS A THINK OF
IT IT'S A- A FRIEND AND- JUST A
STAND ALONE IN. OUR SYSTEM- FOR
THE PURPOSES OF- VALIDATING
INDIVIDUALS IDENTITY ONLY AND
IT DOES NOT HAVE INFORMATION-
TO THE E. B. U. Y. SYSTEM FOR
THE REST OF THE CLAIMED-
INFORMATION- SO I COULD GO INTO
A LITTLE BIT OF A- HOW THAT.
PROCESS WORKS OR EVEN IF THAT
WAS SUFFICIENT TO ADDRESS YOUR
THAT WOULD THAT WOULD BE
HELPFUL BECAUSE WHAT I'M
LOOKING AT IS WHAT- WHAT
HAPPENS IF THEY DETERMINE WHEN
THEY DO THEIR VERIFICATION THAT
THEY FIND THAT THERE'S- THERE'S
A PROBLEM WITH THE SOCIAL
SECURITY NUMBER DOESN'T MATCH
THE IDENTITY OF THE PERSON
THAT'S THERE THAT'S TRYING TO.
MAKE THIS WHAT HAPPENS AT THAT
POINT- INTO THE SHARE THAT
INFORMATION WITH ANYONE OUTSIDE
OF V. D. D. E. N. WHAT DO THEY
DO WITH THAT INFORMATION TO THE
SHERATON WITHEDT AND WHAT
ACTION IS TAKEN AFTER THAT.
RIGHT THANK YOU FOR THAT-
ADDITIONAL CONTEXT- SENATOR
HILL SO I MEAN THINK OF IT IT'S
REALLY A STEP THAT HAS STAYED
THERE THERE IS A SEPARATION OF
WHAT INFORMATION THAT THEY'RE
CHECKING AGAINST- SO BASICALLY
AS A AS AN INDIVIDUAL YOU KNOW
BRING YOUR CLAIM AND IF YOU
WANT IN THIS CASE- THE VERY
FIRST FIRST UP THEY WILL GO TO
THE EDT JUST SAY HEY I'D LIKE
TO START APPLICATION. AND FROM
THERE IT ACTUALLY TAKES DOWN TO
A OF INDEPENDENCE SIDE IF YOU
WHAT IS ACTUALLY YOU KNOW EVEN
THOUGH WAS BRANDED WITH EDT
IT'S ACTUALLY THE ID ME
PROCESS. IN CREATING A LOCKING
ACCOUNT- CITY CAN COME BACK TO
IT IF THEY DON'T FINISH THE
IDENTITY VERIFICATION PROCESS
BUT ALTHOUGH THE IDENTIFIER
SUCH AS- YOU KNOW TAKING A
PICTURE OF YOUR YOUR YOUR
DRIVER'S LICENSE TO BE UPLOADED
OR ANSWERING SOME PRESET
QUESTION TO IDENTIFY. YOU WALK
WHEN YOU AREN'T TO VERIFY YOU
ARE WHO YOU ARE IT'S ALL BEING
DONE IN THE ID ME. SYSTEM AND
THAT IT'S STAND SERVICE AS I
HAVE POINTED. THAT IT'S USED BY.
OTHER STAY ENTITY AS WELL THE
FEDERAL. AND IS WHAT WE CALL A
STANDARD SERVER OR INTO. TERM
SOFTWARE AS A SERVICE. AND THE
POOR THE END OF. TIED TO NOT
PASS. THE VERIFICATION PROCESS.
THAT INFORMATION READ WITH ME
AND EDT ACCESS TO A YOU THEY
CHOOSE TO. AND THAT INFORMATION
DOES NOT GO FURTHER INTO THE
EIGHTIES YOU HI ONLINE SYSTEM
WHICH IS WHAT THE CLAIM I WOULD
COME BACK TO YOU AND CONTINUED
TO FINISH THEIR CLAIM PROCESS-
AND WHAT TYPICALLY THAT WOULD
DO- WITH THE INDIVIDUALS THAT
DID NOT PASS THE ID
VERIFICATION. ORDER RETAINED IS
ONLY THE INFORMATION THEY HAVE
PROVIDED IT'S JUST ABOUT YOU
KNOW WHO I AM. AND THAT
INFORMATION IS NOT TO- I SHARED
WITH ANYONE ELSE AND IF HE DID
HE WANTS TO COME BACK TO THAT
INFORMATION TO SAY HEY I WANT
TO DO A MATCH TO SEE
POTENTIALLY. HOW MANY OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS ARE NOT PASSING
BECAUSE THEY WERE POTENTIALLY
FRAUDULENT CLAIMANTS AND THAT
WOULD ALLOW OR EVEN ABLE EASY
TO DO THAT FURTHER PRICE
INVESTIGATION. BY FROM AT THE
CURRENT MOMENT THAT IS NOT
SOMETHING YOU DD IS ACCESSING
BUT I JUST WANTED TO STATE
THAT- IN OTHER STATES AND
GOVERNMENT AGENCY- YOU KNOW
WHAT HAVE ACCESS TO IT IT FOR
THEIR OWN SPECIFIC DATA. ROUND
IF THAT NEEDS TO BE I SEE IN
WHICH YOU INDICATED EARLIER
THAT 30% OR 70% IS THE HERO OF
SUCCESSFULLY VERIFIED THROUGH
THE PROCESS. SO THAT LEAVES OF
ISSUE 30% THAT MAY BE AND I
THINK THE COMMENT WAS THAT
THOSE COULD BE OR COULD BE
YOU'RE PROBABLY ARE FRAUDULENT-
AND IF THAT'S THE. CASE AND-
THEN OBVIOUSLY THEY DON'T
VERIFY THERE FOR THIS IS I
GUESS. FOR THE PURPOSE AND THEY
GO IN THEY HAVE IT OR TRY TO.
LOOK FOR AND SOME OTHER WAY BUT
IF THAT'S 30% FRAUD. THE HOW
DOES THAT IF YOU EXTRAPOLATE
THAT TO THE END TO THE-
PROCESSES UP TO OCTOBER FIFTH
WHEN. I ID NEEDS STARTED- DO
HAVE WE ESTIMATED THE AMOUNT OF
FRAUD THAT COULD HAVE BEEN. IN
THE SYSTEM SINCE THAT TIME AND
I DON'T MEAN THAT TO SAY THAT I
JUST. LIVE BY LIVE IN SOUTH
SACRAMENTO. YEAH I HAVE AN ID I
DON'T LIVE IN SACRAMENTO BUT I
HAVE A PLACE IN SACRAMENTO HOME
IN SACRAMENTO AND I HAVEN'T
BEEN THERE IN A MONTH AND I
WENT AND I. JUST RECEIVED- I
HAVE PROBABLY A DOZEN LETTERS.
FROM ET DE COLD ADDRESSED TO
DIFFERENT PEOPLE- THAT LAST I
CHECKED THE LIVE IN MY HOUSE
SO- THESE SEEM TO BE A PROBLEM
I WILL GET THEM TO EAT HE
DEVOTED I DON'T THIS IS THE
INDICATION THIS IS HAPPENING
ALL OVER THE STATE. BUT IT HAS
THERE BEEN AN ESTIMATE AND I
KNOW THAT QUESTION WAS ASKED
LAST WEEK IN THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE. AN ESTIMATION AS TO
HOW MUCH FRAUD THERE IS ENOUGH
WORK ARE WE CONSIDERING 30% OF
THOSE APPLICANTS- WERE
FRAUDULENT BEFORE SO I.
PROBABLY HAVE THE BACK TO EDT
US BUT- ADDRESSED HOW MUCH
PERSON WHAT IS THE PERCENTAGE
OF CURRENT CLAIMANT. OF
CLEARING CURRENT FLAME SORRY IN
THE SYSTEM THAT MIGHT BE A
TRIBUTE TO FRAUD- BUT ON THE
NEW CLAIMS ARE COMING IN SINCE.
THE ID ME WHAT'S IMPLEMENTED I
WOULD NOT GO AS FAR AS THEY ALL
30% OF THEM ARE FRAUD BECAUSE
THERE ARE- CLOSE TO I BELIEVE
LAST TIME WE CHECKED ABOUT TWO
THOUSAND. INDIVIDUAL THAT 30%
OF CALL AND SAY HEY ARE THERE
OTHER WAYS SO THERE ARE.
LEGITIMATE CLAIM AND I JUST
NEED EXTRA HELP TO GET THROUGH-
I THINK THE LATEST ANALYSIS
THAT WE HAVE SEEN IS PROBABLY
AROUND 18220% OFF SO. THAT OUR
FULL STOP NEVER FOLLOW UP. THAT
JUST NEVER FINISH THE PROCESS
SO THOSE ARE GOOD INDICATORS.
ALTHOUGH NOT DEFINITIVE THOSE
AREN'T GOOD INDICATORS ARE
FRAUDULENT IN. ANY OF THAT HAS
ANY CORRELATION. OF THE NUMBERS
OF ATTEMPTS. FOR PEOPLE TO TRY
TO GET IN AND THE STOP OF THE-
DOOR IF THAT'S- COURT. TO MANY.
FRAUDULENT TO HAVE A MADE IT
THROUGH THE SYSTEM PRIOR TO ON
A TEAMMATE. THAT WOULD REQUIRE.
ADDITIONAL INVESTIGATION- TO BE
DONE BY EDT TO A PROVIDER
NUMBER. OKAY ANALYSTS THAT WHEN
IT WHEN I GET TO I DO HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS REDUCE ALL ASK THEM
WHEN WE GET TO BECAUSE I DID
WANT TO FOLLOW UP WITH. WITH
YOU MISS DIRECTOR TOM. A LITTLE
MORE. ON THAT- IT MAINLY THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT 18220% OF
THOSE DOLLARS IN THAT FRAUD.
YOU KNOW WHAT HOW WHY THAT'S SO
IMPORTANT AS THOSE ARE DOLLARS
THAT COULD BE USED AT SOME
POINT FOR THOSE BENEFITS THAT
THE- THOSE THAT REALLY NEED IT
AND THE RESOURCES THAT ARE
THERE FOR THOSE THAT ARE
STRUGGLING SO MUCH. I GUESS
TREE HOUSE HOW IS THE WORKING
WITH. THE DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY TO IMPLEMENT THOSE
I. T. RECOMMENDATIONS ARE
OUTLINED IN THE STRIKE TEAM
REPORT ARE THEY WORKING.
CLOSELY NOW AND. IS THAT AN
ONGOING RELATIONSHIP YES I
WOULD I WAS SAY THAT WITH
INNING GAME. OF THE STRIKE TEAM
THE RELATIONS IS TO THE DEGREE
THAT BE. THERE DEFINITELY VERY
SPECIFIC RECOMMEND. FOR AND
THEN A ROADMAP FOR EACH FOLLOW.
AND JUST AS OUR STANDARD OVER.
ROLE THAT IS SOMETHING THAT WE
NOT ONLY GOT. CONTINUE WITHOUT
INVOLVEMENT BUT WITH THE
ADDITIONAL I'M CALLING FROM-
ALREADY I. AND ALSO MAKING SURE
THAT THE RECOMMENDATION FROM
DISTRACTING REPORTS ARE BEING
CARRIED OUT- WE ARE LITERALLY
IN INTERACTION. ALMOST DAILY
BASIS AND BE AVAILABLE AND TO
BE SUPPORTIVE OF EDT IF THERE'S
QUESTIONS OR CHALLENGES ARE
BLOCKERS THAT THEY CAME IN.
WERE THERE. TO HELP THEM TO
MOVE THINGS ALONG. IF YOU THINK
YOU YOU KNOW BACKLOG WORLD
DEALING WITH IN. TO EAT D. THE
CREW THIS FOR. WITH ID MEET.
SICK TO MY AGO HAD THAT WITH ME
A SIGNIFICANT DIFFERENCE IN THE
IN THAT BACKLOG TODAY AND- AND
IN THE CLAIMS AND CERTAINLY IN
THE VERIFICATION ON THE FOR THE
FOR PERHAPS THE- REDUCTION OF
THE FRAUD I KNOW THIS QUESTION
CAME UP BEFORE AND I WOULD SAY
DIED- BASED ON AND THEY
APPROACH- PERHAPS DIED. YOU
KNOW SOMEBODY SAY HEY WOULD
HAVE THIS IMPLEMENT EARLIER
WITHOUT MAKE UP THE DIFFERENCE
WHAT I CAN RESPOND TO- SENATOR
HILL IS THE FACT THAT. THIS WAS
VERY MUCH THIS RECOMMENDATION
FIRST OF ALL TO DO IT IDENTITY
VERIFICATION AUTOMATION IS VERY
MUCH BASED ON THE- US TEAMS
ASSESS. AND THERE WAS GOOD
DATA- AND FROM YOU KNOW
OBSERVATION IN TALKING TO YOU
KNOW A GOOD EDT STAFFER IN
THEIR EXPERIENCE IN PROCESSING
CLAIMS AND LOOKING AT WHERE THE
BIGGEST BOTTLENECK IS. AND IT
WAS THROUGH THAT DATA IT WAS
VALIDATED BUT THE BIGGEST
BOTTLENECK AT THE VERY VERY
FIRST IF THAT ENTITY
VERIFICATION AND BECAUSE OF
THAT. THE AUTOMATION WAS
RECOMMENDED. OKAY IT I GUESS IN
IN THE REALLY THE LAST QUESTION
I GUESS THE PART DO YOU SEE
THIS IN IN WA IN A YEAR FROM
NOW. HOW DO YOU EXPECT EDT OR
WHERE WOULD YOU EXPECT THEM TO
BE RELATED TO. VERIFICATIONS IT
RELATED TO ALL OF THE ISSUES
THAT THE STRIKE TEAM WAS.
LOOKING TO IMPLEMENT A
SPECIALLY RELATED TO TECHNOLOGY.
I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO AND- YOU
KNOW WERE WERE VERY MUCH
CONTINUED DOWN THE ROLE OF-
HELPING THE DEPARTMENT THE
CHANCE FORM FOR MULTIPLE LEVEL
RIGHT TECHNOLOGY BEING ONE
ASPECT OF IT BUT THE BUTTHE
POLICY THE OPERATION THE
PROCEDURE SIDE OF IT ALSO NEED
TO BE. REVISITED THE STRIKING
REPORTER HAVE STRIKE THAT
BALANCE OF RECOGNIZING THE
MODERNIZATION IS NOT PURELY IN
TECHNOLOGY AND THEREFORE. A
VERY SLOW SYNC A ROADMAP. FOR
EASTER FOLLOW IN TERM OF
LOOKING THERE AT WEIGHTS OF A
TRANSFORMATION. AND LOOKING A
YEAR DOWN THE ROLE- AS I
MENTIONED EARLIER THE
DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGY WILL
CONTINUE TO ENGAGE. AND NOW
WITH THE ADDITION OF OFFICE OF
DIGITAL INNOVATION WOULD HELP
WITH THAT TYPE OF HUMAN
CENTERED DESIGN. AND WE ARE
VERY HOPEFUL AND THAT WE ARE
COMMITTED TO- TO MAKE SURE THAT
YOU D. D. IT'S ON A PATH OF
SUCCESS. GOOD YOU. IN OUR TO GO
TO THE PANEL JUST QUESTION FOR
THE EMPLOYER PANEL THAT WE HAVE
WHICH IS- AND AGAIN I WANT TO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
COMMITMENT AND THE DEDICATION
AND AS I MENTIONED EARLIER AND
IT'S LIKE MY COLLEAGUES HAVE.
INDICATED THAT THE DISTRICT
OFFICES THAT WE ALL HAVE IN
THIS DESTRUCTIVE THAT OUR
EMPLOYEES AND OUR STAFF MEMBERS
HAVE HAD DEALING WITH THE
CONSTITUENTS IN THE PAIN THAT
THEY'RE GOING THROUGH AND THE
SUFFERING. WE JUST CAN'T
IMAGINE HOW DIFFICULT THAT IS
FOR YOU. AND FOR THE TIME THAT
YOU SPENT- WORKING WITH. WITH
THOSE CONSTITUENTS IN THOSE-
THOSE APPLICANTS WHO ARE
DESPERATELY IN NEED SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT. A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS AND- IS DO
YOU FEEL. DO YOU FEEL AS IF-
EDT MANAGEMENT LISTENS TO. TO
WHAT THE WORKERS REPORT AND
IMPLEMENTS REFORMS TO MAKE YOUR
JOB EASIER ARE THEY LISTENING
AND MAKING THE CHANGES THAT ARE
NECESSARY TO FIND THAT TO BE
THE CASE. ANYONE CAN AT ANY
TIME WELL THIS IS I MEAN GREEN.
I WOULD LIKE TO ACTUALLY TAKE A
STAB AT THAT YES- MOST PART
MANAGEMENT IS LISTENING AND
MAKING SURE THAT OUR NEEDS ARE
BEING MET- THAT THEY ARE TAKING
EVERY- ASPECT IN EVERY
STATEMENT THAT WE MAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION- IT IS EVIDENT
AND WHAT- THIS TOM JUST
MENTIONED IS THAT THE STRIKE
TEAM TOOK MANY OF THE COMMENTS
THAT WERE MADE- AND USE THEM TO
CONSIDER THEY ARE- ASSESSMENT
AND RECOMMENDATIONS. AND SO YES
WE ARE BEING LISTENED TO ME ARE
BEING HEARD- WE ARE BEING
VALUED I. HOPE AND- WE CAN TO
BE. IN THIS PROCESS R. D. IT
INTO TO LAST IF YOU WILL AS WE
MOVE ON IT COULD WITH THIS
NATION IN YOU KNOW GETTING NOT
ONLY J. THE IMMEDIATE ASPECT OF
WHAT WE NEED TO DO IN ORDER TO
GET TO THIS GOD AND- YOU'RE
ASKING ME. ARE POPPING A
PROCEDURE AND I JUST. MORE
TECHNOLOGY THAT THEY ACTUALLY
INCLUDED IN THAT PROCESS AS
THEY DID WHEN WE WERE MEETING
WITH THE. STRIKE TEAM. THANK
YOU WISH ME ANY OTHER. COMMENTS
ON THAT FROM. MISS WILLOW.
BEFORE WELL TO A TAKE THAT
BECAUSE I THINK THAT'S THE
CHERRY VERY HELPFUL AND ALL ONE
OF THE THINGS TEAM REPORT SHE
THE DVDS HAVE DIFFICULT
ACCESSING TRANSFER SIR FOR NON
ENGLISH SPEAKING CLAIMANTS IS
THAT SHE HAS THAT BEEN YOUR
EXPERIENCE. AND WHAT WOULD YOU
THINK IF HE COULD DO TO IMPROVE
ACCESS TO TRANSLATION SERVICES.
SPEAKING FROM MY EXPERIENCE DDD
HAS PROVIDED A TRANSLATION
SERVICE BUT WE DO HAVE ACCESS
TO IF WE DO NEED TO PROVIDE
THAT ADDITIONAL SERVICE TO THE
CITIZENS WERE SERVING
CALIFORNIA- WE DO UTILIZE THAT
I MYSELF HAVE UTILIZED IT IT'S
A VERY GOOD PROCESS- AND I'M
ABLE TO SET UP A CONVERSATION
WITH THE CLAIMS THAT I AM SORRY
ABLE TO PROVIDE RESULTS IN-
RESOLVE THEIR ISSUES THAT THEY
HAVE IN ADDITION TO THAT WE
HAVE A NUMBER OF PEOPLE THAT-
BACK TO WORK. CALIFORNIA AND
THE D. D. THAT ALSO PROVIDE-
LANGUAGE FROM ASSISTANCE AND
THEY DO THAT OUT OF THE
GOODNESS OF THEIR HEART AND
ALSO ADDED THE ABILITY TO HELP
SERVE OUR CALIFORNIANS SO YES
WE ARE ACTUALLY- MEETING THAT
CRITERIA MEANING THAT-
ESTABLISHMENT IN ORDER TO GET
TAKEN SEVERAL LANGUAGES-
ANSWERED- COULD BE DOING MORE
OF COURSE I MEAN AS AS WE KNOW
THE CANDIDATE HAS HIGHLIGHTED.
A NUMBER OF THINGS- THAT EDT
CAN IMPROVE ON THIS IS. MOST
LIKELY ONE OF THE- THANK YOU
MISS. THIS IS GOING ON OKAY
JUST WANTED TO WE HAVE BY LEE
STUFF. HELLO AND SO OFTEN TIMES
WHEN COME THANK BE TO MY- STUFF.
IN THE PARTICULAR THE DAY COULD
THE CLAIMANT HAS REACHED I'M IN
SAN FRANCISCO HAVE TRY. NOW
CANTONESE SPAN. AND TAGALOG FOR
X. THANK YOU. TWO ONE. TWO IS
THERE ANYTHING THAT YOU SEE
THAT THE UNITY KERR DO ROOM THE
AT ALL I MAY HAVE THE- ARE ARE
THE GETS A THE MICHIGAN THAT
THE NOT. ERIC OR WE NEED TO. IT
BE FRESH. FOR THE CLAIM IS IN
THEY- DON'T MOVE WITH FOR SURE
THEIR CLAIM BECAUSE OF THAT IF
YOU EXPERIENCE ANY OF THAT. I
THINK THERE IS A LOT OF LIKE WE
GET A LOT OF CHINESE KOLS. TO
OUR SWITCHBOARD AND WE DO THE
BEST WE CAN- THERE'S A PROTOCOL
FOR IF. SOMEONE IS INTERPRETING
FOR A CLIENT WHO'S WITH THE
CLAIMANT WE HAVE TO DO A
CERTAIN AMOUNT UNTIL LIKE
CARBONATED UNIFICATION KEPT
VERBAL APPROVAL. BUT I'D SAY.
THE VOLUME OF CALLS AT LEAST IN
THE SAN FRANCISCO OFFICE AT THE
SWITCHBOARD WE GET EXCEEDS OUR
CAPACITY CONSIDERABLY SO IT'S A
GOOD THING THERE IS AN
ADDITIONAL SERVICE- THE WE NOW
HAVE CONTRACTED TO DO THAT
BECAUSE I DON'T THINK WE HAVE
THE CAPACITY THE BILINGUAL
CAPACITY NEEDED ON THE STOVE
JUST FROM THIS VERY SORT OF.
LOCALIZED OFFICE EXPERIENCE.
THANK YOU IT IS ONE FOUR
QUESTION FOR ART. GREAT USUAL
THIS IT'LL BE ON A RE. ARE
THERE ANY CHANGES OR REFORMS
YOU WOULD LIKE TO SEE-
IMPLEMENTED E. D. D. THAT'S NOT
BEING IMPLEMENTED TODAY. I
WOULD LIKE TO TAKE OPPORTUNITY
THIS IS GREEN AGAIN TO SAY THAT
THERE ARE PERSONALLY AND NUMBER
OF CHANGES THAT I WOULD LOVE TO
SEE IT ON A STEWARD FOR SEIU I
AM ONE OF THEIR FRONT LINE
PEOPLE THEY GET TO HEAR
COMMENTS AND CONCERNS FROM
FELLOW COWORKERS- SEEING AS
THIS IS AN OPEN- I WOULD LIKE
TO. EXTEND THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SAY THAT YES- ANY OF THE PANEL
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK WITH ME
PERSONALLY ABOUT WHAT THOSE ARE
I WOULD BE MORE THAN HAPPY TO
HAVE THAT ONE ON ONE
CONVERSATION- BUT GOING BACK TO
THE JOB AS A WHOLE WHAT WE ARE
CURRENTLY DOING IS GOING TO
HELP TREMENDOUSLY- WITH OUR
ABILITY TO SERVICE- THEN CLEAN.
WE ARE ACTUALLY PROVIDING
SERVICE TO- AND SO IF WE
CONTINUE ON THIS PATH THEY
CONTINUE TO MOVE THROUGH- THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT THE STRIKE
TEAM HAS PUT IN PLACE AND WILL
BE ON HAND- I BELIEVE THAT OUR
JOBS WILL CONTINUE TO NOT ONLY
BE- MORE SUCCESSFUL AT
PROVIDING THE ASSISTANCE THAT
WE NEED BUT ALSO BE MORE- I
GUESS BENEFICIAL HARMONY FOR US
IN ORDER TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE SUCCEEDING IN. OUR JOBS.
OKAY THANK YOU JOHN TARA. HOME
WHEN YOU TAKE. TASK IN THE
MANAGEMENT ON THE- OF ID SO I
YOU KNOW PROCESS HUNT OF. C. B.
T. CLEAN BROUGHT TO APPLE. AND
THE LOST WEAKER BE WE HAD THE
AS I WAS. THEM ABOUT NINETEEN
OUT OF TWENTY WE'RE NOT.
FRAUDULENT BASICALLY THERE ARE
CERTAIN IN DC- FRAUD THAT YOU
CAN SEE WHEN YOU'VE BEEN DOING
IT LONG ENOUGH LIKE YOU KNOW
OUT OF STATE ADDRESS WITH THE
INSTATE MAILING ADDRESS NO
DRIVER'S LICENSE AND SO ON. AND
SORRY IF I HAD ONE IN TWENTY
THAT WERE ACTUALLY POTENTIALLY
VALID THAT WAS A GOOD NUMBER
AGAIN THIS WAS JUST BEFORE THE
RESET SO I THINK THE FACT THAT
THE- ID ME SYSTEM IS SET UP.
YOU KNOW YOU WOULD SOMETIMES
TAKE A LOOK IN THERE BE LIKE
TEN DIFFERENT APPLICATIONS
UNDER THE SAME SOCIAL SECURITY
NUMBER WITH DIFFERENT ADDRESSES
IN DIFFERENT NAMES AND SO
CLEARLY THERE IS. A I THINK
THE- A PROGRAM WITH INCENTIVES
LUCINDA IDENTITY VERIFICATION
PROCESS SEES IN YOU KNOW WE'LL
LIKE MONEY RIGHT SO AND FREE
MONEY IS EVEN BETTER INSTEAD
PEOPLE WORKED SAID OF USING. A
CRACK IN THE SYSTEM TO SEE IF.
THEY COULD WIN THE POOL A LOT
OF. AND I THINK I ME WILL TAKE
CARE THAT FOR THEM VERY GOOD
THANK YOU. BUT AGAIN THANK YOU
VERY MUCH TO OUR EMPLOYEES. FOR
FEATURE. TESTIMONY TODAY NOW A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS FOR THE EDT
MANAGEMENT PANEL. OF A NEW
PURGE THE STRIKE TEAM COMMENTS
YOU'VE HEARD THE EMPLOYEE
COMMENTS- HE DO YOU HAVE ANY
ANY RESPONSE TO SOME OF THE
ISSUES THAT WERE RAISED AND
PRESSURED TO RESPOND TO MY
QUESTION EARLIER RELATED. TO
THE TO THE FRAUD QUESTION.
SENATOR NANCY FARIAS NON WITH
WITH HIGH BUT THE ON. SO IT THE
FRAUD QUESTION HI I WOULD DEFER
TO DIRECTOR TOM ON THAT I JUST
ADD TO IS FAR AS YOU KNOW WHAT
PERCENTAGES FRAUD- WE DO LOOK
AT- YOU KNOW THOSE WHO MAY NOT
VERIFY THEIR IDENTITY SO IF YOU
KNOW THAT IS SORT OF A CLEAR
CASE OF SOMEONE DOESN'T WANT TO
WRITE YOU KNOW VERIFY THEIR
IDENTITY THAT IT COULD BE
FRAUD. THEY'RE CERTAINLY NOT
IT'S CERTAINLY NOT ALL FRAUD-
BUT YOU KNOW SO AS FAR AS WHAT
THE PERCENTAGES I AM I AM I CAN
SEE IF WE HAVE THAT NUMBER AND
CERTAINLY GET BACK TO YOU ON
THAT BECAUSE THAT'S IT. IT'S A
GOOD QUESTION. AS FAR AS
RESPONDING TO THAT THE PREVIOUS
PANEL- YOU KNOW THE SPECIFICS
YOU. I DON'T I'M NOT GOING TO
RESPOND TO THE SPECIFICS I
WOULD JUST AND LESS YOU KNOW
LESS THERE'S A SPECIFIC
QUESTION BUT I WOULD JUST SAY
THAT. AS I MENTIONED IN MY
OPENING REMARKS THAT IT IS SO
IMPORTANT TO HEAR FROM THE
EMPLOYEES THAT ARE WORKING THE
PHONE LINES THE CASES THAT THE
U. I. CASES IT'S SO IMPORTANT
TO HEAR FROM THEM AND TO REALLY
LISTEN TO WHAT THEY'RE SAYING
AND TO TAKE THAT BACK WHEN WE
ARE TRYING TO MOVE FORWARD-
THAT IS TRULY I BELIEVE THE
ONLY WAY THAT WE CAN MOVE
FORWARD AND MY INTENTION AND I
KNOW MY COLLEAGUES. ON MY PANEL
THAT THAT IS ALSO THEIR
INTENTION IS TO IS TO DO THAT
AND I PERSONALLY LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING YOU KNOW WITH- JOHN
AND JOYCE AND MISS- MISS IRENE-
IN THE FUTURE. WHAT THAT'S GOOD
GOOD HEAR THE- HERE THE ISSUE
OF ME ID SEEMS TO BE. OF
SOMETHING THAT THE END AND IT
IS IT WAS MENTIONED IT'S ALSO
UTILIZED IN OTHER. DEPARTMENTS
OTHER OTHER AREAS OF THE STATE-
AND IT SEEMS LIKE SOMETHING
THAT SHOULD HAVE BEEN IN PLACE
EVEN BEFORE COVERT. AS A MEANS
TO EXPEDITE CLAIMS AND TRY TO
OFFICIALLY VERIFIED VIA THE
CLAIMANTS. WHY WAS THAT NOT
DONE EARLIER AND WHY WAS THERE
NO VERIFICATION SYSTEM IN PLACE
BEFORE. DON'T NEED THE VARIOUS-
WITH YOU T. CELL I I'M NOT. YOU
GET TO THAT QUESTION. I KNOW
IT'S A TOUGH ONE AND ESPECIALLY
AFTER THREE WEEKS IN A ROW FOR
YEAH I MEAN I'M I'M NOT SURE IF.
SOMEONE ELSE IS THAT CAN ANSWER
THAT QUESTION BUT I'M CERTAIN
THAT IT'S BEEN. WHEN ASKED I'M
SURE IF. A BOILERS AND IN THE
OTHER THING IT WITH. HAVE
CERTAINLY EMPLOYERS. I WOULD
THINK THEY COULD BE USED TO
HELP AND AN AGENCY OF THE
VERIFICATION OF INDIVIDUALS
HAVE THAT BEEN THOUGHT OF
BEFORE OR SET IT TO USED IN THE
QUEUE TO BE USED OR COULD BE
USED IN THE FUTURE OR NOW THAT
WE HAVE ANY ID THAT
VERIFICATION ISSUE HAS BEEN
RESOLVED. SERVICE CENTER IT'S A
DIET THAT NIGHT FROM ODI ALL. A
START WITH AND THEN PROSECUTE
WILLIAMS FREIGHT THANK YOU HI.
EDT CAN FOLLOW UP WITH THAT
WHICH IS THAT- THAT- I THINK D.
CAN THE CATION AND SORT OF.
DEEP COOPERATION WITH EMPLOYERS
AS VITAL TO ADD TO. YOU I'D BE
ABLE TO BE SUCCESSFUL AND I
THINK WE'RE EXPLORING ALL OF
THOSE OPPORTUNITIES AS WE GET
INTO THE MODERNIZATION. OF EDT
I THINK THAT THERE ARE- THERE
ARE DEFINITELY GOING TO BE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR US TO BETTER
USE OF DATA- THAT IS THAT ARE
COMING FROM EMPLOYERS- THAT CAN
BE. INTEGRATED INTO THE EDT
SYSTEM SO THERE'S DEFINITELY
SOME POSSIBILITIES. IT IS
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT
RIGHT NOW AS PART OF LOOKING AT
THE OVERALL CLAIMS EXPERIENCE.
CAROL HE DIED OF TOOK AGREE. AS
WE CAN TO FORWARD WE'RE OPEN AT
WORK WITH ANYBODY THAT CAN HELP
US EXPEDITE ALL BENEFITS
WHETHER THAT'S EMPLOYERS THAT'S
FANTASTIC WEATHER THAT'S OTHER
DEPARTMENTS SHARING DATA WE'RE
ESSENTIALLY ALL IN. FROM WHAT
WE'VE BEEN EXPERIENCING TO THE
STATE- HAS BEEN THE- WHAT I DO
ME HAS HELPED US REVOLUTIONIZED
SO YES IT'S TAKING CARE OF THE
LARGEST OBSTACLE THAT WE WERE
EXPERIENCING AND PAYING OUT THE
CLAIMS AND AS WAS MENTIONED
EARLIER THAT WAS DIRECTOR
TONGUE AND- DIE AT. THE REST OF
OUR WORK EDT IS TO CONTINUE TO
REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF TOUCHES ON
THE LINE OF WORK IF IT CAN BE
AUTOMATED AND THAT'S THE NEW
DATA. NEW COLLABORATION-
PARTNERSHIPS BECAUSE THAT'S
WHAT FINALLY NOW IS REALLY THAT
THE HARD WORK AND THAT'S
REMAINING FOUR EDT TO DO. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. OF MY FINAL
QUESTION IS EVEN OUR
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT HE D. D.
WILL RELEASE A FULL TIME LINE
OF THE- IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
TWO FOR THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE TASK FORCE RECOMMENDATIONS
BY THE END OF THIS MONTH. IS
THAT STILL PART OF THE TIME
LINE THAT YOU. EXPECT TO BE
ABLE TO MEET AND- WHEN WILL THE
COMMITTEE BE ABLE TO GET THAT.
ABSOLUTELY WE COMMITTED LAST
WEEK TO THE ASSEMBLY THAT WE
RELEASED THE FULL STRIKE TEAM
REPORT WITH FINAL TIMELINES
ASSIGNMENTS ANNEX ESTIMATED
COMPLETION DATES AND SO WE
CERTAINLY WILL COUNT AS A
COMPANION DELIVER THAT TO THE
SENATE AS WELL. YOU'RE GOOD
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- I HAVE.
OVER THE QUESTIONS AND I SEE
NONE HERE SO WE WILL NOW MOVE
TO THE- ANYONE FROM THE- PUBLIC
WHO WOULD LIKE TO MAKE A
COMMENT SO DUE TO THE
CONSTRAINTS. REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF HEARINGS IT. DATE AND-
CONSIDER. AND CLEANING
PROTOCOLS WE WILL NEED TO PLACE
TIME LIMITS ON PUBLIC
TESTIMONY. FOR NOW I WANT TO
GET STARTED SO WE CAN HEAR FROM
AS MANY PEOPLE AS POSSIBLE. I
WILL BEGIN WITH WITNESSES HERE
IN ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE I
SEE. ONE HERE WISHING TO SPEAK
WITH ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE WHO WISH TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT I SEE NO
ONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE AS WELL
SO- THANK YOU WE WILL NOW MOVE
ON TO THE WITNESSES WAITING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS. MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE PROMPT THE
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT WE WILL BEGIN.
AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT YOU CAN PRESS
THE ONE THAT THEN PHARAOH NOW.
AN OPERATOR WILL GIVE YOU A
LINE NUMBER AND PRAY THAT AND
THEN WE'LL CALLYOU BY LINE
NUMBER AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
MAKE A COMMENT. AT THE ONE THEN.
ZERO AND AT THE MOMENT. THERE
IS NO ONE IN THE QUEUE. WHO
WOULD YOU UP WHERE MORE TIME
PLEASE. YES AND AGAIN LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
MAKE A COMMENT PRESS THE ONE
THEN ZERO AGAIN WHY NOT THEN.
ZERO I SHOW NO ONE IN THE KIA
VERY GOOD THANK YOU MODERATOR
APPRECIATE THE GOOD WORK- SO
WE'VE HEARD OF ALL OF THE
TESTIMONY TODAY AND- I WANT TO
CONCLUDE BY THANKING THE
PANELISTS VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION TODAY AND- AND
YOUR COMMITMENT TO. THE
IMPROVEMENTS THAT WE'VE SEEN
COMING TO EDT IT'S CLEAR THAT
WE HAVE A LONG WAY TO GO TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THOSE ISSUES
AND THE CHALLENGES THAT ARE
FACED WITH BUT IT'S EQUALLY
CLEAR. THAT WE'D BE GONE THAT
LONG PROCESS AND APPRECIATE THE
STATE APPRECIATE THE TASK FOR
THE STRIKE TEAM IN THE
GOVERNOR'S COMMITMENT TO MAKING
THIS HAPPEN AND ALL OF THE GOOD
EMPLOYEES THOSE THOUSANDS THAT
ARE WORKING EVERY DAY- SEVEN
DAYS A WEEK AT EDDY D. D. THIS
IS REALLY WHAT THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA DEMAND OF US. AND IT
IS THEIR RIGHT TO DO SO IT'S
WELL PAST TIME FOR EDT TO BEGIN
THE DIFFICULT BUT NECESSARY
CULTURAL CHANGES TO BRING OUR
BENEFIT DELIVERY SYSTEMS INTO
THE TWENTY FIRST CENTURY SO I
LOOK FORWARD TO THAT PROCESS
COMING TO FRUITION. IN THE
MONTHS TO COME- ADDITIONALLY I
WANT TO THANK- ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO- WHO WHO HAVE
PARTICIPATED TODAY AND- IF YOU
HAVE NOT AND WANT TO COMMIT TO
WANT TO SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS.
OR SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON LABOR
PUBLIC GROUP IN PLYMOUTH AND
RETIREMENT OR VISIT TO VISIT
OUR WEBSITE TO DO THAT YOUR
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS ARE
IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT TO
INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE
FISHEL HEARING RECORDS THANK
YOU. WE APPRECIATE THAT
PARTICIPATION I THANK YOU FOR
EVERYONE FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION TODAY- I DO WANT TO
THANK YOU SPECIFICALLY- TODAY
BEFORE WE CONCLUDE THE GREAT
STAFF HERE THE I. T. STAFF HERE
IN THE SENATE WHO HAVE BEEN
EXTRAORDINARY OVER THESE LAST
FEW MONTHS- THAT SPEAK BEYOND
ANYTHING THAT I THINK IS
IMAGINABLE THAT THEY COULD PUT
THIS TOGETHER SO QUICKLY INTO
SUCCESSFULLY. I WANT TO THANK-
GIDEON BOMB THE STAFF DIRECTOR
OF OR SENATOR COULD. ON LABOR
AND PUBLIC AND RETIREMENT AND
ALMA FOR A SHRUB THE PRINCIPAL
CONSULTANT ALSO IN THE
COMMITTEE. THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO
HAVE MADE THIS HAPPEN THIS YEAR
AND LAST YEAR AND I'M GRATEFUL
TRULY GRATEFUL FOR THEIR HARD
WORK. TEN MILES EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR AND THE PURGE
CONSULTANT- JAKE FOR ARAP
CONSULTANT AND MARTHA GOOD
CHERISH OUR COMMITTEE COMMITTEE
ASSISTANCE FOR HER GREAT WORK
AND- AND I CAN'T COMPLETE TODAY
IN OUR COMMITTEE WITHOUT
THANKING THE GREAT BERNIE
MCNULTY. AND PATTY HANSON FOR
THEIR CONTINUED GREAT WORK ON
PROVIDING THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
ALL OF US TO HAVE THESE
COMMITTEES. IN THESE A TRUE
TIME SURE THANK YOU FOR THAT
THAT. THE BUSINESS OF THIS
COMMITTEE WE ARE ADJOURNED.